e
we need for today or at least the first
one all right so we'll open up the work
session um
on House Bill
1394 relative to lure and regulation of
Music
therapist this went before Edna came out
of their committee uh without a
recommendation then it went to the house
floor ought to pass as
amended on the 22nd of February and the
vote was 194 to
186 so pretty close um someone here like
to speak to the
bill seeing none um anybody on the
division wish to speak to a
representative
McGuire thank you Mr chairman so um I'm
I'm against this for the reasons I Carol
was the main person who argued against
this on the floor and I'm I'm against it
for those those reasons that she
articulated but I do happen to have
an you know we're starting to think this
may be un stoppable so um so I I do have
an amendment because if you look at the
fiscal note um this spends $70,000 a
year because they want oplc wants to
hire a new uh
employee but but strictly speaking that
particular
employee is not necessary for
specifically for music therapists
because there's only 30 music therapists
and they're only going to charge them
$150 every two years for their license
fee so we're talking
about $4,500 every two years or
something like that right and so um so
what this amendment would
do is reduce the budget by not having
that particular employee but but
allocating to them
$33,000 in their annual budget for
temporary or part-time uh help now um
representative cell had the idea maybe
we should also we could also say um
overtime in addition to that I don't
know um Melissa if if we is that the
same line item or is it we'd have to
pick one or how would that work we can
just add it into the bill and then they
can put it during the um dur during the
budget and they can allocate where they
think it needs to so do you want to
change this to add or overtime I don't
know represent cams
any
okay yeah yeah just add that to the list
how about that Melissa
okay are there any questions or
represented grassy I don't exactly have
a question I think that that probably
adding overtime would be fine to to this
as well um having worked in special
education I see a value in in having
this because I know that and and I
worked as an art therapist but you
couldn't build and that was part of the
problem is is being able to Bill uh
Medicaid or Medicare for these Services
um
and if you can't bill a lot of times you
just don't provide the service
unfortunately because you don't have
enough time in the day and and as a
special ed provider I know that they
were looking at every minute of the day
that you work you had to account for so
that they could get reimbursements for
it um because it's it's it's additional
cost to for special needs children in
our districts uh so I would support this
I I don't know why we didn't put art
therapists with it as well because it's
certainly something that is is used and
was used very effectively in my
experiences I'm not sure if art
therapists are already licensed or not
yeah okay more discussion on
representative Maguire's
Amendment so are we okay with adding
overtime as representative cambrell has
suggested that's fine just to show a
hands at support of the
amendment unanimous
um we can take that up as a final next
week we'll just bring it in as corrected
yeah you have two options because this
is division one you can just vote on it
as amended um with adding the overtime
you don't have to have the amendment in
front of you to vote on it so you could
vote on the bill if you wanted or clear
the plate sure so representative Maguire
we going to move your Amendment okay and
it's seconded by represented
Griffin yeah and then we'll get the
corrected book so it
gets well the bill is
amended
yeah yeah oh I'm not moving that one
you're not no somebody representative
grassy can
okaya otpa grassy Griffin I got fill in
the
blank the
am 101
9h there will be a new number a new
number it'll have a different number and
then representative
gr okay does someone like to Second
represent grass's
Amendment yeah
it's
repres C cell
seconds now that we're all clear on that
when the clerk is ready yes I'm gonna
write in chair wier's name right here so
I won't
forget he at the top
very okay all right we're rep we're
voting otpa on House Bill um
1394 uh with the amendment
101h that will be amended to include
part-time subsequently it's overtime
overtime I 1019 H right I got it
right I understand okay just one
second takes us a while to get going
here as well okay representative Maguire
no representative Griffin no
representative Sweeney no representative
camell yes representative Wier chair
Wier uh chair I mean the clerk votes yes
representative hwit yes representative
grassy yes and chair leean yes okay so
it is one two three four five six to
three the motion passes six to
three so I have a 15 minutes so I have a
so I have a question for representative
McGuire you brought the amendment
forward but you voted against it so I
just kind of curious on your said I I I
said I was going to do all right I just
because I'm against the bill but I'm
also against spending $70,000 right so
[Laughter]
it's now we're only going to spend 3,000
so
well well while we have a minute I just
thought i' give that's why the vote was
close right
some who seconded the amendment
Jose yeah
yeah all right um so while we have a
minute I just I'd update the division on
uh Bill reform as you know we had a
meeting last week there was a lot of
discussion there was a little confusion
because some of the uh as the clerk said
if you pull a string out of one the
whole thing would come apart so uh what
I have done is I sat down with Mr
Hoffman uh and we're going to
consolidate all the bills into one so
it' be easier to deal with so the U LBA
can put together a better fiscal note
because we had competing fiscal notes
and they didn't jive with each other you
know some of the bills said we had
magistrates but didn't fund them others
said we funded them but didn't give what
their roles were so uh Within the next
couple of days we'll have a a bill that
combines everything and we'll take it up
next Wednesday when we come we'll be me
meeting next Wednesday whatever date
that is the 20th I think can can I
suggest something yes sure we have so
along those lines you remember last week
uh we we acted on I think um where was
the judicial one judicial training House
Bill
105 I believe we passed at
otpa and and I had an idea about that
one because these bail bills want to
train um uh bail Commissioners better
right so if you remember what we did
with judicial training we hired the
coordinator but we delayed it until the
next budget so so I would think maybe we
could fold that one in and hire the ba
the the training person right away and
say okay your first job is bail
Commissioners right um and that way it
kicks it off gets it rolling faster
so yeah we can take a look at that okay
is that what about no but I was going to
just mention that but but um so I don't
know if it's necessary for us to like
reconsider you
know what we did or just we
as long as we don't execute in the full
committee next week then we're okay
unless we do it in the context of our
review of the bill yeah that seems like
it make S yeah let's we'll pull that up
because under this
suggestion what we did last week I want
to undo or you know not do
something all right so we'll take a look
at U we have a minute does anyone have a
copy of the do you have HB one05 in
front of you
yeah
is the
amendment yeah the amendment was a
replace all
so
so what I'm proposing now is that yeah
because you had an amendment that we
voted on yes and that we we did it we
916 yeah I think it was unanimous so
[Music]
um they left it as shell in the
amendment yeah yeah but but um so so my
thought was to the list of things that
the coordinator does is provide judges
administrators Court staff Etc add bail
Commissioners
um and then change the effective date
back to 60 days after passage or
something like that
so because I believe in one of the bail
reform
bills there is a requirement for
training for bail Commissioners
so right so we could just
say itl or interim study this bill and
put all this language into your combined
thing all right pleasure of the
division to me it just makes more I'm
sorry no go ahead represent you to me it
just makes more sense to look at it I I
think it's a good idea but it seems to
me like we should do it in the context
of the bail
report I'm not sure any of us has
thought enough about we don't have to
make a decision now but I I I think this
is a good thing regardless of what we do
with bail reform that the bail
Commissioners get training and having
this trainer out there I think is this
is just the first step and I think this
should be done regardless of whatever
else we do as far as bail reform is
concerned this training needs to be done
and that's been the problem with bail
reform up to this point is that the
Commissioners have received no training
so in frustrating so in House Bill 318
it does call for Bill commissioner
training yeah already that so in a sense
these two bills are redundant now
because what criminal justice did with
318 they totally gutted the bill there's
training in there there's a fee increase
in there um so there's probably a little
redundant with
105 only
if they probably don't have a training
coordinator that also does judges and
yeah that's the thing and and and and
you know what if that bill doesn't
pass that's a good point you know the
thing is having two bills out there that
do the training and this is I think it's
a little more geared towards the
training side of it that we should move
this one along and then if they both get
there that's
fine so but this sets up that position
for training yeah I mean it's not in
Conflict to just say they'll have
training no but you don't hire a person
right yeah but this is the bill with the
person oh you took it I was wondering I
mean I suppose we could hold this off
and do and merge it into the other two B
you know all the other bills at the same
time that would be one of the other Pro
situations we do but this one could be
done separately without affecting the
merging of the other bills right and I'm
not sure the prime sponsors
would necessarily want their bill to on
training to live or die on the what
happens to bail reform right right so
yeah uh so okay so why don't we my
suggestion just change the amend the
amendment that uh 916 AG to add those
two things right change the effective
date back to what it used to be which I
think was 60 days and add bail
Commissioners to the to the U what the
judicial training coordinator is
responsible
for all right more comments from the
division representative sweee you're
okay what does representative yout think
about this and this something that he
dealt with
intimately you want to use
your thank
you
um grainy of course is the is the the
big issue as far as everybody is
concerned because uh there was there
been a lack of it for years and years
and years in the the superior court was
a little bit better because they had
regular meetings the whole court and
they would include some sort of uh
unofficial training in with their
meetings uh the place where the training
was most needed was in the district and
municipal courts and they didn't have
any I think that for 10 or 15 years I
was the only place in in the state that
had regular training sessions for bail
Commissioners and I said with some
nights I would have 10 15 bail
Commissioners most most of them not
coming from lonia they came from all
over the state uh to hear what what was
going on and in inevitably there was a
lot going on on because the legislature
was in
session that's a very dangerous
thing and the legislature would change
this statute and the next statute and
come come about oh we had these these
sessions like in October and people
suddenly find out they' were doing the
wrong thing for nine months oh so yeah
train training is
crucial uh as I said I wouldn't worry
that much about this it's very for um
but as far as
the now I don't they follow yeah still
bail commission bail commission is in
The District Court District Municipal
type Court setting that's critical and
circuit that's
[Laughter]
circuit that's the wages of getting
old okay
all
right
oh
TR I don't think they
did eight
hours
so it just have a
coordinator
yep he's watching right now and he'll
also have representative Maguire's
Amendment this
afternoon I've got a bill that's in
another committee and I'm sort of
keeping track of where they are so I may
Le here
quickly
Lu
so now we'll open the work session on
House Bill
1577 relative to digital images of
ballot and this is another one that came
out without recommend recation from the
committee election law it passed on the
house FL
otpa 193 to 182 back on the 22nd of
February so is there anybody
here yes we do it it seems it' be easier
for us to keep tabs and get people's
names spelled correctly thank you and if
you could state your name for the record
please thank you I'm representative
Alvin C from ladden representing eight
towns in marac
county and U House
Bill
1577 uh is a bill to um be able to allow
voters to view the digital images of the
new ballot counting
devices um and if they find any
discrepancies they can be formally
investigated by the
AG uh the two primary things that people
would look for was does the machine
correctly read the ballots and the other
is do the vat counts add
up um this bill essentially provides an
inexpensive way to have somewhere all of
the new ballot counting devices uh
audited Al beit unofficially and with
Free
Labor uh hiring professionals to do
extensive audits will likely be
considerably more expensive to get
similar
results um the fiscal note was not
updated after the amendment was approved
by the house um under the Staffing and
bullet uh equipment and Staffing bullet
point the it position would not be
needed all
year we do have an updated fiscal note I
think are oh just gave it to
you was amended on March 11 just got
one okay the uh the new fiscal note
still calls for hiring an IT position
but the um um one of the things the
amendment did was that the secretary's
request was to limit the time available
for doing these uh audits so the bill
calls for a maximum of four months after
the completion of uh recounts and and U
any
um any uh appeals to the recounts so
after and and also after our primary
election there's only about a month or
maybe a week or two more that would be
available before the general election
before they have to get ready for
general election so
um so maybe five months every two years
plus town and City
elections and since there aren't as many
of them and those elections usually
don't
take um have as many voters show up that
they may not even need full four months
after those
so in all intense purposes it would
probably be in the neighborhood of uh 7
to n months that this it person would be
needed for this project so if they were
to hire somebody maybe some of the uh uh
costs could be attributed to some other
account and the um software bullet
point
um
okay that's um it still refers to one of
them as having a initial cost of $20,000
but that may be for a deluxe software
package I'm not um privy to all the
details of
those um
Provisions would you take questions uh
certainly will represent Maguire thank
you Mr chairman thank you representative
for coming and taking my questions um
let's start with with the question of
timing do any any towns have these
Advanced machines and when would you
expect that we would need to be spending
money on this okay uh thank you for the
question yes there are five machines
already in use yesterday I cast my town
ballots in a new
machine um also that was in ladden and
uh Northwood Winchester and a couple
other town I don't remember which ones
they were um have the new machines great
um at the time the ballot law commission
approved the um uh the
uh
machine uh boning Works had five
machines available at that time to
deliver so I'm sure they're stepping up
production thank you may follow so all
right so that's good so we need to do
this right away now the second question
is the
um the expensive part of this if you
look at the page two of the fiscal note
is the the new employee um 82,000 88,000
87,000 per year um and will be necessary
to coordinate and manage the image
viewing process so the way this
bill implies is that uh people who want
to look at the ballots will come into
some some
place uh some meeting room and and our
employee will display them on some
screen or something so that people can
look at them right and that's why we
need the employee there but I'm
wondering if that's strictly necessary
couldn't you um simply sell copies of
the of the memory card to people and
they could in at their own time use
their own equipment and we wouldn't need
an employee to babysit them looking
through the ballots thank you in the uh
the bill
itself
um there is a provision in there that
the um um the last paragraph of it the
secretary May determine if copies of
removable memory devices or Digital Data
on the memory device may be provided to
The Observers that are examining the
digital image so if the secretary
chooses to just you know hand out or or
sell the U USB
chip to to people and let them use their
own computer at home that would
certainly be far less
expensive um it allows the secretary
to decide how stringent he wants to be
on on control of the
images do may I yes sure do you have
reason to believe that he would object
to having that be the only way this is
distributed as opposed to this image
because we would like to not I would
like not to hire this person because it
seems kind of a a useless task right I
mean I I would tend to agree with that
um in my discussions with the secretary
in development of this bill and and the
amendment um he didn't spe speci ify
that he
would uh necessarily be willing to do
anything
less uh
but other than that I I can't speak for
him because he just didn't say and the
the bill itself allows
for total control and just allowing an
observer to look at a screen while
somebody else manipulates it to handing
out copies whatever he wants to do he
can uh
also
um uh have uh non-disclosure agreements
signed and things like that so let me
question one so do you consider these
images to
be um not subject to 91a and proprietary
and that sort of thing or is it is there
some harm in in letting these images out
uh there is there's some people have
expressed concern that somebody could uh
analyze the handwriting of somebody
writing in a
name if they happen to write in a name
and be able to identify the person uh I
think that's a little bit too small a
sample of a handwriting to to do that
kind of analysis unless there was a lot
of writing on the bill and occasionally
people also put other sorts of comments
on the bill uh including even signing or
on the ballot and including even signing
the ballot uh um it's it's hard to say
so the bill does allow for um
non-disclosure agreements and uh for
people who don't follow the terms to not
be allowed to proceed any further on
that any further
questions seeing down thank you very
much okay and I thought maybe the
secretary would be here today to they're
they're right behind you oh okay
representative cambrell I noticed that
your name was on the bill do you have
anything to add while we wait for the
representative from the Secretary of
State's
office all right
thanks hi Erin welcome good morning Ain
Hennessy deputy secretary of state
um would you where would you like to
start let me start you have the mic okay
let me start with the memory cards so we
have um as you probably are aware we
have the acote device that we currently
used in most elections in the state we
still have hand countdowns um but the
majority of the ballots are counted by a
device yesterday was the first time that
one of the new devices met all of the
conditional approvals except
ultimate um vvsg 2.0 certification in
2026 and those are the new ballot
counting um standards set by the EAC um
yesterday was the first time in New
Hampshire that these devices were used
officially um and can be used going
forward um these devices capture images
of the ballots that are run through the
device not images of ballots that are
put into the side
pocket they also um capture information
about how the device counted that
ballot um this the language in this bill
talks about making public the
information um what is referred to as
the cast vote record but then nowhere in
the bill does it then go on to allow for
the viewing of the cast vote information
um so my understanding would be just the
images of the ballots um the reason why
additional Staffing would be needed is
to coordinate um not only the view in of
the ballots but the retrieval of memory
cards uh from towns that have these new
devices um the um purchasing of the
memory cards at this point in time we
don't know how many towns will end up
using one of the new um devices or
another uh we are we don't know if the
alternative device the the one device
that is being used currently is from
voting works it's an open source
software their memory card costs $10 or
less it's a USB card um the alternative
device that's working on meeting the
conditional approvals is from dominion
and that device has a proprietary memory
card I don't know the details behind how
much um the they estimate the cost to
purchase one would be approximately $50
I haven't um gotten in um anything in
writing about how much those would
actually cost I don't know if we would
be able to copy them or um if they would
have to do that themselves their
software to view the images um and the
cast vote record um they estimate our
purchase of it would be approximately
$2,000 but I don't know if that would be
for State purposes only or if that would
allow for every single um town that uses
their device so there's a lot of
monetary information that I still do not
know
um but my understanding is that we would
have to purchase these for all the towns
that we get their memory card from and
replace the memory card that we've taken
from
them um some of the reasons why we um
traditionally have not been in favor of
viewing a ballot is because there are
identifying marks that some voters put
on it um it would open the possibility
of vote buying um you could easily mark
it in a way that somebody knows that you
voted um the way that you said you were
going to vote um and we don't think
that's a good idea um altern
Additionally you can tell um uh how how
somebody who who uses an accessible ball
accounting device has voted um because
those marks are very per perfect
although it uses the official ballot um
you would be able to tell exactly how
that possibly just one person in your
polling location voted and um um the
purpose of the accessible voting device
is that so someone can have a a secret
ballot just like everyone else even if
they need um the assistance of a device
in order to vote that way um sorry I'm
sure there's other things I want to tell
you um so a lot of the cost is related
to memory cards and purchasing of the
software potentially from one of the
vendors the other vendor software is
approximately $500 a year um which I
would consider nominal
um the viewing of the I don't believe
that there would be any way we could
enforce a non-disclosure agreement if we
just hand out a memory card with all of
the images on it um and I I don't know
that that language for enforcement um is
in this bill so those are my some of
concerns about the language we would
need a new position we would need money
for memory
cards I believe we probably would have
space to do this um the timing wise I
think would take all year um I it
doesn't limit the number for each Town
viewing so if you wanted to come in and
view say I'm from Littleton littleton's
ballots and then I go and talk to
somebody in Littleton and then somebody
else from Littleton wants to come in and
somebody else from Littleton comes in so
I imagine even if it's just restricted
to four months after um the close of any
recounts then it's going to be 4 months
after town elections and four months
March Town elections four months after
April Town election four months after
May Town elections four months after um
City elections in the fall so it's it
would
be um non-stop throughout the
year sometimes much more busy than
others so I guess my question to you is
does the office does your office support
this legislation I'm getting like mixed
signals I would I would say we don't
support the at this time the viewing of
digital images it would um because not
all ballots are scanned it would lead to
inaccurate um self- recounts um because
they don't have the complete election
information to go off of um and because
of the other concerns I mentioned about
the secret um your secret vote being
open for anyone to view it there is a
one of the devices does have a potential
um
um way for you to link back and they're
supposedly fixing this but to link back
the cast vote record viewing the cast
vote record to how somebody voted by
recording which you can do in New
Hampshire your entire election and you
would be able to look on the cast vote
record how the order of seron voted and
so linking viewing that information you
could see oh um chairman Lehman came in
he was the third voter of the day oh
this must be his ballot um they're work
I believe they're working on fixing that
but there are some there's still some
unknowns with the with one of the
devices which were required to be fixed
if we were to do this thanks Erin um
other questions for the depuy Secretary
of State yes representative wer followed
by
eil thank you hello Erin there's a lot
of distrust in the voting in in this
state especially in certain polling
places in my County I keep hearing about
the same places over and over again so
the more we can allow the public to
check on things the better and I like
the idea and if we give warning up front
don't Mark the ballot with anything
extraneous that could be traced to you
and and if you just let people I don't
understand I've seen it in voter counts
where people do stupid things like they
they vote a certain person then they
think they have to write in that
person's name where it says write in I
voted for Peter lean I write over here
Peter
lean dozens of times and and there's
other patterns you see you can tell the
feminists come in and jump back and
forth looking for women's names you see
a lot of curious things when you when
you uh do recounts and you know let the
public be more informed and if you could
get a machine that makes it easy to copy
and easy to pass out
copies that here for 10 bucks or 15
bucks whatever you want to do take take
this home and look at it on your own
machine I think that would make for a
lot more
reassurance and a lot more help with
keeping the vote honest because I still
know there's a lot of crooked voting in
New Hampshire I you and I have had this
discussion and we don't always agree but
I've seen too much to say there isn't
but I would hope we could make this
thing with an ey to It Whatever machine
forget Dominion there's there's no trust
in the Dominion anymore they've stolen
too many election starting in Venezuela
right
and and let's let's get another company
involved that has a little bit better
reputation and have things that are
clearly anybody can go and buy it and
look take the hours it takes to look
through it all and and keep the marks
for themselves but that I think that's
that's something we've got to work to it
and I hope the Secretary of State's
office will be cooperative in that thank
you representive kimbrells yes thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking the
question so by your own testimony you've
stated that uh it sounds like Dominion
is going to be more restrictive and more
costly in terms of uh having an openness
to the information and I'm I'm one
that's for more transparency so is Domin
didn't guaranteed any contracts and any
guarantee that they're going to be
selling machines here to New Hampshire
thank you for the question
representative so the ballot law
commission has conditionally approved
them and once they meet all of the
conditions um they can be used in New
Hampshire elections right now um one of
the main conditions that they have to go
through is some of the vvsg 2.0 testing
standards that are office identified for
um mostly secur reasons um that they
would have to have those tested before
they can use them in New Hampshire so as
long as they meet that they and towns
would like to purchase them and again
it's up to the local local
municipalities here in New Hampshire
which device they would opt to use or
opt not to use a lot of people a lot of
towns still hand
count is that your
okay representative
eel um nice to see you madam um just so
if I could summarize your testimony a
little bit would it be safe to say that
the costs are basically indeterminable
because you're not sure about the
database the memory cards and all those
sorts of things plus the Staffing that's
going to be needed to facilitate this is
that I I have a problem is that a fair
statement that's a fair statement
financially yes okay and then your your
big concern it sounds like to me is from
a privacy standpoint that it's even even
I agree with representative wer if you
chair Wier if you tell people not to
Mark things they may listen they may not
but you can tell them that but the real
concern is for the um accessible voting
machines that they are clearly being
voted by folks that need those machines
and um so your concern is really really
also from a privacy standpoint thank you
for the question privacy standpoint but
also from a transparency standpoint uh
to representative Wilder's some of his
comments um people want to make sure
things are transparent and we definitely
agree um but if you're only using a
subset of the ballots to come up with a
recount of your own you're not going to
have all of the information and a lot of
people won't understand that and they'll
think that something went wrong with the
election when in reality the machine
counted the ballots correctly and then
there was a sub count of federal office
only ballots um over voted ballots for
some reason the machine just didn't want
to read a certain ballot um so there's
always going to be hand count ballot
somebody doesn't trust the machine they
put it in the hand count bin um so
there's they're just not going to be
looking at the whole set of information
um additionally this is would only
affect locations that use a ballot
counting device uh the new ones not the
acotes um so no one's going to be able
to do this for towns where they they
live in a hand count Town representative
kimbrells thank you Mr chair uh I
understand what you're saying but if
somebody is requesting the the
um memory card would you not also inform
them that oh and by the way there were
300 other ballots that were not counted
for various reasons so that they could
match up the numbers would you not
provide that information that
information would already already be
provided it's public information for all
elections on the return of votes either
locally or at the state level that's um
so any information that someone would
want we would give them so then what's
the
problem did they have all the
information what's the problem with not
having all of the information I mean
no I said would be able to they would
you just stated they would the
information is accessible so combining
the memory card with the extren
information they have all the
information that they need in order to
match up the numbers so why is there a
problem the return of votes does not um
show how handc count ballots were C
calculated so it doesn't
show um
it wouldn't show anyone's ballot
information um to to reconcile with no
one would be able to look at the hand
count ballots to say that is correct
that P that ballot was counted correctly
for Aaron
Hennessy so there's there's a subset of
information they can't look at those
hand count ballots nor can they look at
any hand count ballots in any hand count
towns
follow
up represent Maguire thank you and thank
you for coming
so Hand count ballots um clearly people
see them when there's recounts yes right
okay um are they kept separate from the
other ballots uh physically when when
when the ballots are returned to you are
um and you open them for a recount do
you do you know okay this stack was the
hand count stack and that stack was the
machine count stack or not necessarily
not thank you for the question not
necessarily we get information back in
all sorts of manners um but sometimes
they just bundle up all the the ballots
and throw them in a box sometimes they
have them in stacks of 50 with labels on
them um not written on them just pie of
paper um so some towns we may be able to
determine that some towns we would not
be able to determine that may I follow
up so but you do training of all these
clerks and so on could you require that
is or would we need new law to to make
that happen
or um we could say best practice wise um
but if you wanted them to separately
boxed hand count ballot for recount for
recount purposes
um I believe you would have to put that
in to law okay all right the re where
I'm going with that is that this whole
display process happens way after the
election's already over and so at such
point when you're about to hand out the
memory images you could look in the box
take the envelope of hand counts scan
them yourself and add that picture image
to the to the image of the other ballots
right and and then there would be all
the
images thank you for the question yes
you're correct we would then have to
pick up the ballots every single box of
ballot from every location where
somebody wants to view these um for the
purposes of doing that oh I see so so
mostly ballots are stored at towns and
not with the secretary of state is that
right all ballots are stored locally
unless there is recount request and then
our office goes with two employees and
physically picks up those ballots all of
them all right thank you um let me
one other thing back to the question of
the employee and the viewing and all
that
um could uh what would you say if we
limited it strictly to Distributing
memory cards and not do the viewing and
all that you know that's the time
consuming part it seems to
me there would
be um
a very timec consuming part of
distribution of memory cards um it
wouldn't it definitely would not be a
full-time position um and then I would
still have the privacy concerns that I
had previously of course yes thank
you all right just a reminder to the
division we need to really focus on the
financial Impact versus the policy even
though I can see there was a lot of
debate since it came out of the
committee earlier with not a
recommendation one way or the other
so seeing no further questions for the
deputy secretary of state thanks Aon
good to see you as
always the Gent does the gentleman from
the municipal Association wish to
testifying if you could please fill out
a pink card for us when you're done yes
thank you Mr chair n Grace for the
municipal Association uh we agree with
the secretary's uh position on this um
we did attempt to calculate uh the costs
associated with um with the original
legislation um and then looking at the
uh looking at the uh amended bill this
morning I don't believe we would change
any information that we provided to LBA
at their request um we're just unclear
exactly to what extent municiple
officials would be required to
participate in this process obviously
quite a lot of the review processes up
to the secretary um and and the the
processes instituted by the secretary um
certainly our local election officials
support them in that capacity and we do
whatever is
necessary um but we have to keep in mind
that that's just one of the roles that
town clerks and other local officials
play um you know we have a robust um
review process audit process I do know
that Senator gray has introduced another
bill this year Senate Bill 489 um to
update some of those audit processes
related to ensuring that the machines
are giving accurate counts I believe
he's worked with the Secretary of
State's office on that and then has been
sent over to the house for reviewing the
PO appropriate policy um committee
certainly happy to take any questions
the comme may have of me at this
time are there any questions for the
representative from the municipal
Association
representative um I just want to be
clear on your position on the bill so
you do you oppose it or we do oppose the
bill um as on mostly on policy reasons
but we're also unclear on what the costs
are because yeah so um but you have
concerns about the costs because of uh
the sort of unknowns of how this is all
going to roll out and also you're
concerned for the employees of the towns
who are already very busy correct so the
town clerk for example has a number of
roles in addition to election roles that
um he or she fulfills um with this
four-month kind of rolling process as
the secretary uh the deputy secretary
testified it's a year it's a year-long
process so while the town clerk may be
busy trying to do things like prepare
the uh the warrant for town meeting or
something like that
um they're also um being required to uh
act in a support position for the
secretary's office as one of the if one
of these requests comes in or multiple
requests come in um so it would be very
difficult with current Staffing levels
to ensure that every municipality uh can
adequately respond to these requests in
the manner that would be required by by
this
legislation as we understand
are there any further questions seeing
none thanks much for your
testimony the uh division any particular
feeling represent mire can we wait a
little till next week I I I need some
time to to process this and and perhaps
think of an amendment to uh make it make
it cheaper well talk with uh Miss
Hennessy offline and see if we can work
out a way to to make it cheaper and
workable um because I see the I see the
problems here and especially with the
hand count aspect of it um but I have an
idea of how that might be fixed
um but personally just to say I mean
personally
I having an employee to do this seems to
me not a valuable enough
thing to to justify it you know that's
that's my problem
um so I'm not sure this is a like
musthave with with
item all right any problem pushing this
to next week we are meeting so we can
add this to our agenda next
week all
right I wanted to say senator Hennessy
then it was representative Hennessy and
um so Aon next week we'll reschedule
this
thanks all right next on our agenda we
have House Bill
1647 relative to the calculation of
group to retirement benefits and the
retirement system this came out of Edna
20 to0 ought to pass as
amended it came uh had a vote on the
house floor a Voice vote back on the 20
22nd of
February and there is
a new fiscal
note thanks
and
mean
Melissa so if there's anyone out there
that would like to speak uh we are using
pink cards today try to keep things a
little cleaner
I was probably going to call on you
first Marty but
um yeah I can give you um representative
Maguire and I are on this bill this was
a result of a u retirement commission
recommendation last year and uh I see
that the Edna committee did amend the
bill slightly by requiring people to be
of full age before they could collect
the additional benefit and U Marty if
there's anything you think we should
know as far as if I know there's been a
slight reduction in the uh cost of a
million and or two but if you'd like to
speak to anything that you think would
be relative relevant for yeah Ju Just
Just for a background and I realize this
is a financial committee not a policy
committee I did um revise the handout I
provided to Edna for the initial public
hearing that's what Melissa just sent
around just for background uh on what
the change is it was updated to to note
that it only applies to members who
would qualify for service or disability
retirement I.E you know work through the
the full career or were no longer able
to U through no fault of their own um so
that's all background just you know on
the the policy piece and some of the
history
uh the second page of that handout is
something I know the chair is familiar
with we put this together for Edna as
well and this just shows the current
multipliers um for each of the group two
tiers and how the the bill would change
them after 10 years uh and when the the
minimum number of uh years worked were
for each of the the tiers and there some
some keys and some head counts on the
side so um just again more background on
the policy p P the the fiscal note the
the change the amendment
0326 uh out of house C DNA did reduce
the cost uh somewhat on the unfunded
liability I think believe the bill
continues carried over with the
55.9 million appropriation uh towards
the unfunded that number has gone down
to
53.6 in the analysis so if the bill were
re amended to that amount or if you kept
it at 55.9 it would just reduce the
liability a little bit more not
associated with this proposal but just
generally speaking so um a lot of
numbers a lot of things moving around be
glad to answer any questions but
that's where I'd like to start sort of
setting it
up let me just say how fortunate we are
to have you and we've all agreed that
you can never retire even though you
work at the retirement commission
but I'm still still really it's a a
learning process in this whole matter
but um other there questions for
Marty again you must have done an
excellent job there no
questions okay thank you sure thanks
thanks so
much the municipal Association would rep
uh would you like to speak to it or
no representative
Pearson
oh she's waving off
speaking
good
morning house finance division
one Representative Steve Pearson
Rockingham District 13 representing the
town of dery just um I just wanted to
come up here and just make a little bit
of a reminder a reminder that
the the negotiated
fix for this originally infor House Bill
436 passed the house with a veto proof
majority uh left the house in the
budget and uh we know
the chaos that ensued after that so The
house's policy on not
only a a partial fix but a full fix was
pretty much made loud and clear last
last
year this is a and I want to reiterate
that this is very much a
partial
repair to what was ultimately done in
through House Bill 436 so uh the guard
rails or the amendment that was
discussed that went through Edna was a
was actually proposed
by uh the the affected parties that's
that's the origin of it they they felt
that a guardrail would be welcome and
necessary not only just to drive the
cost down but
to um accomplish the ultimate goal here
which is to continue to have people
working and um try
to make the jobs in emergency services
more
attractive you know
the I am fully confident in saying this
is I is I have a relation ship with all
of these organizations that everyone
involved wants to see a prosperous and
healthy pension system that is universal
so
um so that's just really why I'm I'm
here before you today is just a little
bit of of a reminder of what we've gone
through in the past two years and just
kind of how we how we got to where we
are today with with that commission and
and um and I just would ask
the division one here to move this
through and and let's uh let's have some
positive change forward for the First
Responders you don't give yourself
enough credit this has been going on for
over a decade to try to get to this
point so I appreciate certainly the six
years I've been yeah involved um let's
just say I've been a little bit more
aggressive I appreciate I know we all
appreciate your effort because it's been
a long road uh to get this far lot of
ups and downs
from
our battle to get this resolved um but
you got me here so go for it I'll take
questions are there any questions for
the representative from
der representative Maguire you don't
have a question yeah no I don't want to
encourage that but you don't want to all
right I'll listen sure so
um thank you for coming represent so
sure it seems to me that the key
difference between this and the and the
original House Bill
436 is that this expands the two and a
half% to be a available to younger uh
members of group two that's a fact yep
yeah and and I would you agree with me
that that's a very good feature of
this sure you
the when the when the legislature
created and or Consolidated the various
state pension systems in the'
60s um as you know the reason for that
was buying power in a lot of ways and
and uniformity amongst the various
groups and it took a few years and there
were some tweaks in the early days and
and they really got the system kind of
figured out where it can
function it's it's a cost-saving measure
to the
taxpayer uh based on Alternatives
and you know you kind of had to jostle
the the parameters to to get a good
running system and that system ran well
at 2 and A2 so you know to to restore
and I and I want to stress that for a
lot of folks it's a restoration and yes
for the newer folks it's it is a change
from their hiring condition but it is
putting the system basically back to
where it was functioning effectively
prior to the legislature messing with it
in the 90s so um you know we we bear
respons responsibility we I say as a
body not certainly as as members
individually the body but as a body we
bear responsibility in in mistakes that
were made in the past as well as some of
the lobbying organizations you know
pushing for some things that they didn't
fully understand so now that we have the
luxury of some 2020 vision and some
historical context to where we've made
some goof ups and and um you know we're
we're still kind of morphing this blob
that is the pension system into
something that frankly at some point I
hope we can just leave alone we can just
set it and let it do its thing but until
we get to that point we've got to work
our way through um getting back to to
that somewhat of a homeostasis type of a
operation and um within the financial
constraints of what we are able to do
based on the budgets that we have in
front of us so not to give some sort of
an Oxford level answer but that's that I
mean that's kind of where we are so um
this this is a step in the right
direction it's certainly not the step
that a lot of stakeholders want but you
know when you do what you can when you
can right thanks Steve sure repres
sweenee you have anything to
add I think this is a commitment we we
pretty much made last year that we'd
address this issue seems to me the fair
thing to do at this
point are you moving the passage I'll
move the we pass
it it's been moved and seconded
representative Griffin followed by with
a second representative
Sweeney thanks slight more discussion
yeah you're welcome to discuss the
motion thank you so um I had an
extensive discussion yesterday with uh
the Senate and um one of their big
concerns I mean just overall cost of
this bill plus what we did with House
Bill
436 is um the ongoing costs to
municipalities right so the if you look
at the fiscal note I think it's about 4
million a year something and I just want
to stress to people that um that money
is
for the what we pay now the 53 million
um is and and you might want to amend
the bill right to to to the current
fiscal note right rather than the amount
that's appropriated in the bill we might
want to talk about that for a minute but
but the my point is the the 4 million
ongoing that's for people who are are
not yet hired right and it's sort of
impossible to pay for them because we
don't know how many of them there will
be we don't know what they're going to
be paid Etc this is just our guess as to
what the ongoing costs will be and those
people get a better pension right they
get the 2 and a half% instead of the 2%
they do under current law and so it it's
sort of this ongoing cost is a concern
for the Spate but in some sense it's
impossible to pay for now right and so
um I think it's just you know it's one
of the characteristics you're going to
get a better pension it's going to cost
a little bit more all right so then the
other part of the discussion is um we
saw from the new fiscal note that the
amount for the now part is a slightly
less because of the house Amendment so I
would suggest a friendly amendment to
this motion that we we put make the
appropriation match the the fiscal
note okay representative Griffin
supports that friendly Amendment
representative McGuire is that seconded
by representative
Sweeny seeing no further discussion
representative
Wier well we have director Carl here I I
would have a question for
him as to what the deficit is now in the
in the retirement system and are we
making any progress on it um thanks uh
representative wer at the end of the
last fiscal year last June 30th it was
5.61 billion which was down from
569 billion in the prior year so there
was some uh movement downward uh based
on investment perform performance we
we've reached the point um in the
30-year funding of most of the liability
where the employer contributions coming
in now are reading into the principle
there's sort of a negative amortization
in the first you know decade or 10 12
years and that even though the employers
were paying the rates the the negative
amortization was increasing the
liability as well so we've kind of
crossed over to that Tipping Point so
we're eating into the principle more at
the current contribution rate so the
hope is barring any economic
catastrophes you know we that number
will be going
down thank you thank you
thanks there also another thing that
occurred to me if if the um
municipalities are upset about the extra
money and make it a 28a issue that
perhaps that percentage should be passed
onto the
employee
there is a motion on the floor and uh so
I won't take any further discussion
other than from the members of the
division
but seeing no further discussion we have
a motion of ought to pass with the
friendly Amendment offered by
representative Maguire to bring the
amendment into compliance with the
fiscal
note when the clerk is ready will please
call the RO okay
um as described by the chair um we're
voting on hb1
1647 uh representative mire yes
representative griffi
Griffin representative Sweeny yes
representative cell yes chair Wier yes
clerk votes yes representative hwit yes
representative
grassy ABS absent
absent
zero and chair
so it's unanimous um 8
to House Bill
1647 as amended
passes few minutes before we get to
okaying
e
we'll open up the work session on House
Bill
1589 uh establishing a veterans
treatment Court this came out of the the
Judiciary Committee 18 to0 ought to pass
with Amendment passed on the house floor
with a Voice vote back on the 15th of
February representative
wett thank you representative
lean uh yes I was a prime sponsor of
this measure and as you mentioned it did
go through U Judiciary fairly easily
with as amended um I was really hoping
that uh representative Lynn Judge Lynn
uh who I spoke with earlier could be
here to speak to the measur as it came
out of
committee um the uh the policy part of
it was what I focused on and uh in all
cander I didn't give a whole lot of
thought to the finance part and um I I
try to be pretty careful uh about
spending but uh and I know that's what
you all do so um the I can speak to the
policy um and I can try to I just re
reread the amended version and and there
are there is I had a little bit of
sticker shock actually looking at the
numbers that that that are there to put
this into place so anyway I'd be happy
to speak to the policy part of it a
little bit and um in the absence of
Judge Lynn um but I'd be happy to try to
take any
questions
yeah we try to stick to uh Finance but
often we get off track but uh as far as
policy have a bad lot over here but are
there any uh questions for
representative mofet representative
wer some of the earlier courts that we
did like the drug court and the family
court the family court I remember I was
involved with that we tried it for a
couple of years at a large count County
and a small County and see what the
acceptance was would you object if we
did this same kind of thing tried it
experimentally at a couple of counties
before we expanded it thank you for the
question and comment I would not object
to that I uh I know there's a template
in play that's been in place here to
kind of do that
combination uh thing you just described
one of the concerns that did come up is
that there were some gaps that's why
this bill moved through Judiciary so my
only concern would be that that uh in
some fashion there no veterans uh
falling any gaps uh like in Grafton
County or Coos or whatever but uh what
you just what you just described uh it
sounds like something that could could
work at the drug drug court I think is
rocking County at the
drug at the drug court it started in a
couple of counties and the counties paid
for it because we were convinced yes
this is a good idea and it went on for
some time before it went Statewide and
then the state started to pay for it
before that it was a county budget so
it's another way to to try it to
introduce it thank
you any further questions uh represent
mire thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative we have in front of us a
a proposed amendment by representative
Stapleton um have you looked at that
because I I can't find any difference
between that and the and the the bill I
know representative Stapleton uh on the
house floor uh had an amendment that
passed
obviously uh that if I recollect
correctly had to do with making certain
folks eligible who were uh Allied
members of Alli forces who worked with
Americans uh so I I think that was the
point of his his uh amendment was to if
there were
Allied uh military personnel who got
into trouble in New Hampshire they would
be eligible for this uh sentencing
option um so I think that's what
representative stapleton's um Amendment
spoke
to a question for Mr
Hoffman so the
Amendment we have before is stated
February 6 that that's the one that
passed the house
floor
no I don't believe so yeah it's got
these
yeah but so maybe he rote it because
there's there actually were two
amendments on this bill right so there
was the committee Amendment and the and
the floor amendment I guess yes
represent McGuire the the committee uh
changed the language in Committee in
then there was the floor Amendment which
we just uh representative Stapleton
sponsored that or put that in maybe this
is obsolute yes so we got to put an x on
the uh February 6 x x just because it
okay confuse the
issue sorry are there any further
questions for representative Mett yes oh
represent Maguire thank you m Mr
chairman now um so the expensive part of
this bill is
these grants to counties in what way
does this bill cause counties to spend
money uh thank you for the question and
I'm looking over my shoulder to see if
uh Judge Lynn is here but but this young
woman
uh yes uh is very familiar with the uh
judicial the inner workings and hidden
mechanisms of our judicial
processes uh and I'm U more I'm a word
person not num person but uh in terms of
the structure you just spoke to uh uh
she or judge or representative Lynn
could um being part of that judge world
could answer it better than me well
representative Lynn who's used to be
part of the judge world just came in so
would you like to come there's been some
questions that representative Moffett
said you're the person to ask represent
ly here I'm so pleased
so uh so I I I uh I spoke to I
introduced this uh representative ly and
I we're not really into the policy part
but the mechanism of uh in fact
represent wer had a interesting good
question comment that maybe he could
repeat for you sure and I I apologize
for being late I we had our exec
sessions going on and we just just got
done sorry about that no I was referring
to the
implementation um like in Family Court
first we tried it in a large County and
a small County for a couple of years
years before we decided whether or not
it was successful and to expand it and
then with the drug court I know we
started in Rockingham County we were
convinced by the county attorney that we
should try it and it was paid for just
by the county and then I think another
County had had done it and then it was
successful so the state took it over and
started paying for it so I'm wondering
if that same mechanism might work for
this I mean I I that certainly would be
a a Poss you mean you could do it that
way I think um the the way the way it's
drafted now doesn't do that and I think
the but what it does do is you'll see
there's language in there that gives the
the court system the flexibility so that
because I for example in let's say in
Coos County and might that's arguably
this could be true in other counties it
may be that the that the uh the number
of people the number of veterans who are
participating in a uh in the veterans
court would not be sufficient to you
know know uh have a sort of
separate uh judicial officer and staff
and stuff you know related just to that
County so this gives them gives the uh
the court system the flexibility to say
well we're going to combine Coos and
Grafton uh or whatever um but I I guess
the other thing I would say and I and
I'd be if interested what the judicial
branch would have to say because they
obviously have more recent information
than I do my sense though is that these
kind of
treatment oriented courts the drug court
mental health um even the veterans I
mean there is some language in existing
law dealing with veterans courts um you
know it's been around sort of long
enough for us to kind of know that it
works and so I you know the pilot the
pilot program model I think I'm not sure
we need to do that anymore so that's I
guess that would be what I would say on
that
any further questions for representative
Mett or representative Lynn
representative Maguire has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you um
chairman Lynn
um let me ask the question I um asked
previously so the main cost of this bill
is the grants to counties in what way
did the does the bill impose new C new
costs on
counties well I think in terms of the
you know um the the County correctional
systems for example uh they uh they
Staffing people uh some of those things
are paid for by the county and I assume
that there would be
um things that they would do in
connection with the drug court um I mean
in connection with the veterans court
that would uh cost money you know at
least or at least things that they could
do that could cost money that and that's
I think maybe what the the idea of
having the grants is to is to uh make
them available to so that if so that if
there are treatment options that they
could uh that they could that they could
Implement they would have money to do
that and I wish you know I'm I'm is Alex
is Alex Cassel here not he's not I wish
I'm sorry I wish Alex was here because
he's he's kind of our the judicial
Branch's Guru on these on the treatment
uh course and he could he could give you
the the specific examples of things that
the counties do now in the other
treatment courts that I'm you know I'm
I'm not I don't have the details and I
apologize for that may I follow so
you're thinking of
um the judge might order that somebody
go through drug treatment or something
like that and the county would pay the
the treatment person for that
service that what we're the county I
mean that that as an example or they
might have
um uh for example I I as I I give you
just an example I understand that in
Rockingham County which I'm you know I
have some more familiarity with they um
the County House of
Corrections does some out of House of
Corrections um provide some out of House
of Correction services to um either
former or or deferred inmates uh in
terms of counseling and drug treatment
and that kind of thing and so I suspect
that that would be the kind of thing for
veterans that um count you know that
counties might do and would be um and
that would be something that the
counties would pay for and presumably
this grant money would be available to
you know to help them in that regard so
I think that's U that's sort of the idea
of what we're talking about but in terms
of you know exactly what exactly what
you call that person and you know the
exact duties I'm I I I have to say I
don't really
know one more one more so the the fiscal
node says we're we're looking at an
ongoing cost because this grant thing is
not just one time this is every year and
so the ongoing cost looks like $2
million a year
and so um and it says there's a pilot
program that has 12 individuals in it
and it takes up one quarter of one
judge's
time
um is this two million a year I mean do
we expect do you know how many um
individuals we expect to help with this
and you know what's what would be like
the cost
per kind of thing do we have any idea
about that representative mfet I'm in
terms of the numbers I'm I'm really
not I I don't have a good feel for that
okay yeah thank you for the question
representative in terms of numbers
there's just no way we can project how
many veterans are going to get in
trouble or might be eligible for this
program uh I don't have the current
numbers in terms of like last year the
previous year the number of veterans who
were uh referred to drug court uh that
would give us some sort of a Baseline uh
great question and and it's somewhat
indeterminable thank you know the other
the only other thing I say is um I I
completely understand your concern I
wonder if you know
um I mean if if I guess I would speaking
for myself and I I haven't talked to
representative Mofford about this but I
if you you know decide well look let's
let's sort of see how this works in
terms of the money let's let's let's say
that you know we're going to appro rate
this money uh uh for for next year or
whatever and and have some language in
there that says you know this will be
reevaluated um at the end of the at the
end of the fiscal year or whatever that
I mean that makes perfect sense I would
I wouldn't have any problem with that
thank seeing no further questions thank
you I do see a gentleman from the uh
National Guard in the back there I
believe would you like to come forward
and say anything or
oh absolutely
yeah
thanks yeah we we do have an updated
fiscal note and it seems a lot higher
than the original bill that went to the
Judiciary Committee so I'll be curious
and why it's now closing in on $2
million the I think the the major cost
there is it's in the original language
the actual grants themselves and my
understanding of the grant Amounts is
that that those are amounts that are
used in the drug courts and so I think
the I don't want to speak for the the
policy sponsors but their thought was
that it would be unlikely to exceed the
amount of funds that are used in the
county grants for the drug courts um and
and I think that's true and it's it's
also not very likely certainly not
initially to approach the amount of
money that's used uh for the grants for
the drug courts uh I don't know if their
intention they can maybe speak more to
it as just to Envision what I know many
Advocates of the bill have said they
expect to be able to pull many more
people into the program than are
currently in it uh that they didn't want
it to have a a ceiling that was too low
uh for a future date but I don't expect
that the grants would reach the total uh
maximum that's currently listed in this
bill the direct costs for the court are
relatively low the bill has a veterans
court coordinator that's a hiring of a
position the creation of a database to
answer record questions and a certain
percentage of our grant manager time the
same way that she manages the grants
through the drug court to manage them uh
through the counties but the the the
grants themselves are not a cost to us
we're we're a pass through for them the
costs for the court are under a quarter
million dollars a
year I should have asked you this at the
beginning if you just state your name
for the record soone outside there knows
who I should assume everybody knows me
by my face uh my name is eron k I'm the
general counsel for the judicial branch
my name is Warren Perry I'm the deputy
agent general for the Department of
military Affairs and veteran services so
I would just kind of say that the demand
on the court for veterans court services
we anticipate to be less than 40 a year
historically we generally have about 12
or 14 in the program at any given time
so to uh to kind of get after uh
representative Maguire's question I
don't think there'll be a huge demand
for this but I I think there's a there's
there could be an anticipated increase
in demand if we establish a complete
veterans court right now there's a
docket inside the mental health courts
that that Services veterans that's kind
of the pilot that uh representative wer
talked about and we've been doing that
for a couple of years and that's where
those numbers come from so at any given
time about 12 maybe 40 veterans a year
might come in contact and that could
swell if we expand this to all the
courts in the state so that's kind of
what I wanted to say would you take
questions as many as I can answer all
right represent Maguire yeah thank you
Mr chairman um yeah this more a question
for Miss krian I think
um since we don't know how many people
are involved the way the the way I read
the bill is the grants are only
pro-rated based on the the portion of
the year uh that the grant will be
effective and it's so much for this kind
of County and so much for that kind of
County it's not based on the usage in
the sense of how many veterans were were
having these kind of cases so would it
be make more sense for us to say um
number of
veterans cases and and $10,000 a case or
you know I don't know some kind of
number I don't think that the the courts
have a perspective on that it it is low
enrollment right now and and that's one
of the things we've appreciated working
with the sponsors that they specifically
inserted language in the bill that would
be clear that we would have some options
if we had the county where for example
there was only one or two participants
in the court at a given time uh you know
from the Court's perspective I don't
think that this is we just a pass
through for this money the counties may
have more of a of a view on what is
efficient for them to receive it and uh
but for us it would not make a
difference if it were structured that
way because we would solely use our
grants manager to transfer that money to
the
counties um one question yeah so since
you're the attorney here um it seems to
me that uh on page four line 33 is in
conflict with um page one line three so
page one line three says at least one
veterans court shall be established in
one circuit court and one Superior Court
in each County or
District um are districts some counties
have more than one district is that one
District Court yes there are 34 district
courts okay um and uh but the on the P
page four line 33 it says a county
seeking to implement a veterans court
May obtain a grant right so we're
telling them they must implement it and
then um they may get a grant you know
seeking to implement right so it sort of
that implies that maybe they don't want
to
implement what do you think that's a
good question I think that the the
Mandate is for the courts to to
establish um the the veterans court and
I think if we didn't have the county
participation and they didn't want to
get grants and they didn't want to bring
some of their resources to it the
Court's role is to provide the judge the
clerk that but there's a paration a lot
of other folks uh you know prosecutors
defense attorneys uh treatment
professionals the VA uh so if we did not
have uh participation Beyond Court staff
that would certainly uh limit the
effectiveness of the program it would be
much more simp ilar to a traditional
adjudication um so I I I but I I take
that language to be on the courts
already now we do try to have a veterans
track where we have subscribership and
they have varying levels of formality
it's it's relatively formal in
Manchester and nashaa where there's a
high population there's a lower level of
formality in a couple other locations
with a small number of folks um so I I
think that for us our view is our
interpretation of the legislation is
that we have to make sure that this is
available regardless of the geographic
setting in which the veteran finds
themselves but that may mean pulling
them into another District somehow for
example by video conferencing and that's
the line that was inserted at our
request immediately after the
requirement to establish so you could
theoretically have a county that didn't
participate and the veteran would have
to go to another County it would have to
be served by a video conference through
another location um but it this would be
a much less effective Bill if we did not
have good participation from the
counties are there further questions
representative
eil thank you for coming I I don't know
if you're the right person to ask this
did the association of counties testify
or have a position that you're aware of
on this bill I'm afraid I don't know the
answer to that yeah I'm you're probably
the wrong person sorry I don't recall at
the public hearing seeing
them no
I I don't think they did
don't
so I had a question for Miss
krian so I see that there's a special
fund that's a special account that would
be set up separate from the judicial
branch now with the drug courts that was
all rolled into the judicial budget and
why would there be a need for a special
account
for this program that's not something
that we have a position on if the
legislature would like to structure that
differently it's not an area where we
sawed change I think to the original
language of the bill uh we can
administer it either way but it's it's
not something in which we take a policy
position okay these are their cards oh
okay thanks are there any further
questions seeing none oh thank you very
much is there anyone else would wish to
speak
or sure
you look familiar you've been here
before uh good afternoon my name's uh D
mcy I'm the deputy director of the
division of field services with the New
Hampshire Department of Corrections um
so I was asked to be here um listening
to some of the previous
uh y sorry um so yes you want me to
start all over okay um I just wanted to
give a little background um obviously in
my role I've been in probation PR for 28
years as an officer Chief and now in my
current position worked with the drug
court um been involved in the startup of
like the youth adult uh Court um
obviously with the the veterans court we
we support all the specialty courts um
and in in all of those usually the
probation Pro officers are the ones who
are supervising these individuals
because usually they're on probation um
you know in like drug court drug court
cases uh youthful adult court cases um
those case loads are a lot more involved
with all the court
meetings uh other supervision type stuff
um so I wanted to kind of echo what they
were saying I you know I work mostly as
a pro Pros are up North so I'm very
familiar with Coos Grafton Carol um you
know I don't see that uh those counties
probably having a dedicated veterans
court just because of the numbers um you
know typically we might have had two or
three indiv individuals who were
veterans under supervision certainly the
larger counties would probably have a
dedicated veteran court if that's what
comes to pass and I saying that there
was like maybe 20 or 40 uh individuals
um I think we all know Lake drug court
if you have a veterans court in Seven
Counties you're going to have a lot more
than 20 or 40 individuals funneled into
that um you know you're talking about
fiscal note and resources that would be
needed um certainly for the supervision
I would think the Department of
Corrections would
need additional officers to handle this
type of endeavor um so you know kind of
like in drug court best practices are
one officer to 20 to 25 cases and that's
what we've try to do with drug court um
so I think there's a a need for this but
I I don't see it going Statewide or
having you know you might like she she
was testifying saying that you know
you'd have people reporting from Lebanon
say to maybe lonia or Sullivan counties
for those areas where there was only one
or two people in these types of Courts
um but I think you know it would
definitely be
uh an additional uh income resource
issue for the Department of Corrections
if you know we had 200 veteran courts
individuals placed on probation and
under our care so that may be something
that you want to consider as far as an
impact with this this kind of Bill and I
will certainly take any questions from
from any of
you other questions represent Maguire uh
thank you Mr chairman so can you answer
my question in terms of uh how much per
individual this bill adds to costs for
counties or get some idea or I'm I'm not
I I think it would be similar to the
drug court you know individuals um you
know I don't know if they do it per you
know I I I know like every county has
you know kind of a a cap of you know
Coos has 10 you know other areas may
have 50 I mean I think that's how they
base the Appropriations to fund it you
know because you have a a drug cour
coordinator or a veterans court
coordinator and you know the team that
does all the treatment so I think that's
probably how it would be broke down I'm
sure sure if you you know like Mr
casselle Alex probably has a breakdown
on you know we in Rockingham we have
this many cases and this is what we a
lot for that uh program all right one
one followup now you said that um this
adds cost to the Department of
Corrections and I I don't quite
understand that because absent the drug
the the veterans court aren't these
veterans they've committed whatever
crime they commit and they're in your
charge and you know you still have to
deal with them and so on yes I would say
most likely they would be on probation
regardless if there wasn't a veteran
Court the difference is the amount of
time energy effort resources that these
cases take like a drug court case
probably takes three times the amount of
time energy resources from the
Department of Corrections as far as
dealing with those there's weekly Court
meetings there's daily uh Communications
there's increas
supervision um so as far as a resource
for the Department of cors that's why
we've tried to increase in drug
court to the most that we can as a
department but what I'm saying is if you
have 200 veteran Court uh individuals in
these programs Statewide I'm not sure we
would be able to absorb that without
additional probation Pro officers
keeping up with all the other stuff that
we're
doing well you just got a homework
assignment if you could get together
with the LBA Mr Hoffman and U look at
the impact this would have on the
Department of Corrections before next
Wednesday that would be great okay thank
you seeing no further questions we'll
take this up next Wednesday when we meet
hopefully I think we're at about six
bills now for next
week
yeah sure if I make one
comment I I just would like to highlight
some of the testimony in the policy
committee about cost right so and I
think this is what representative
McGuire was getting at it's like it
costs a certain amount of money to to
incarcerate Veterans and it cost a
certain amount of money to run through a
veteran's track and what we really need
to be focusing on maybe which one is
cheaper and more cost effective I would
AR without doing the math I would argue
that it's cheaper to use the alternative
sentencing methods and the the the
potential impacts of recidivism and
getting a productive member of the
community back in the community who is a
veteran are cheaper than incarceration
so I just would make that point to the
committee as as a consider the bill uh
and and move forward so I just we think
it's a good program from the from the
depart from our Department's perspective
we do understand that there's costs
associated with it but we think the
costs are less than if we had to
incarcerate veterans
well hopefully by next Wednesday we'll
have that well everybody will be happy
with the
results thanks Mr Hoffman for doing that
working with the Department of
Corrections uh seeing no further
questions uh it's almost 12:00 we'll be
back here at 1 p.m.
thanks well done what's
that
e
for
studies of nuclear energy
Technologies um this came out of Science
and Technology and energy with a 7 to
three
vote and it passed on the house floor
ought ought to pass as amended on um
with just a Voice vote on the 22nd of
February so is there anyone here to
speak to the bill we have Josh Elliott
from the Department of energy here all
right and if we could get you to fill
out afterwards a pin card that would be
great thank you Mike is there a new
fiscal
no we do not have a updated fiscal note
for
that are we waiting for one Mike or are
we all set with the last one uh we are
waiting for one I'm not sure how much it
will change but all right thanks
Mike all right all yours good morning Mr
chairman members of the committee for
the record Josh Elliot I am the director
of the division of policy and programs
of the Department of energy um which is
where this uh position and this reformed
office uh are located um so I am here to
happy to answer any questions that um
the committee may have regarding uh the
bill if I recall you're not General
funded at all right that is correct um
we are a mix of either federal funds
assessment dollars from the utilities we
regulate um or um the renewable energy
fund which is where this office would be
funded out of other questions represent
Maguire thank you Mr chairman thank you
for coming you said this will be
renewable energy funds where does those
come from sure um so the renewable thank
you for the question the renewable
energy fund um is a uh continually
appropriated non-aps fund um that is
managed by the department of energy the
funding from uh for the renewable energy
fund comes from what are called
alternative compliance payments um
essentially in State Statute we have
What's called the renewable portfolio
standard or RPS um uh electric
distribution utilities so eversource
Unitil Etc or competitive energy
suppliers are required to purchase what
are called renewable energy certificates
or wrecks in order to meet those um
statutory requirements um to have a
certain percentage of from various
renewable um
resources to cover what they sell in any
given year in the state of New Hampshire
um if a um entity can not purchase
because there are not Recs available to
be purchased on the open market or they
for whatever reason choose not to um
they can make essentially what is a
penalty payment called an alternative
compliance payment so essentially
instead of going out and purchasing
those renewable energy certificates they
say okay I'm going to pay essentially
this penalty instead um those penalties
then go into the renewable energy fund
which fund a variety of activities and
is contemplated as funding this
position one followup so as I if I'm
right
um any leftover renewable energy money
goes back to ratee payers right and so
is that am I right or um you're thinking
um I'm thinking of Reggie you're
thinking of Reggie yes so these funds
come to the department we are then um
statutorily required um we have a number
of programs to fund renewable um uh
either rebates or um competitive Grant
programs so they go to a variety of
things whether it's um installing a a
pellet boiler at someone's home to doing
community solar projects and sort of
everything in between
so follow so so therefore if this
position's funded and it's a new
position there's something else that's
losing out a little bit is that right it
so the amount of alternative compliance
payments fluctuates in a given year
because there are other Market forces as
well as actions taken by other uh New
England states in terms of the wreck
market so it's a very Dynamic Market um
so that's not to say that we would um
not fund it or I should say that um by
adding this position doesn't necessarily
mean that somebody wouldn't get a grant
or a rebate because of
it are there any further questions Magic
Money representative wer thank you Mr
chair I've been told that the uh sebr
nuclear power plant produces enough
electricity to power the whole state but
ISO New England has decided to spread it
all over New England is that any truth
to that it's so C Brook Nuclear Station
which is owned by uh nextera is a
private company um so they are they are
merch we're called Merchant generators
so essentially they can sell their
electricity to whomever is the purchaser
of that electricity um so they don't
have any sort of statutory requirements
or federal requirements that they only
sell electricity to within the state
boundaries um so in theory if somebody
has a contract whether it's a utility uh
or other entity to buy that electricity
from cab Brook that is how they sell
their electricity thank you you're
welcome uh representative Wy got me
thinking a little bit so what's the
lifetime left on
SE
um I believe and I am not I would be
happy to follow up with the committee on
this I know they recently renewed their
license with um the
NRC um I believe it's out to 2050
something at this point um I'd be happy
to follow up with the committee with the
exact date all right thanks so much
seeing no further questions oh I'm sorry
represent evil thank you I did you take
a position on this bill your
agency if I um I apologize because uh
one of my colleagues was the one who
testified in front of um House St um I
believe we were neutral on the
bill thank you very much um for your
testimony I see the prime sponsor here
would you like to say
anything
representa El for the record my name is
uh Representative Keith Ammon Hillsboro
District 42 uh and I'll submit a pink
card when I'm done um I was down you
guys missed an exciting caucus if you
weren't in there that's why I was late
um so I apologize so uh this bill uh was
a product of the nuclear the advanced
nuclear study uh commission uh and and I
had the pleasure of chairing ing that
and in our research we went through
statutes so we have this whole statute
set of statutes on atomic energy and
they're ancient they're they're very
ancient statutes and in the statutes uh
by anually so every two
years um one of the department heads was
supposed to be appointed the coordinator
of atomic energy development and that
whoever that was was supposed to every
years create
reports in conjunction with many of the
other Departments of the of the
executive branch and present those
reports to the governor and the
executive Council so that's existing
statute that's completely being ignored
so we thought it was a good uh a good uh
you know effort to update our statutes
with current
language so we didn't seem like we were
living in the
50s and then also resurrect that
position to sort of carry on the work
that our study commission had been doing
and put that position under the
department of energy which is which
didn't exist you know when when the
statute was written so that was sort of
the thinking of it and then we had
experts come in from um you know the
different different organizations like
the nuclear energy Institute and the
American nuclear Society we had um
Federal um we had people from the the
office of nuclear energy from the
Department of energy that came in and
and helped us and one of the suggestions
was we want to put the definition I know
this isn't a policy committee but I'm
giving you the background we wanted to
put the definition of advanced nuclear
into our statutes and then include that
that consideration in this reporting
requirement and we tied it the
suggestion was to tie that definition to
the federal definition of advanced
nuclear so that's kind of the whole
point of the original bill was to start
looking at Advanced nuclear because C
Brook and I think I think I heard the
same number 2050 it's been extended to
it may be extended further um but we
know we have high energy costs and
advanced nuclear these are these are
Generation 3 plus and generation four
designs that are they're they're the
idea is they'd be built in a factory
delivered by a truck assembled in a few
months that their their safety perimeter
could be
just the site boundary it doesn't have
to be 10 mil in radius they don't
require a lot of water they can power a
municipality for eight years before
being refueled so there's some really
cool promises that are on the horizon
potentially and we want to make sure we
send out the signal that our state is
aware we're interested we're looking at
it and for to
have um there are about a
hundred that it's somewhere
around uh let let's say about almost 10
billion of venture capital federal money
going into exploring this new
technology um I'm trying to remember all
my stats there's something like 40
companies working on it we have a
startup right here in
Manchester uh called star cube that's
working on it so so that was the the
idea behind the bill um and then the
committee uh amended it to change the
name of the office of offshore wind
development to be more generic
for energy Innovation so that would
cover Advanced nuclear it would cover
hydrogen battery storage that kind of
thing so and uh I thought that made
sense and I agreed to it because uh with
inflation there's a lot of contracts for
offshore wi that are being cancelled uh
the costs are prohibitive so um for now
that may be a dead end so to repurpose
that that uh commission makes sense to
me so happy to answer any questions
about that
are there any
questions like obviously you did a good
job so thank you for com you have
something else to add I was going to say
I know the Department's neutral on this
um we had had discussions with um uh
Deputy Commissioner uh Elms and some
others and um my opinion is that they're
favorable towards the direction that
this bill is going but I don't want to
speak for
them I guess I do have one question I
saw there was a reference to class to
money what's that
do I don't know okay yeah the bill makes
reference I I guess is it the is the
fiscal note or yeah so I haven't seen
the revised fiscal note
okay are you like to I just i' never saw
it before so I just kind of caught my
eye
sure um having to answer that question
uh class two um refers to the class uh
classes within the renewable portfolio
standard so class two is solar um so
there are other requirements that the
money that we get in for acps be
directed towards solar activities
specifically within the statute um so
that's that's where that um comes in I
will answer your other question uh
regarding SE Brook station um I did look
it up while um representative Ammon was
testifying uh their license was renewed
in 2019 to operate through March 15 of
2050 all
right I guess you don't have any yeah
sounds good all right thanks so much for
your thank
you all right representa Sweeny's moving
thank you I will move on to pass and
seconded by representative
Griffin was supposed to be
representative
cell oh you already had that set up I
see he's one of the sponsors yeah that's
why I
when the clerk is ready please call The
rooll Sweeney and
Griffin
yes
not to jump to 1649 but did you have an
amendment for that danan uh no not not
not at this time oh okay so I thought if
there was I got a lot of questions about
the bill but okay well I thought if you
if you had an amendment we could pass it
out and look at it before we start I I
handed I did have a handout uh so I I
already handed out the one thing right
which was the summary of the the
computer generated summary of the
previous public hearing yeah and work
sessions but I have more copies in case
people in the audience might like to
read
it just they don't exactly tell the
story
well
e
House Bill
1649 relative to prohibiting certain
products um receiving PFS and I believe
this went to the Commerce Committee and
came out what 8 8 to three no 16 to
three 16 to three 16 to three ought to
pass and on the floor it passed on a
Voice vote that's right and just um
thank you very much Mr chairman for the
record my name is Karen Eble and I
represent maram uh District 9 which is
New London and Newbury and just for
further clarification on The Voice vote
this wasn't one that we needed uh any
clarification on it was unanimous but
for a couple of voices in the background
so it was uh very forcefully um
supported as I of course believe it
should be I didn't hear your voice Dan I
was listening um uh it's difficult to
express I think how much uh passion um
supports this bill and how much input uh
was um given on it and how much work has
been done frontes representative money
I'm sorry you can sit with the Karen if
you'd like I know you're very involved
in this a while yeah it's okay sure um
but it's also it's um it's very
difficult to talk about the
financial um note fiscal note without
also giving some kind of background on
um on the
issue I think we're all very
knowledgeable at this point about St
gobain and the impact that it has had on
the um on the towns immediately
surrounding it's not as well understood
what the impact of p is on our um on our
waist stream which is something that I'm
particularly interested in and the first
thing that I've given to you in your
packets so you can just look at it is
that the sources of pasas um from
products setting aside industry the
pasas bearing products end up in our
landfills the landfill leachate of
course comes out it has pasas in it the
uh lee8 and I've given you a sheet here
hundreds and hundreds of millions of
landfill leachate has to be processed by
our wastewater treatment plants the
waste water treatment plants at this
point have no uh testing requirements
for past when the uh Wastewater after
it's been processed is released into our
surface waters the wastewater treatment
plants uh a lot of the residual is
sludge that contains some of the past
the pasas goes right back in the sludge
goes back into the landfills again many
of you may have heard about sludge that
has been um land applied in the past uh
that had p in Maine it was a huge
problem because it actually ended up
contaminating dairy cattle and dairy
farms had to be taken offline and
basically it it's it's bankrupted them
much of the land applied uh sludge in
the state of New Hampshire is actually
treated and is called uh biosolids so
that should not have p in it it is
treated
but the point is that the wastewater
treatment plants and we know what an
investment we've made in wastewater
treatment plants in this state um are
having to deal with untold amounts of uh
of Wastewater and the sludge is going by
the tons and tons and someone from waste
management is here that can perhaps talk
to this but Millions uh you know a lot
of tonnage going back into the landfills
bearing pasas and then you know who
knows there's the leech Aid again the
other thing uh just to keep in mind is
that about 80% of us have independent
septic systems in the state most of us
have um a cocktail of p in our bodies
and it ends up in the uh septic tanks
and in our leech Fields the septic tanks
gets pumped and then that goes to the
wastewater treatment plants as well and
then lastly but definitely not least is
the drinking water water uh facilities
and we had a um support from the
drinking water utilities for this have
had to spend excruciating amounts of
money to upgrade their facilities to be
testing for p in the trillionth I have
not brought information here on the
health effects of past um whether you
agree with that or not the fact of the
matter is that we are testing the water
and just about everything else for past
to the trillionth and we're having to um
we're having to treat it and it's
extremely expensive in fact the state of
New Hampshire has probably already
invested hundred
million and um there's really no end in
site one thing that I gave to you is an
article that I got from the Minnesota
Pollution Control agency they estimate
remediation of past in the future will
be 14 to 20 8
billion and they also have information
here that says although pasas can be
bought for 50 to ,000 per pound the
remediation costs are 2.7 million to $18
million per pound to remove and Destroy
them from Municipal Wastewater which is
an incredible amount of money by
anybody's standard another thing that I
have in your packet um I just want want
you to see this is from the
USGS and this shows that all over the
state they have tested the soil for
pasas and while not all of it exceeds
the amounts that are concerning it's
literally everywhere and if you
um if you think that the products that
you're using that contain P aren't
contributing to the situation um I
you're wrong wrong because most of
everything you can imagine has p in it
um I want to say also that this bill
came out of the solid waste working
group that I chair and it's a
stakeholder group that includes uh Solid
Waste processing folks
municipalities and representative from
the governor hospitals and they
uniformly supported the concept of
banning p in products uh for a lot of
reasons but one of them is to reduce the
toxicity in our waist string um I
haven't really spoken about the uh
Health costs that pasas can cause those
are really
unquantifiable um I focused more on the
on the leachate and the Wastewater and
the drinking water now I've spared you
the raft of support letters that I
brought into Commerce but this is unlike
any bill I think any of us have ever
seen this is supported by the solid
waste industry and I've given you um an
association letter from the national
waste and recycling Association so we
have landfill operators we have
wastewater treatment facilities that
also provided a letter in support
drinking water facilities Public Health
asso associations environmental
Coalition the New Hampshire Municipal
Association and any number of a
different um additional clean water
Advocates and the issue of pasas has
bring brought all these people together
in support and this is why when you look
at the recommendation of Commerce you
will see a 16-3 vote now I know that we
have an AI replication of what happened
in the hearings what's not reflected
there is that the chairman asked on
several occasions for people to step
forward in the final analysis of the way
we in the way we uh amended the bill and
no one said anything and that is because
during the process of amending it I
removed several parts of it that were
onerous I thought for manufacturers and
I removed them one was a notification
provision that all manufacturers that
produce products with past had to um
submit to the department this was also
difficult for the Department I also
removed a uniform labeling requirement
which was onerous for
manufacturers I also communicated with
several industry groups who were
concerned especially about the impact on
um medical devices I provided an
exclusion for that I also worked with
Honeywell and other businesses to
provide an exclusion for um products
that may include past but at a greatly
reduced level that still were much less
onerous than for instance refrigerants
that are used at the time um so I can
stop there I I want to just talk though
a little bit about the manner in which
the products that I have uh banned in
this um
and this bill were selected it was
twofold one was because I communicated a
great deal with the waste processing
folks including waste management and the
items that bear the biggest load in
landfills are bulky items like furniture
and carpet and uh that sort of thing so
you'll see that uh represented in the
list that I have here secondly I have
data that shows where people are the
most exposed themselves to pasas that's
Cosmetics that's food proc uh food
packaging um also carpet and so there's
that group and feminine hygiene products
and then lastly out of concern for our
children I've included juvenile products
so that those will no longer have uh
past for children 12
and under and I have PPE which I've
given you a letter from the professional
firefighters they um are strong
supporters of this bill so just jumping
ahead then to the fiscal
note um first of all it is I'm sorry to
say wrong um part of the way this bill
will be um
administered may include the
participation of the apartment in a
Clearing House the way they um currently
participate in a clearing house for
mercury and for toxics and packaging
toxics that don't include past by the
way um the numbers at the time were very
high they were
incorrect um and I actually communicated
directly with the executive director of
the Clearing House where a module would
be developed to deal with pasas for
different states that are um that are
have banned or will be banning products
with um pasas in them the numbers are
far less and now because I've removed
the notification and the labeling
Provisions they're much much less and I
believe I haven't looked behind me yes
there he is director um whimet will
corroborate the fact that a new fiscal
note is going to have to be prepared in
connection with this um so really the
costs in here relate to one employee to
help um administer the program an
employee that by the terms of the bill
is limited to five-year position um and
the Commerce Committee felt very
strongly that rather and I agree rather
than putting somebody into place uh for
an very extended period of time you want
to make sure that the person who is
there is doing the job for which they
were hired and so we have the five-year
Proviso in there so that's fiveyear post
ban um the
$250,000 number that is in there is
really to get the program up and running
and general Administration costs right
now for a for a manufacturer to uh
provide a certificate of compliance if
one is requested there's no fee
associated with it there will be other
education and administrative costs
associated with this
um so I also so you have the Minnesota
example they're not unique uh the other
thing is that the state of New Hampshire
itself is in the middle of a big lawsuit
to try to get mitigation money back for
cost that it has um it has expanded and
if you read the complaint as I had every
reason you can imagine for Banning pen
products is right there in the um in the
complaint and as those of you on fiscal
know there's a six-month report um that
has to be given to fiscal every year
which the most recent one I just read um
which I think was from December and
itself says that when you test
groundwater around the state um you will
find P at various levels and if you want
to look at a map on the dees website for
testing for P I challenge you to find a
place where they haven't found it
because it's like covered with with dots
and then the very last thing I think is
really important for this discussion I
gave you a chart it's called State
action on P it's from December of
2023 and as you can see all the states
that have banned past products in some
in some way and you can see the um
effective dates of the bands and I was
very careful in the selection of the
products that I've included here
including looking at what the landfill
operators are concerned about including
where our direct exposure is to look at
what other states have done and the um
products that I've selected and the
effective date which um I hope we can
talk a little bit more about um all our
corroborate or go along with this and
also are beyond the effective dates of
these products California in particular
has a lot to do with um with the what's
going on with cosmetics and with apparel
so that will be helpful and then just in
conclusion the impact P has had on this
state it's hard to imagine another state
that hasn't been impacted the way this
state has I'm really proud to say that
we've been a national leader on this the
next step is to ban some products that
have P associated with them and um for a
time what I think compared to the magn
the huge amount of money we're expending
already and what we can look to in the
future what I have in this bill is um is
small money and I'm really really
hopeful that the finance committee will
understand The Voice vote and the
passion and the um necessity the passion
behind and the necessity for this bill
and with that I'll take your questions
representative
McGuire thank you did representative
Moody have to leave because I mean does
she want to speak first oh I was
wondering if she might want to speak
first or no you're
okay I mean are you together kind of
or oh okay all right well I mean because
I'm gonna get into lots of detail and
maybe I mean I'll I'll I'll be happy to
have you by my
side and again just a reminder for our
friends we try to stick to the fiscal
matters versus the policy right since
the policy's already been approved by
the house M Mr chair I would say there
are other people here that want to
testify is and and so I wouldn't want to
occupy too much of their
time represent McGuire you had a
question all right so I heard you say
that um you're you're primarily
concerned with water and and
Wastewater um but on page four lines uh
four and five um line four uh line three
um public the these those two things are
are being exempt from characteristics of
this bill well that makes sense Mr um
representative Maguire because let let
me explain to you how that happened
first of all um utilities are not the
ones that are buying banned pro products
that would be banned under this bill but
they're the ones that are having to um
work with it and they're the ones that
are going to have to upgrade their
facilities to deal with pasas the reason
that they're excluded was that the
utilities were very concerned that for
some reason someone might think the
sludge that they produce is a p added
product and it's not a p added product
so that's why we excluded
it really Qui
yeah thank you
so but your point is you're trying to
keep stuff out of those systems right
yeah well it won't be a uniform um
believe me it's not going to be 100%
effective okay
um all
right so however your your little chart
here about um past concentrations says
that landfill leech a is not a problem
by comparison to these other
it what it says uh representative is
that that is a chart of the exposure to
human beings from landfill leachate
that's direct exposure so not a lot of
people have have that much direct
exposure to leee that chart has to do
with things that we are applying to our
bodies or
consuming and landfill leachate may
eventually be something that uh might
get into drinking water or something
like that indirectly but that's what
that is right so my point is wouldn't we
be better
off um keeping it out of drinking water
keeping it out of food as opposed to out
of carpet or out of something else but
um that's the point in order to keep it
out of water and to keep it out of waste
waterer and to keep it out of our
landfills you have to stop stop using it
at the at the source and as I've already
shown you the remediation cost the cost
for drinking water and wastewater
facilities and the cost frankly for
landfills to be processing these out is
astronomical and the way this bill is
written you know there's really no
particular the the the people who have
to pay attention to this are
manufacturers it's not like retailers
and people like that in the um in the
state you really and in the meantime I
just want to say that if you don't ban
the p in these
products people are consuming them the
packaging is also getting thrown away
the carpets is are getting thrown away
and then it goes to the wastewater
treatment plant so that's where you I
mean we have I have two people here from
miramac that can speak to this far
better than I can but they've spent
unbelievable amounts of money there and
and from a health standpoint their
people have been very severely impacted
okay I I appreciate that but I don't
think they've been impacted by products
right they were impacted by some
manufacturer of something or rather
right you I I think that the larger
impact on miramac is certainly St Bo
gobain but you can't um that's the big
impact but you can't um SE separate out
what we're all consuming um through the
products that we're exposed to and I
don't want to speak for them but I don't
think they want their people exposed to
any more P whether it's from St gobain
or from the products they use and I'm
not sure that their taxpayers want to
spend a lot more money on processing out
the P that they didn't ask for because
they're the the the drinking water in
marac is coming from the marac river
isn't it largely and ground and and so
they're having to process it out to the
trillions uh that's what the testing
requirement is and you have a letter
from the person who's the head of the
marac village
District in
support all right let's go ahead all
right so let somebody else
representative
gry I'm I'm trying to understand this
because and based on some of the
questions that were asked here and and
you made a comment earlier that
biosolids were the problem but biosolids
are the problem because it's leate from
or basically it's the bi it's the it's
the waste that comes out of the water
treatment plants that is the sludge that
is treated and when it's treated most of
the time it's treated for biologics it's
not treated for past so that it's and
and then it's considered safe to apply
to to land and that's what happened in
Maine was that they applied these what
we considered to be safe biosolids but
they were contaminated with PE fast that
comes from household waste that comes
from what goes down your sink um you
know and and that's part of the problem
if I'm if I'm correct and correct me if
I'm wrong here and then the other part
of the problem is products that are dis
that are disposed of through your
garbage um sofas coting and stuff like
that that goes to Wastewater that goes
to landfills is subjected to the
environment it's then the you know water
gets there the leech the P leeches out
of that it goes into their leech eight
much of that ends up going over to a
water treatment plant as well but uh
some of it also May in some instances
get into groundwater uh but the thing is
is that wastewater treatment plants um
are not able to really to take care of
all of this stuff if and if what we need
to do is we need you're saying we need
to stop it at a source so that it
doesn't get into the landfill and it
doesn't go down the drain of your sink
and and that's how we stop the past and
you know you're not going to stop it all
but what we're looking looking at is
reducing the amount of pasas I mean
there are other ways of pasas getting
into the environment such as who smoke
stacks that you folks have dealt with in
in marac um but the thing is is that
it's basically materials that we have
every day in our kitchens and our living
rooms and our clothing uh that's getting
into the water into Wastewater and
getting into our garbage streams that
are creating this and by eliminating
that that's going to help reduce our
problem I mean that's that is definitely
the the idea I mean we can talk about
the biosolid but there's a lot of uh
misunderstanding about sludge versus
biosolid biosolid is processed sludge
and biosolids in New Hampshire is now
being tested for p certain pasas um but
I mean you you're absolutely right what
is going into the landfills at this
point is either refu from consumer
products um or sludge that's going back
in it into it I mean hundreds of
millions of gallons of landfill leech a
is being processed through these
wastewater treatment plants and it's
coming from us and the products that we
use and we can't stop any of this if we
don't stop um using products with P
added I also I have one more point we
just need to understand this bill
applies to intentionally added past not
PS it happens to be there through
process it it it's intentionally
added further question representative
gry
have so I I understand there's a new
fiscal
note is that correct no we haven't I
think no it's wrong so that's why the
director really but these other PE I
should get out of here and let these
other people
talk
to me well there's um it says at least
on the original fiscal note that the
Department of Environmental Services
states it is unable to accur accurately
calculate the complete Financial impact
of this bill so the new fiscal note will
completely and accurately show the
impact of this
bill are there any before we have you
Mike are there any more questions for
representative eel or I mean these guys
should be oh I'm sorry representative
Sweeney thank you Mr chairman thank you
for for interesting the bill I'm just
curious the enforcement mechanism
because it seems like we're investing in
this Clearing House to prevent it from
coming in in the first place but if
somebody has been found to intentionally
add PAs to their product what is the
fine that we should be Ling I'm I'm
going to let the director speak more to
this but the process is that the uh the
department can request a certificate of
compliance and then there's a series of
enforcement mechanisms already in our
statutes that they can follow to um to
enforce the uh to enforce the Bill thank
you kind of a follow-up to
representative Sweeney what is a
substitute for pasas it appears that
everybody's using it from whether it's
utensils to rugs to whatever what's the
substitute I mean I think they're
they're figuring it out and I think I
appreciate the question because that's
an important Point there's this concept
floating around out there about um about
um if pasas is essential in some way um
I just want to say again that the
products that are selected in here
there's
no essential need for pasas in them it's
not like it's a heart V
replacement or something like that I
mean if I don't happen to wear a
foundation but if I did and it ran in
the in the rain I really wouldn't
care thank you for that
example um Mike
whimet oh I'm
sorry I'm sorry we could go in that
order if you like no go ahead Mor okay I
just wanted to briefly Mooney sure thank
you Mr chairman and colleagues on the
committee so for the record I'm
representative Moren money I represent
the town of marac Hillsboro County
District 12 I support House Bill 1649
I'm a co-sponsor to House Bill
1649 now I fully understand that some
Bill sponsors will have to be told no by
house finance outside of a budget year
if not then collectively the bills
referred to us would amount to about 2
billion above
budget however this bill is in a must
pass category as a representative of a
community directly affected by what is
now the biggest most dramatic
environmental disaster in the state's
history this bill is a necessity to
starting stopping
P I've been involved like my colleague
also from miramac in now what is
accumulated to hours hours of
discussions and meetings on the subject
of P both its environmental effects and
health effects
repeatedly repeatedly the only way to
stop it is to prohibit or ban it that's
my understanding that's it and this bill
is the vehicle having received the
latest Sur plus just yesterday this bill
is Affordable necessary and good for New
Hampshire on the matter of health
effects I would just remind the
committee that in our budget passed
unanimously last year we asked for the
phase three feasibility health study in
miramac only twice in 10 years has a
phase three of a health study been
requested because of the severity of the
health effects on the community so with
that I would ask that you vote a to pass
House Bill 1649 thank you
all thank you would you accept any
questions if there are any certainly
representative
Griffin thank you for taking my thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
my
question um what is the process uh where
does that study stand at this point do
we have any conclusions yet uh dhh a
DHHS is here and we're fortunate enough
to have the prime sponsor of the uh
study here as well with regards to
they're probably the best to describe it
but it's moving based on the um pasas
commission I serve on and representative
Murphy do you want to add to
that thank you um Nancy Murphy town of
March um I know DHHS is here um but that
um approval for that funding was signed
by uh governor and Council and the
project is just in its very ear early
stages of Dartmouth College is working
with DHHS um Dr Megan Romano is leading
that study and um right now I know
they're in the process of putting
together Community um groups for for
communication between um uh Dartmouth
and DHHS and the March community so
excuse me we're at the very at the very
beginning but I I I think maybe DHHS can
also clarify there's a limited time I
think it's two years maybe that two
years yes that they have to complete so
a lot of work to do in a in a short
amount of time and I think they're just
figuring out um exactly how that how the
stud is going to work but finally the
funding was the was the big piece and um
once that was received the contract was
able to be signed and it is now in
process further questions for
president uh is there an end date where
you expect to report
I would defer to D
HHS good afternoon members of the
committee my name is Michelle robers um
I'm the bureau chief for public health
protection within the division of Public
Health Services with the Department of
Health and Human Services um to answer
your question relative to the contract
yes the contract is in place for two
years and it it uh goes through June
30th I believe of 2025 and that is the
expectation is to have the feasibility
study completed within that time
period any further questions for
representative I yes representative wer
as far as we know is this the H first
human study all the other studies of
past effects have been
animals
um yeah no I I I I really can't speak to
the breath of the studies but certainly
for New Hampshire this is the first
feasibility study um that we're looking
at with respect to that I haven't seen
anything in literature that refers to
human
studies I would say that this um PS have
been well studied pooa in particular
pfoa um and that's the um uh the prime
um chemical uh that we're we're dealing
with in March although there are many
there are hundreds of of pasas chemicals
that are impacting March there are over
10,000 I think probably 15,000 P
identified but in order um for um these
these chemicals to um receive um the
determinations to be made around um
maximum contaminant levels what what is
safe for human exposure um in a great
amount of research and data has to be
collected and that um we've often heard
people say well you know you have no
proof that it causes whatever um you
know a community may be raising as a
health issue and um fairly recently uh
PFA has been determined to cause cancer
So based on Research we do have the data
that's backing up the concerns that that
community members are voicing in
environmentally impacted areas this was
human studies yes I believe yes thank
you
yeah any further questions for
representative Mooney or Murphy or the
kind lady from the Department of Health
and Human
Services seeing none
thanks representative money you have
something else to
add thank you Mr chair and I appreciate
it I know representative Murphy has a
statement to read I think it's important
the division hear
it oh absolutely thank you again good
afternoon Mr chair and honorable members
of the committee um I'm Nancy Murphy
representing the town of marac which is
Hillsboro 12 today I'm here in support
of HB uh 1649 as a co-sponsor and a
representative for the town of marac
which is the site of the largest
environmental industrial disaster in New
Hampshire's history um 10 years ago New
Hampshire taken no action to address the
use of pest in our state the Live Free
or Die state had few environmental
regulations that would have protected
our citizens which made it appealing
easy and very profitable for pollas to
take up residents here and so they did
they pretended to be corporate good
corporate neighbors while filling our
air water and soil and us with toxic
chemicals we weren't and still are not
adequately protected some of us will be
paying the consequences of this
contamination for the rest of our lives
those citizens don't have the power to
stop our exposure the New Hampshire
general court has the ability in the
past but not the will thankfully some of
that's changed the vast majority of New
Hampshire citizens had never heard of
pasas man-made toxic chemic that have
such concerning bioaccumulation and
biodegradation properties it wasn't
until 2016 with the discovery of the
past contamination of maramax and
surrounding uh communities in Southern
New Hampshire they're drinking water
that um a small group of informed
citizens recognized the enormity of the
mess that we were in and publicly
sounded the alarm since that time we're
we're in a very different place and many
more people are educated and informed
about about um why we need to be so
concerned about these these um these
harmful chemicals um March and
surrounding communities found themselves
in the midst of a public health and
environmental crisis um that citizens
neither created nor were able to end on
our own doing nothing was not a solution
and so after election to the the house
citizen Advocates turned legislators
began beating the drum about the
necessity for these public health and
Environmental Protections from pest
that's what hb1 1649 is um that effort
you can see uh continues today since
that time uh and through a variety of
efforts thankfully New Hampshire has
become far more informed about Pest and
the harms
Associated however that knowledge has no
value unless we use it for good citizens
are paying for remediation of public and
private Wells the cost of inhome
filtration to ensure that our families
have safe drinking water and the cost of
Health Care to address negative Health
impacts known to be linked or in the
case of pfoa actually caused by PS This
causal connection was recently
scientifically proven and confirms one
of our greatest fears pest causes cancer
and is linked to many other negative
Health outcomes marac kidney cancer
rates one of the cancers known to be
associated with pest exposure has been
rising and currently is 42% higher than
other similar
communities the
$500,000 phase three kidney cancer
feasibility study is currently under
contract with Dartmouth and is U uh
being used to investigate this finding
if we care about the health and that of
our families and our neighbors we must
stop our exposure HB 1649 is all about
stopping our exposure ongoing exposure
is particularly concerning and
detrimental to those of us living in
pfast contaminated communities like
those in Southern New Hampshire and on
the Sea Coast one of the uh questions I
think raised earlier was um well yes our
exposure in March has been primarily
through drinking water but given the
exposure we've already had we don't need
any additional exposure and it's not
just our town it's it's it's as
representative eel said anywhere in New
Hampshire most people we're just aware
of of it and many people um with with
high exposure are
not um Beyond uh the dangers of pest the
most important thing we've learned is
that the only way to truly Pro protect
Public Health in the environment from
pest harms is to stop the source and
that is why I'm here to testify today
hb1 1649 is the next step New Hampshire
needs to take the bill aims to stop the
source of PS contamination in Goods that
negatively impact the environment and
public health and burden all of us due
to the cost to manage them in the waste
management area remediation and impacts
to Public Health the number one solution
to the pest mess we're in is to stop the
source HB 1649 will go a long way in
addressing that without Source reduction
this nightmare will never end um I ask
that you please support this important
legislation thank you can we have a copy
of your testimony oh I can send it this
one you don't want all right sure send
it to me I will sure thank you are there
any further questions for representative
Mone or
Murphy seeing none thank you very much
thank you
uh maybe we could get Mike whimet from
the Department of Environmental Services
up
here
and again just a reminder Mike if we
could focus on the fiscal impact
absolutely since the house has made it
pretty clear of their support sure uh so
um first of all for the record my name
is Mike wisat I serve as director of the
waste management division for the New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services and I I do I I want to do a Mia
Culp here we did receive a request from
the legislative budget assistant to do a
revised fiscal impact worksheet for this
bill and we we we we muffed it we didn't
do it quite right we we looked at it and
and and really kind of didn't add any
changes the reality is is that with the
Amendments that have been made to the
bill particularly with respect to
removing the uh notification
requirements in the bill and the
labeling requirements um that does have
a substantial fiscal impact on the on or
changes substantially the fiscal impact
of the bill when we first looked at this
bill with a notification requirements we
anticipated that in order to effectively
Implement those we would need to join um
a a national Clearing House probably
through the international chemicals
Clearing House um and and actually pay
to have uh the programming done to
develop a New Hampshire specific module
to that to that Clearing House database
and that was probably going to be on the
order of a couple hundred thousand
dollar or perhaps more and it wasn't
really clear how much it would be
because there isn't a lot of it's hard
you if you've ever tried to get quotes
for for programming they always seem to
end up higher than where youed to start
so we that's one of the reasons we said
that it was really difficult for us to
develop um an actual cost of this now
that this bill has been amended to
remove the notification labeling
requirements uh we believe it's it's
substantially easier to to to
essentially estimate what it would be
what it would mean for the agency to
implement the bill so as as it's been
amended we believe that we would still
need a position to to work that up to
develop a program and be able to
administer it uh we don't we we probably
would join the clearing house but we
understand that's less than $10,000 a
year for dues um we don't believe we
would need to um have a module a state
specific module programmed for the
agency and as a result uh we think that
you know probably that would put us in a
position to administer the bill through
that position um which of course makes
it much easier for us to estimate what
it might cost on an annual basis I'm
happy to take any questions if there are
any do you believe you'll have that
information over to uh Mr Hoffman
so we can get it to we will absolutely
do that and again I apologize to the
committee we we we messed this one up
and we we should have had this right
before today's
hearing representative Maguire followed
by representative eel uh thank you Mr
chairman um so we have something here
that says that dust has half a million
parts per trillion of
P um if we were to spend this money and
the bill were to become law what
fraction of the pasas were exposed to
would decline you know are we cutting
out half of it sure a percent of it well
it's going to be really hard for me to
quantify that but I can talk about it um
in in in a qualified manner um we've
been working in Earnest on this ever
since we discovered the problem in
Southern New Hampshire in
2016 and by 2017 if you go back to the
Department's testimony and a number of
bills that have come before this body
since then I believe we said and I I
personally testified before number of
committees that we weren't going to
solve this P problem unless we
substantially remove P from from from
General Commerce and the reason for that
is that what we learned you know we were
on a steep learning curve when we when
we first had discovered this but what we
learned is that and I guess maybe the
best example that goes to your question
is that um just a few years ago a 16
ounce bottle of resolved carpet cleaner
was essentially 100% pfoa And if you're
at all good at math and you know that we
regulate pfoa at 12 parts per ton in
groundwater you can imagine what one
bottle of that that ends up in the wrong
place can do in practice what happens is
that you know carpets are already
treated with past compounds when they're
manufactured we know that that's what
dupon stain master and and those other
stain resistant treatments are and then
when you clean your carpet you use
Resolve Carpet Cleaner or a spot remover
um and that ends up the exposure from
that is substantial you got babies
crawling on carpets you've got dust
that's created as you asked about um
from a carpet it gets Airborne you know
when you vacuum you know it just gets
unless you have a hepac it gets blown
out one end of the vacuum cleaner and
everyone in your house is breathing it
it gets on your food and you ingest it
um hamburger wrappers are another common
place that these are used um and so all
that taken together results in
substantial exposures directly to humans
but also ends up as it's been discussed
going into our Wastewater and and and
and particles that go to our landfill
and then the the sort of past Circle
happens with lee8 then going to the
Wastewater Plant and the past
essentially not really treated but being
partitioned between the sludge and the
discharge to the which in most cases is
to one of our New Hampshire Rivers so um
when we developed uh when our
toxicologist worked on developing a
drinking water standard for pasas um
it's important to understand what went
into that calculation there was an
estimate that if you look at the total
burden of fast on the average human
person um only about 20% of it would
come from drinking water so they use
that to calculate the standard but what
that means is 80% comes from other
sources and those other sources are
things like dust and hamburger wrappers
and popcorn bags and all the you know
the list goes on and on and and so again
we we determined and and it became very
clear to us that while we're working in
Earnest you know our our main mission is
we try to make sure people have clean
Safe Drinking Water if if you just tried
to distill de's purpose to one thing and
it's not the only thing but drinking
water is a huge part of what we do
that's what we've really been focused on
but as we learn more and more about
these compounds we realize that the
exposure is much much broader than that
and that's what I think this bill is is
trying to address did I hear you say
that this this carpet cleaner is no
longer sold uh I I believe it's still
sold I I I I am hopeful that it has been
reformulated I will I will tell you that
there are still these compounds on the
on the market I I learned much my to my
chagrin I have h a particular kind of
tile in my kitchen that is you can buy a
a very broadly uh widely available
finish for that tile at Home Depot and
my wife was using it just a couple years
ago and I looked at the bottle and lo
and behold I realized it it it contains
substantial amounts of pasas so it's
still out there it's still being
marketed man so just go make sure no one
else has a question anyone else have a
question representative
grassie has has anyone taken it and to
do an analysis I know we're looking at
the cost of what what this is going to
cost us to enact this bill do anyone
take into account the cost if we don't
do this bill upon wastewater treatment
plans local communities health care cost
uh cost at the state for cleanups and
and and impacts on on businesses as well
that are going to be held responsible
has anybody looked at what I mean
hundreds of Millions to billions I would
think it's certainly it's a huge complex
calculation I will tell you just to put
in Easy
terms EPA has got proposed drinking
water standards for past including pooa
that are even lower than the ones that
we currently enforce and um we commented
on that because we were mainly concerned
that their estimate of the economic
impact of that was vastly understated
because at the time that they first
proposed it they suggested that it would
cost about $700 million nationally to
implement and I'm sorry to say that when
we looked at what we knew about our
Drinking Water Systems what it cost to
treat them to meet that standard and how
many of them would need to do that we
came up with almost $700 million in New
Hampshire
so representative evil um hi uh just a
couple of questions just following up on
what representative grassy said isn't
there discussion also at the EPA um on
having testing standards for past for
surface water release from wastewater
treatment plants yes that's that's being
looked at by the agency and and that um
is likely to have a substantial impact
if you look at you know most of the
major towns and cities in New Hampshire
have a Wastewater Plant and almost all
of them discharg directly to they're
they're treated effent discharges
directly to one of our New Hampshire
rivers and uh to the extent that
depending on where those standards land
and particularly for those facilities
that are located within 20 mi uh
Upstream of an intake for drinking water
system and there are many because we do
have intakes along the marac river in
particular um they would very likely
need to treat their effluent to meet
that standard in order to be in
compliance and that will be very
substantial in terms of cost do you
think it's at least 700
million uh did you say million or
billion yeah million it's well right I I
me I think that if you start to do the
math on this depending where this lands
it's going to represent a very
substantial substantial cost I just have
one more on the fiscal note um I have
the the in the amount in the bill for
the employee which again is capped at
five years there's also
$250,000 that um amount you had
previously estimated would be used
entirely for the clearing house and now
the clearing and and it and it didn't
leave any additional money for just
administrative costs so um
I assume that you still will have
administrative costs associated with
this program that would be on on going
as you develop it um and I assume that
money could still be used by the
department that that would be our hope
and our understanding yes okay thank you
representative Wier thank you Mr
chairman Mr whet is a lot of this stuff
used in the dry cleaning business they
do they have any pfas uh yeah it's our
understanding that um not so much you
know typical the typical dry cleaning
fluid is per chloroethylene which which
doesn't necessarily contain past but um
to the extent that you might have a spot
treated or you might have your you might
have your article of clothing cleaned
and then you might ask them to put a
stain resistant you know material on it
it very likely would be a past
compound question please I just sure I I
do have a quick question m so the origin
of pasas is this a petroleum based or
where does it come from so pasas were
actually they're man-made compounds they
don't occur in nature they're synthetic
compounds that were developed in the
late
1940s um and they um I mean almost
everything that I mean they're organic
compounds so I wouldn't be surprised if
petroleum products are used in their
manufacturer but they're not by their
nature petroleum they don't they're not
contained in crude oil that you take out
of the ground they are actually
synthesized and manufactured at a
chemical
plant representative eil Follow by
representative Maguire Can you estimate
roughly what the state of New Hampshire
has already um expended uh for p
remediation and do you have any idea
even going ahead what you would estimate
I mean I guess if to frame the question
when you say the state of Hampshire you
mean the state government or yeah so
certainly I I think you mentioned
earlier in your testimony representable
over $100 million and that's certainly
true if you look at the money that's
been appropriated by this body and the
and the uh monies that we've used uh
from other sources to address this we're
definitely in excess of 100 million no
question about it I think moving forward
um we will indeed you know continue to
incur cost we we still spent a
tremendous amount of man hours on this
on this compound on these contaminants
um but I think that almost is not the
story the real story is what our local
communities is are going to be spending
in our in our individ in in the public
and private sector on a smaller scale
because of the need to treat so many
community and public water systems and
then potentially moving forward um our
Wastewater systems that's where the real
big dollars are going to start to add up
very
quickly represent McGuire thank you Mr
chairman how many products are regulated
by this
bill I I don't know the answer to that
Su I suspect it's a substantial number
of products I mean if you look at um you
know the categories there there are I'm
sure thousands of products that would be
would be banned from having P added to
them and how would you proceed I mean do
you test these products are are you
going to start massive testing and find
out this one has past and therefore it's
it's gone or what so I think uh that's a
great question so obviously this is this
whole movement towards B in past and
products is happening both regionally
and nationally so I think that you know
large manufacturers that are marketing
their products across the country or
across the region are going to be
looking to to solve this and I think
what I would Envision one of the
concerns we had frankly was when the
notification requirements were in
there we didn't know how we were going
to process all those notifications
because there are so many products and
we weren't really convinced that that
was going to be all that valuable in
terms of um you know the for the time
that we would spend and the money we
would spend to collect that information
we weren't convinced it was really going
to help very much so what we would much
rather do is um you know working with
and that's why I said we were very
likely join the clearing house so that
we would be getting access to
information that's being provided across
different states and across the country
and then use that information to
identify where we need to focus uh
compliance monitoring efforts to make
sure you know so if we learn that what's
being experienced in various states that
are implementing these laws is that a
particular product line is a violator
then we could go to that and say okay
can you give us a a certification and if
they certify to us and show us that
they're compliant that's the end of the
story if they're not able to do that we
might well go out and Sample the product
test it and then take appropriate uh
compliance uh assurance and and
enforcement actions do you really think
this certification thing is necessary
because if I were somebody breaking the
law say in ch I'm in China or something
wouldn't I just send the letter and and
now you're off my back for another
couple years or well that would assume
that we always believe everything
everyone tells us and we never do so if
I if we got a certification but we still
had reason to believe that there was
non- compliance then we'd still sample
and evaluate but in many cases you know
um it's a matter of timing maybe
somebody isn't compliant but then they
fix their problem and they're able to
show demonstrate real evidence that
they've they've gotten they managed to
get the pasas out of their product then
we don't need to waste anybody's time
but to the extent we weren't confident
about that that's where we would focus
our compliance monitoring
efforts so I brought a product here uh
it's called thundershield silicon water
repellent um I don't it says no cfc's
but it doesn't say anything about no P
um how would you know looking at this I
mean I have no way of knowing is there
pass in here uh I I I I don't know for
sure I mean I would look at the
ingredients first I mean it's easy these
kind of things don't have a list of
ingredients it's not food so sure no but
we're able we we often are able to
obtain um safety data sheets from these
compounds that you don't get one when
you buy it at the store but they exist
when these chemical products all have to
have a safety data sheet associated with
them and we can go you can go to the
manufacturer and get a copy of that and
it's not always
completely um informative but you know
we have a lot of staff that have been
working for years regulating hazardous
waste and hazardous waste facilities so
we we have a lot of experience running
to ground what a comp what a particular
product might have and then when we're
not
certain the best way is always to obtain
a sample and test it
yourself yeah I I'm just worried that
the the amount of money here isn't
anything like what would be necessary to
to
systematically make sure that all such
product I mean there's there's there's
hundreds of thousands of products on
this list in my opinion right so are you
sure that this will do the job this
little bit of money here I'm not
suggesting let me add something okay we
have another bill today right which
proposes to regulate 15 stores that are
selling one product made by six
manufacturers or something like that
right and and the agent asks us for $8
million a year right okay you're asking
us for a quarter of a million dollars a
year for hundreds of thousands of
products it seems to me right it doesn't
it doesn't compute here well what I'm
not suggesting for a moment that we'll
ever be able to say yeah all these
products are are are pfast free that's
that's not what we can ever say about a
a compliance monitoring program we have
you know on a much smaller scale we have
several thousand small quantity
generators of hazardous waste we visit a
very small number of those every year
but what we do is we we we do Outreach
and education we do training and then we
through that compliance monitoring when
we find a problem we take appropriate
enforcement and we basically make an
example and that's one of the ways you
you kind of look bigger than you really
are by targeting the work you know
sharing information with our neighboring
states we're going to and States across
the country that are going to have a lot
of information
and then you really targeting our
efforts so it's it's a drop in the
bucket compared to the total Universe of
of products no question but that's
that's you know nobody I would never
want to come to this body and ask you
for the amount of money it would take to
sample and monitor every product that
would be absurd and it wouldn't be a
good use of anybody's money um so I
think that what we do whenever you know
setting this bill aside whenever we come
when we're asked to do something and
evaluate a particular sector of our
Commerce and and evaluate its compliance
with an environmental requirement we're
always trying to devise a coste
effective way to monitor it and get an
understanding what's happening and then
learn to focus in kind of like a laser
on the areas where there's likely to be
non-compliance and that's the way we
would address this and I don't suggest
for a moment that it'll be 100%
compliance but it it'll be good it it'll
it'll be
effective so representative Maguire
raises an interest interesting point I
think you mentioned earlier you're going
to see a reduction in the fiscal note
because you're taking some things back
right so you're taking things back that
may make this a better Bill if they were
on the bill and would require the
initial funding that you requested or no
I think all I'm suggesting is that we
you know you had asked earlier I believe
Mr chairman about our statement that it
was very difficult to to estimate the
actual fiscal impact and what I'm
suggesting is the way the bill has been
amended it's easier to do that now
because primarily the notification
requirement being removed we no longer
need to administer that and that was
going to be a substantial cost to
administer and we didn't think it was
that helpful because number one it only
applied for two years it was it was it
the way the bill was originally
structured the notifications were
required for companies to notify that
they were monit that they were marketing
a product in in New Hampshire
that was going to be subject to the ban
in a subsequent year and so we were
going to invest a whole lot of energy
and money into a module with a Clearing
House try to collect that information
and then two years later those
notifications would stop coming in and
we just didn't see first of all it was
really hard for us to estimate what it
would cost to administer that and we
didn't really see that it was going
to add that much value representative EV
well thank you thank you I mean this
being a work session I hope it's all
right if I make a comment there's two
things and Mr uh whims can confirm this
the EPA in uh May of 2025 has put into
place a reporting requirement correct
for all products that are being sold
with pasas so that um reporting database
will already be available to the state
if they want to check anything the other
thing that we're missing here in this
discussion and I just want to remind
everyone we are not first in in time on
any of these products all these products
are already being banned by upwards of
or most of them are being banned for up
by upwards of 14 states that are all and
so manufacturers are already complying
or starting to comply with the banss
that have been put in place by these
other states we're just taking a step
here on on and and I think if we don't
hear the I'm going to say this Cry of
the people to stop having pasas in our
products for two or
$300,000 to put this van into place I
think we're totally missing the boat and
I'm sorry that's not a question but I
just is it not correct that we are not
first in time and also we have done this
already with Mercury and toxics in
packaging yes on both counts that's
correct are there any further questions
from Mr
webet seeing none thanks Michael thank
you chair do have a card Michael Strand
from Bedford representing the town of
Bedford think he's here but waste
management is here and they'd like to
speak uh would you please come forward
and fill out a card for us
and thank you just very quickly I will
summarize uh just a few points that I
had um as it was mentioned um my name is
Garrett treer director of public affairs
for Waste Management um we own and
operate the landfill in Rochester um uh
landfills as has been noted are passive
receivers of posos um we don't produce
we don't generate we don't utilize it in
our operations but we to manage it
through the course of um running our
landfill um I'll just go right to the I
was mentioned FIS impacts um TurnKey
facility does have a water leate
treatment plant um recently invested $
three and A5 million do in that in that
process um to maintain that every month
is another $50,000 uh chart cost to the
facility which is born by the businesses
and residents who utilize a facility so
uh managing these materials is extremely
expensive um and without uh beginning
the process of starting to remove them
from the environment um those costs will
probably only increase as time goes by
that does not include you know facility
maintenance and and uh future um
expansions and whatnot so again I just
wanted to be really quick as also was
mentioned other states are are dealing
with this we are supporting other states
to do that and as more do that I think
the manufacturers will start to um
change the way they uh make their
products so happy to answer any
questions and again thank you for
allowing me the time to to speak uh
thank you are there any questions I I
have one
um are you of course are you not a
member of the national waste and
recycling Association group and are
there not uh members of that group from
around the state of New Hampshire that
that Association is speaking for that
also support this Bill yes the industry
as you mentioned did submit testimony uh
at the other Committee hearing and the
industry is uh supportive of these types
of bills not just here but throughout
the country absolutely yes and that
would include cassella and wheel abider
and a variety of other companies that
operate members of N correct thank you
of course seeing no further questions
thank
you um Michael Strand uh representing
the town of
Bedford and it's asked for two minutes
we have to hold you through
that we there we are I'll learn how to
use these someday um so my name is
Michael Strand I'm a a town counselor in
the town of Bedford um here to speak U
both on behalf of the interests of uh
the town and taxpayers but also have
some additional comments that are my own
so I'll try to clarify the difference
when we get there um most fundamentally
um I think this bill long-term will
protect municipalities from legal
liability and exposure um um we are in a
current environment no pun intended
where um when you know
long-term indirect exposure uh happens
towns are on the hook and often
uninsured so we are facing uh a very
dangerous situation right now both
short-term and long term and this is
Statewide many towns um
where you know if found uh you know
liable for past exposure that we either
didn't know about or didn't cause um you
know you'd be in a situation where you
know local budgets can't handle that
type of cost you would directly impact
you know property taxes um you know the
other part of it I think um you know is
protecting the people in the towns and
you know I know that there's often uh
you know a sentiment to you know protect
business in New Hampshire and that's not
a bad thing um but at what cost um so I
would offer that open question uh to the
committee um another issue that I have
having you spent the last two years on
the state P House Commission um is I
find it uh pretty unacceptable that the
only way we can do remediation which you
know obviously water in this case um is
through state funded or federally funded
remediation mechanisms and so I would
remind the committee when we talk about
about cost that you know when we use
taxpayer dollars whether they're Federal
taxpayer dollars that we all pay or
state you know taxpayer dollars you know
largely funded through property tax
rooms and meals Etc um you know we're
using taxpayer dollars to clean up
environmental contamination you know
this is tantamount to subsidizing our
own corporate chemical
polluters and there may not be an
immediate answer but this bill does
something to remove this substance from
the environment and that is noteworthy
and it is worthwhile and I would urge
you to pass it
um and I'll shift now you know some
couple quick personal opinions and get
out of your hair but um you know I would
urge you to consider long-term cost
versus short-term thinking um I have
noted on more than one occasion we
struggle with that in New Hampshire
sometimes and it doesn't make any sense
to leave our kids with the bill uh or
future tax payers with the bill because
we wanted to uh you know be friendly to
large companies whom often are shipping
their profits out of state sometimes out
of
country um so I would urge you to put
people in public health um in our local
towns over again often out ofate
National or multinational corporate
profits um we have to remove this from
the environment every day that we stall
in doing so we'll continu the same
issues that we are paying for hand over
fist and you know if you believe in free
market capitalism which I most certainly
do it's not the job of government to
protect big business it's just not let
the free market adjust we'll be
fine
thanks thank you seeing no further
questions or anyone else like to speak
seeing n the pleasure of the division
again a reminder we are waiting for new
fiscal
note
water is that
your'll do it representative Evel you
had a question um your no I mean if the
I obviously am very interested in
getting but it would be
helpful if it would be help to the
committee in um thinking more favorably
toward it I would certainly be willing
and happy to wait for the updated fiscal
note represent McGuire thank you um I
know that um representative Mooney will
not be in committee on the 19 so um
there's no harm I I think she would like
to vote uh in favor of this bill and so
um therefore I don't think we should
execute next week in the full committee
and therefore we don't necessarily L
have to execute
today um and I just in I'm sorry I was
just going to say In fairness to the
committee I want you to also know that
uh representative Mooney me and
representative Lehman have an amendment
that we were going to bring to um move
up the effective date from July 1st 2028
to January 1st of
2027 and um Mr Hoffman can distribute
that
and I just want to say I I've done a lot
of work on this obviously if any of you
have any questions um I hope you will
ask me um I think just from the people
that have been here today you see the
strength of the feeling here and this is
about half of what uh we saw before the
Commerce Committee which went through
the policy in a very detailed way and
we're just looking at the fiscal
effect okay we'll take this item up next
Wednesday the time will be in the
calendar that comes out uh on
Friday representative eel asked for a
minute to ask mop up or
PF
than
e
66 relative to income reporting
requirements for
lobbyists this came out of the administ
uh legislative Administration committee
ought to pass 14 to zero there was a
Voice vote on the house
floor and that was on the 15th of
February so it's just someone that would
like to quickly speak to the
bill seeing none
uh catch up real quick here any
representative Sweeney a comment or
question represent
Griffin I think correct me if I'm wrong
Mr chairman but uh didn't fiscal deal
with a bill from the federal government
that was uh
uh a million and some dollars for for an
identical program no no we're talking
about 1666 oh I'm sorry yeah we're
that's the next one I'm I'm ahead of you
you're you're one no problem no problem
so Mr chairman um uh let me ask um LBA I
believe that the house Amendment um
removed all the spending is that correct
um no there's actually a revised fiscal
note in front of you but I'm also or a
revised
for the amendment I'm also going to do
another one I just got some additional
information from secretary of state so
the new cost would be a one-time cost in
fiscal year 2026 for 50,000 to 150,000
for some programming
costs that's a fiscal note that Aon
brought in there was a correction to it
she just sent me some additional
information so we need a new fiscal note
any other issues NOP that's
it does the division wish to wait to the
revised fiscal note or act on the bill
now so we will wait for the revised
fiscal
note um Melissa so we'll just let Janet
know this will be on for
next week as well thank
you
so next we have
1678 establishing a New Hampshire Farm
to school local food incentive pilot
program this came out of Education 7 to3
ought to passes
amended and the there was a Voice vote
on the TW uh 15th of February supporting
it someone like to speak
[Music]
I just saw representative Simpson
yeah would you like to speak to your
bill after you're finished testifying if
you could fill out a pink card
and you're welcome to fill it out after
thank you I appreciate that thank you
all I just ran down from voting in
executive session and so my um timing
was better than I
expected um my name is representative
Alexis Simpson and for the record I
represent exitor New Market New fields
and
stratum I appreciate you taking the time
to hear from me
today I'm going to um introduce it
introduce um just give you some
background on the bill and then um there
is uh there are a couple of folks here
one who administers the farm to school
program and one who is a um food service
director who's been working in um Farm
to school procurement um for
years so good afternoon and this bill
represents many years of dedicated time
and energy from stakeholders across the
state those in agriculture and the food
sectors those in school nutrition
programs and those community members who
are part of the social infrastructure
that helps local food the local food
economy thrive D last year we submitted
a bill requesting State investment in a
farm to school program that school
districts across the state would be able
to access after feedback and
conversations with the Department of
Agriculture we have come back this year
to ask first for the development of a
pilot program to help assess the
feasibility of a local food incentive
program before attempting a program that
would allow access to all school
districts Statewide New Hampshire's Farm
to school program operates in some
schools across the state where local
food nourishes children supports local
farmers and strengthens the resiliency
of our supply chain in some communities
however there are currently schools
across the state who would like to get
involved in the farm to school program
who need encouragement fiscally and
operationally the pilot program would
allow one school district in each of our
10 counties to
participate schools across the state can
apply to the Department of Agriculture
who will put together a committee and
criteria to choose schools to
participate in the pilot program and
then the department will also gather
data from the pilot program in order to
discern if and how best to go about a
farm to school incentive program that
would be accessible to all schools
across the
state um a couple of months ago the
United States Secretary of Agriculture
Tom vilsack spoke here in New Hampshire
and he described the many ways that we
can support farming and Rural
communities in New Hampshire one of the
ways we can do this is by investing in
our local food systems investment in the
farm to school programs is an investment
in our local economies investing in our
local food systems especially our rural
economies makes a big difference in the
economic viability of small and Medi
mediumsized Farms as
well this investment will support our
kids our schools and our
farmers and not only can we help our
economy locally but we can also improve
the health and well-being of our
children and the resiliency at the local
food
system so my hope is that we can start
this pilot program and strengthen New
Hampshire's agricultural sector as well
as our um food Security in New
Hampshire and again there are folks here
who'll be able to answer technical
questions about the program um behind me
as
well well thank you would would you take
any questions um yes I will do my best
are there any questions representative
Maguire thank you Mr chairman you said
that this will improve health school
children in in what
way sure so probably um Jean Pierce
who's behind me um a a food service um
Professional School nutrition
professional probably has a better
answer to that than I do but um food
that does not have to travel as far does
not lose its nutrients as quickly so the
longer food is out of the ground or off
the vine the quick the um more nutrients
it loses by the time it gets to your
plate so if you can get food grown
closer to home it maintains more of its
nutrition
yeah representative
Griffin thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question sure um I seem to
remember in uh fiscal some time ago uh
dealing with a government gr uh grant
that was basically for the same program
are you aware of that yes I I sure am I
think we talking about we refer to the
stakeholders refer to as the Cooperative
agreement and there was half a million
dollars that we were able to get from
the federal government um after after we
tried to um get the local Farm to school
program last time then um some folks in
the nonprofit sector worked very hard um
to turn around a Grant application real
quickly and we got that $500,000 grant
for um specific schools mostly I think
maybe entirely schools that have a
certain percentage of folks in the free
and reduced lunch program but that
program is a short a very short program
and then that um goes away my
understanding is whether or not we spend
all the money um although hopefully the
schools will be able to but but um
interestingly enough because we got that
Cooperative agreement and the Department
of Agriculture is already administering
that
then they felt comfortable um taking on
a pilot program that would help schools
um a pilot in every County um so that
they could the timing works out such
that the Cooperative agreement ends and
then the pilot program would begin and
they would hopefully the department will
be able
to use some of their knowledge having
worked out some kinks in The Cooperative
agreement in order to go forward with
the pilot program with
ease that
clarify thank you
yeah so the Department of Agriculture
they're supportive of your yes yes they
are represent cells thank you Mr chair
uh would you happen to know what
percentage of that 500,000 went to
actually buying the agricultural
products for the kids uh as opposed to
administrative costs I do not I am not
that deep in the weeds of the
Cooperative agreement um 100% there is
no money
allow s if you could just come up and
use the mic please we might be getting
into the questions that Stacy Perlo is
the administrator for the farm to school
program I was going to say that but I
didn't want to jump ahead of us yeah
100% of that money went to
Food are there any further
questions all right I guess you're both
off the
hook would you like to hear from would
that be helpful to hear from the arm to
school administrator well we're we try
to just focus on financial matters and
we're running a little behind schedule
in a sense although we have something
coming up at three but um we know that
it was supported out a committee I think
but great by 17 to three votes so we're
good on the policy apparently great well
um if you have Financial
questions were helpful I mean if you
have any more money questions were
helpful hopeful are able to hopefully
take those as well all right so are
there any money questions Financial
questions about how the money's been
used in the past for any such program is
this an entirely new program this has
never ever been done before right right
it's never been done in New Hampshire
but other states have similar programs
okay thank you representative
wer I remember my local school district
doing some of this and just putting the
word out to anybody that had excess food
please bring it in so it's
it's been ongoing for quite a while
locally okay rep represent McGuire thank
you how will the schools that are
involved get
picked yeah sure that's um in the bill
the Department of Agriculture will be um
will be coming up with I mean there's
some details outlined in the bill and
the Department of Agriculture will form
that committee based on that
you all set so presumably then there
must be administrative costs right
because they they'll have to do things
to contact schools and do other things
oh I was talking about the Cooperative
agreement didn't have any administrative
costs oh I see so of this money it's not
100% Going to
food now this money does also support a
halftime coordinator position that would
be outsourced from the Department of a
thank
you seeing no further questions I
believe representative grassy has a
motion move on to pass motion's been
made on to pass I'll second it seconded
by representative huitt
okay all right seeing no further
questions any when the clerk is ready
please call the
rooll
just when you man from the when you have
an opportunity could you do a pink card
just so I have the name for the record
sorry okay uh representative Maguire no
representative Griffin no representative
Sweeny no Representative camell no chair
Wier
representative the clerk votes yes
representative huitt yes representative
grassy yes Cher yes yes so it is five to
four ought to
pass all right thank you for appearing
and thank you this will be taken up at
the next full finance committee
meeting thank
you we'll take a short break we got like
two or three minutes before
I'm sit here and
this you add this fiscal note how much
this halftime person
cost yes I just have to walk around I I
need she said that
a really oh really no but was I in
was it did it make me in no
no
get know what
Happ
e
okay we'll open up the work session on
House Bill 1633 three relative to the
legalization and regulation of cannabis
and making Appropriations
therefore this came out of the Commerce
Committee on to pass as
amended uh and had a division vote and
the division yeah division vote 239 to
144 about to pass as
amended so do we have someone here
that's a sponsor of the bill that would
like to speak first
thank you Mr chairman for the record my
name is Erica Leon I'm a state
representative out of dairy I'm um and
I'm the prime sponsor of this bill this
bill Builds on quite a bit of work in
the past um initially we um there was
House Bill 639 which passed last year by
a resounding level but clearly was shot
down um once it left our body because
there was a list of requirements that
needed to be included in the bill in
order for it to pass and become law
there were 10 items there that we large
that we largely addressed and then there
were two additional ones that came out
of um the Work Commission so I was
actually the chairman of the committee
of conference that created the study
group for to study the state run model
for the legalization of cannabis we had
actually charged that commission with
coming out with legislation that
commission failed to produ UC
legislation to be introduced to the
house um I recognize what a challenge it
is if it was easy this would have been
done many many many years ago but I
think that when we look to the different
points of view we need to understand the
path of all of these I never intended
this bill to represent the commission's
work I expected that they would file
their bill but in good faith I have been
working closer and closer and closer to
those guidelines implementing as many
items that were found in the commiss
found in the work of the commission
and trying to get to a good bill that
can actually make it all the way to
law two of the challenges uh that were
noted from the bill that's already
passed the house is that we had what
some might call a soft 15 store limit we
had a 15 store limit but we laid out a
pathway to which that could expand um at
the last commission meeting the one of
the governor's Representatives came in
and said that we need to have um we need
to move slowly we may increase or
decrease the number of stores but we
need to move slowly we had taken that in
with that language I have an amendment
it hasn't gone through OS but you have
my very expensive color Staples copy of
what I submitted to OS so that it's a
little bit easier to track what's in
there I also have a road map for you so
you can see what we have so now it's a
hard limit um there's also there was a
request for a ban on lobbying and
political contributions from any lensey
I see some First Amendment issues with
that but if it's possible the Secretary
of state would know how to do that so
this bill is amended to ask the
Secretary of State to um to come up with
rules in order to give that restriction
because that was one of the one of the
last minute requirements that came in
and led to the commission to study the
state run cannabis model not being able
to meet their charge Duty because they
were presented with two items at the
last
minute so the amendment that I have for
you has those two changes
um and then it also has some other
clarifications we had removed the Dual
use therapeutic cannabis I know some of
this is policy but some of it really
adds to the cost um we had removed the
Dual use therapeutic um license and
there are some other areas where it
comes back in there's some clarification
and advisory cleaning up definitions and
loose ends that's why it has the number
of pages that I have but most of those
are ones that are well within the scope
of of just specifying these one that's
large is that the fine of $100 on the
first offense of public consumption the
$100 fine had not been included so it
actually could be up to ,000 fine and
there's a potential of somebody actually
spending some time in a Cell um I'm not
sure exactly how long but if we don't
specify that there is that risk and that
would have a higher cost to the state as
well as a cost to the individuals
obviously um the the restrictions that
we have on public consumption really are
designed so that we're not like some of
these other states when you walk down
the street and instead of smelling
cigarette smoke you're smelling cannabis
smoke all the time that's just not
acceptable you know even for people who
are consuming it you shouldn't be
forcing that on
others so I guess the big question the
gorilla in the room is do I believe that
this meets the requirements to become
law and I do Minnesota enacted a
state-run model and as I looked at their
legislation and their rul making it is
very very similar to this agency store
model that you have here in front of you
um when we've heard commentary about
what bills would work I've never seen a
strong Embrace of the franchise model
which I know is the alternative option
that's being pursued because there has
been no clear Embrace of the franchise
model I think it's our duty in this body
to do the best work that we can here and
then if there are others that have a
different perspective let them let them
see if it makes sense to change it
change it over the
Senate right here we have a chance to
finally end Prohibition in a way that
will not grow the market very much
there's no
advertising you know how large did the
illegal cannabis Market grow without any
advertising I don't think this Market
needs any sort of billboards or anything
else but it does allow people to reach
out look for it find it in Industry
Publications and
whatnot so basically what I'm asking you
to do is to work with me as we move to
make those final finishing touches on
this agency store modeled Bill one that
will be able to breathe and grow over
time with the state as we see what a
mature cannabis Market looks like my
concern with the other Alternative
Market is that once you put in a
franchise once you put in a limited
market where the government designates
who can
participate and the prices that can be
set I'm an economist that is the
definition of a cartel we don't want to
create a cartel like OPEC in New
Hampshire what we want to do what would
be the best way to be able to adapt over
time would it be have a very very
tightly regulated tightly controlled
agency store modeled plan like you have
before you this is our best way to
thread that
needle and
reduce those undue influences just like
you see in the illicit market today why
create that in the legal market so with
that I'm happy to take any
questions thank you for your testimony
so the document that you provided us uh
outlining your goals that's highlighted
that you referenced this has not been
submitted to the uh OS folks yet for
drafting or it has um yes so that one
was submitted to them but um given given
that there's so many committees that are
trying to get some finalized work they
weren't able to get that in time for
this work session but it is in process
cuz we're under some time constraint as
well so getting these documents today uh
kind of pushes us back a little bit and
I was just handed a document that
apparently is coming from the Senate
side on the same issue so um just to
make you aware that um we're going to
try to get to this as fast as we can but
there are a number of questions on the
bill the amendment that's before us
which won't take in well may take into
some of your comments and suggestions
but we have a number of questions and
I'd like to refer to representative
Maguire to start thank you Mr chairman
thank you representative for coming um
you talked about the agency model this
is the franchise model and then a third
possibility would be uh just run like
the Liquor Commission with you know like
sell sell it just like they sell alcohol
um for for you for you personally would
you support the bill if it ended up in
any of those three ways or not um I
prefer the thank you for the question I
prefer this model I would be fine with
an actual State operated system where
it's just like our existing Liquor
Stores um just like the bill that passed
last term with a 13 vote margin I think
that the potential problems with the
franchise model are so large especially
because then you get the franchise board
involved if you have one of the
franchises or somebody at a franchisee
that slips has a problem then you're
bringing in a federal agency that has
not been dealing with cannabis whether
or not they decide that the state of New
Hampshire is the franchise or is liable
whether or not they Des decide that they
want to investigate our Communications
and Records whether or not they want to
put a freeze on the assets of the State
of New Hampshire for any potential
settlement we don't know we know know
how those agencies that already interact
with the Cannabis Market act but
bringing in the franchise model just
brings a huge amount of risk and if
we're going to go that way let's just go
whole hog and do the state run stores
because that way at least there's
transparency thank you I'll give you
I'll give you a copy of thisk
question represent sweene thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative for
being here in your work on this
obviously you alluded to the history of
this topic uh at the beginning of your
talk we need a bill that gets 2011 house
votes 13 Senate votes and gets signed by
one person mhm does this get signed by
that one person yes I believe that it
can and I will continue talking with him
through next week to try and get him to
have a firm statement of yes but he
wanted a state-run model um he talked
about State control so looking into the
liquor model New Hampshire is one of the
highest control control States as
opposed to open States for liquor there
are many control states that have a
touch that's very similar to this
throughout their system followup Mr
chairman thank you for that have you
talked to him about this proposal I've
been trying I hope that I can get a
chance to actually speak with him I've
been doing my best all right thank you
very much and if anybody can help me get
in with him I would appreciate that
thank
you further
questions I have a
few so I'm looking at the draft that we
have of your bill as it came out of
Commerce and that's where my questions
are focused um one of the biggest
concerns I have is the cost obviously
it's the finance committee and cost of
what we look at now I did read the 124
pages of the commission report and they
had different numbers for cost of
implementing what they had suggested
upwards of $18 million in this amendment
that we have that came from Commerce
there's a line for $8 million for
General funds to get this started is
another
$500,000 to get it
started obviously that's General funds
which concern us it's not the Liquor
Commission you know paying for it even
though it's the same part of money what
the Liquor Commission gives us goes into
the general
fund
but your proposal is that still the $8
million or is it less amount required
from the state to implement the your
franchise proposal um thank you so this
this is the agency control it would
simply have a higher level of control um
than in the 639 bill um it may make
sense to it'll it's one of those areas
where we want to try and break it down I
do know that um Mr Mike Hol from the
Department of Health and Human Services
has a little bit more refinement for
some of the positions required for the
data um data in the data collection
that's required but as we look at this
we're only looking at Ru making at this
point um before we'd be well into next
bium by the time that we start moving
past the ru making and and those
processes well you raise a good point as
far as timing because our folks at the
LBA have looked at the time to get the
rules put in place and it could be
upwards of 20 months and during that
time there'd be a lot of cost that the
state would bear as far as Enforcement
Officers rules the folks you know
developing rules whether it's a Liquor
Commission or something else is
developed so there's a lot of cost here
that we're trying to get our hands on
and just again we try not to go into
policy but this is quite an issue and
we've got all these different things
before us that aren't going before now a
policy committee obviously we're not
going to kick this back your proposal
back to Commerce so it's going to be
here for us to look at but looking again
in the amended version that was provided
to us uh after the House vote the
there's some troubling language at least
for me and uh should it be the Liquor
Commission this is on page 10 line
21 the commission shall appoint liquor
investigators who primary whose primary
function shall be the proper prosecution
of this
chapter uh the liquor investigators
shall have statewide
jurisdiction as far as a reference of U
reference to enforcement of all laws
either in the co uh cooperation with or
independently of officers of any town or
County so this is giving the Liquor
Commission the authority to go into any
Town any County without notifying the
local police officials of their
activities that kind of stuck out to me
is something that I don't think we want
to do but any comments from you on that
well I think that that is maybe a great
refinement this um as being a
collaborative process over so many years
um just talking with all the different
stakeholders everybody that's involved
in it that wasn't one of the areas that
jumped out at me but if you have a way
that we can better re them in while
making sure that they have the authority
that they need I would be very
interested um if you give me some
direction trying to find some correct
language to include into an amendment
for next week now in addition to that on
the next page on on um page 11 it talks
about whether the commission has the
authority to suspend revoke licenses and
it says this can be done without any
hearing
whatsoever it seems to me when we have
the do conducting hearings on violations
so that any agency within state
government has a setup so if someone's
AG grieved by their decision they can
have a hearing just as the um Lottery
Commission had with a casino here in
there was a hearing which the person was
uh grieved by their decision could
testify and bring his lawyers or
Representatives this would not allow
that so if the commissioner just says
sets someone in suspension mode that's
it there's no hearing or appeal process
is that something that you address in
your new proposal so this is an area
where the government takes a much
stronger hand than they do in the
gambling um when you look at that with
the gaming commission it's that's the
there's a lot of State involvement but
this is a higher level of stra State
involvement the state may not be
operating those stores but what the
state giveth the state can take away in
this so by doing that we have a Liquor
Commission and liquor enforcement that
are very good at their jobs and they're
used to managing when somebody goes
outside of the rules and the laws and by
doing that they're able to make sure
that the people who are operating under
their Authority are doing what they are
supposed to do that's one way that we
can have the assurance that without
having that Financial tie through either
operating it or having that fiduciary
relation relationship of a franchise
that we know that the state will be able
to exercise appropriate control on them
should this Market mature and reach a
point where it can become a little bit
less tightly connected as it would be in
this law it might make sense in the
future to change that but right now the
whole intention isn't to raise a baby
and throw him out onto the free range
the whole point is to keep that baby
close to you make sure that it's very
close to the state as this Market starts
getting up takes its first steps and
starts to see what the world around it
is as it becomes more mature we can it
we can as a legislature look at giving
them a little bit more space to operate
but keeping it tightly controlled to
start I think is one of the big ways
that we address the requirement for
state run control for the governor now
if you look at Massachusetts I believe
they have five Commissioners and they
have a cannabis commission all separate
from liquor nobody else and if you take
a look at one of their maps of all their
stores around the state they're all
along our border on the side that just
from Salem you can go to methan or havil
or anywhere and this 15 store limit to
me it just sounds excuse me like a
disaster um because you've already got
all these stores out there in the
Restriction of 15 stores in the state
within a population base of 15,000
th000 that's Manchester may get eight
stores or conquered five what about the
other communities like uh ammer Milford
Peterboro that have less than 15,000
people are all the stores going to wind
up in the bigger communities so those
people that live in the surrounding
small towns would just go over to
Vermont M or Massachusetts to buy their
cannabis um so the language and what
passed the house says that a
municipality can have one or one per
15,000 people but right the issue of ma
Manchester Nash and conquered means that
those concentrations can basically take
up the entire capacity and that doesn't
make sense the amendment that I have in
drafting for you says that
municipalities may have two if they have
a population of over 30,000 or have one
because we're launching it with such a
small number of stores if people wanted
to keep it to one per municipality I
would understand that too also you
brought up a great point with all of the
crossb stores if we only have stores
it's going to be a lot more attractive
for them to be in areas that aren't
served with that crossb flow I've
actually gone and I've went into a lot
of dispensaries both in border states
and in other states to understand how
this Market works and what it actually
looks like instead of just trying to
read reports and whenever you drive by
half of the plates or more are from New
Hampshire so clearly the people who live
near the borders already have access to
cannabis that's they're not buying on
the street from the illegal cartels with
the potential of contamination from f
senel because of that because it's so
tightly restricted it's quite possible
that we're going to see stores pop up in
the areas that aren't quite as well
reached by the borders if it's more
competitive to be near a border because
we have half the tax or not tax whatever
you want to call it rate then that's one
thing but I could really really see it
being more competitive having some of
these up in the mountains having them in
areas where people will come to because
they're on their pathway you're coming
to explore the mountains you're coming
to enjoy the beauty and nature of New
Hampshire and quite a few people who are
into Outdoor Sports would really like to
buy some New Hampshire specific product
to enjoy in the woods as well so um
that's one of the areas where I think
that it's kind of in my mind honestly I
do think 15 store limits kind of a bug
I'd prefer not to have it but it also
creates some hard conversations about
what works best and I think that we're
probably will find that we're going to
better suit the actual New Hampshire
Market by having those constraints on it
as opposed to just opening it up
now is your proposal there's a proposal
in the Commerce amended version that
requires people to be a resident for
three years which caught my attention it
doesn't seem fair like if say
representative
Maguire's sibling decided to move to New
Hampshire and he or she couldn't sell
cannabis for three years or get a
franchise I I don't know how that holds
up as far as people's right I mean you
can run as a state legislator just
moving into the state and signing up in
June or whatever so where did is that in
your proposal that someone has to be a
resident for three years before they can
get a franchise it is and don't we have
to be a resident for two years before we
filed a run not necessarily in our
specific town but we need to be in New
Hampshire for two
years a lot of I've been here all my
life so I guess I didn't know that a lot
of that is just because we want this to
be a classy craft cannabis sort of look
in New Hampshire we don't want to have
Mad Men all of the big chains coming in
here and just squashing our market and
making it look like a McDonald
you know if you want to go to something
where it feels like you're at a 7-Eleven
you're at any sort of um basic
utilitarian store where there's not
really anything that makes it special
then let all the large um they're not
really multi-state because you can't be
multi-state because of the federal
requirements but in essence they are
because they have somebody operating in
each of these states and they're using
um franchised franchise names um this is
to keep it New Hampshire specific
because it's not about crowding us out
some of the challenges other states have
seen are when people come in from out of
state come in flood the market and then
they crash the market and they take
people out of
competition that's one of the big
reasons to have the residency
requirement then again it's been going
on so long maybe some of those people
have already moved in and gotten a home
and they're voting with us too who knows
but uh I want to try and protect this
market and make it be for New Hampshire
and not just have us be yet another
place that's feeding money to some out
of state location it's not about big
cannabis I just have one more and we'll
let the other members speak up but one
of the fiscal notes noted that in the
first year after things really got
worked out the state may realize about
4.9 million the next year 6.9 million in
the meantime this general fund is
funding this right along and it could
take you know more than two or three
years but this before the state even
realizes any return let alone the
payback the general funds that would be
used to get this up and run
it's just a concern that I have there's
a long layover before the state really
realizes any Revenue state of Maine I
think averages 13 to 15 million a year
in Revenue
um and I think that's one of the areas
where I really truly deeply share one of
the goals of the governor to focus on
harm reduction over profits um one of
the biggest problems we have is people
who already use cannabis because most
people who are going to start using it
if this becomes law will be the people
who either already were using it or
there're such rule followers they are
waiting for us to make it totally legal
instead of
decriminalized so you have people who
currently use cannabis and if they're
not driving out of state they're buying
from somebody in the elicit Market
whether it's intentional to get somebody
hooked on the other product lines or
just because of poor product handling we
have seen people overdose and die from
fentanyl because cannabis that they
bought on the street had fental in it a
woman in my town lost her son to that
and that was in the opioid review
commission so it is happening and it's
not just one of these boogey men but
beyond that it's about making it so that
we build a model slowly I'd love to open
up the gates and have it be something
where it's going to become cost neutral
to a benefit to our taxpayers sooner but
that's not what's there's no pathway
like that in front of us that I can see
unless we are bringing in investors and
having investors invest in a state run
model um whether you're investing in a
franchise and expecting a future return
on that investment you know that that
state company partnership makes me a
little bit uncomfortable especially on a
product like this and especially when um
there's there's all sorts of federal
statutes about colluding to violate
federal laws and while nobody's been
gone after over Rico over cannabis the
closer we get the state into the
business relationship as opposed to the
regulatory relationship the more danger
we bring so as a regulatory body it's
very very clear that the state can
enforce business res regulations and
health and safety regulations most of
what we're worried about is health and
safety so that doesn't get us into any
challenging areas with the federal
government but I am very very concerned
that the franchise would even if that
means that in that investment companies
are going to be funding some of the
early development I don't want to trade
off the future of this market and build
a cartel in New Hampshire just because
of that and I'm not trying to offend
anybody from say from Cartel I'm an
economist I get to the sort of core
principles on what it is but when you
have a relationship between the state
and the only businesses who can do it
that is de facto what it is I appreciate
your tenacity on this issue uh I do have
further questions but I'd like to allow
my colleagues to ask a few represent cim
Bells anything yes thank you Mr chair um
did I hear you say with some of the
amendments depending that we would not
charge any tax on this or uh so um I
said tax because the governor doesn't
want it to be taxed it's an agency fee
so at our 10% agency fee we'd be a
little less than a quarter of what
California has which is why it has such
a supercharged elicit market and a
little under half of what Massachusetts
has which is one of the reasons that
they're still struggling with a lot of
the illicit Market I actually spoke to
some enforcement agents when I was just
driving down to check out the Tings Boro
store and I asked them what their
biggest problem was and they said our
tax rate is is too high it's probably
about two times as high as it should be
for our Market because there's a lot of
people that aren't coming to the stores
they're still going to the dealers on
the street okay followup Mr year so with
a 10% rate fee whatever you want to call
it do you think that that'll be
competitive enough to com obviously you
can compete with Massachusetts what but
how about the illicit Market how close
are you to the illicit Market do you
have you guys done studies on that um so
the elicit Market has a sporadic 100%
taxation rate because if they lose all
of their products it's taxed at 100% And
same with their customers um 10% is very
competitive with other states although I
forget exactly which state but somebody
just introduced 8% there is a cannabis
advisory committee that's created as
part of this and one of the things that
they do is look at the tax rate so if we
find that it doesn't seem that we are
keeping moving some of the sales from
either on the street or out of state
into those stores that would be a good
reason to look at either if it's the tax
rate the product offerings and try and
understand why the state didn't get the
market dynamics right the first time
because quite frankly you can't uh make
business Decisions by Committee Action
very well um but it'll give them a
pathway in order to give us
recommendations about how to do that
harm reduction and get it in in better
sync with the actual Market
cycle
thank
you representative Sweeney you have
anything representative
huitt Cher Wier any questions so
far you've given us a lot to read for
sure now you you mentioned you'd like to
see The Liquor Commission basically run
this have you support got their support
for your suggestion or proposal um so
I've want to make sure that I'm not
attributing words that didn't come out
of somebody's word mouth to them um what
I do want to say is that when I've
spoken with them it has seemed like it
would be generally agreeable I can do
some work uh before you have your next
work session and try and figure out
exactly if you give me a list of
stakeholders you want me to check with I
will take it there I will do the
homework I will confirm exactly what I
hear from them and uh let you know what
their perspectives are and also do any
necessary tweaks in order to make it
work for them as
well yeah under the proposal again the
Commerce version I think I counted about
29 positions that would need to be
funded pretty shortly after if the
Bill's passed um do you have an idea how
many people your proposal would require
from liquor or um thank you for the
question my I I did write the one that
came out of Commerce that is my bill
that I've been working on the Amendments
that I have um they deal with moving to
the hard limit of 15 empowering the
Secretary of State the fine on the first
offense clarifying some of the age
restriction restrictions flow through of
removal of dual use um one of the things
that was highlighted was our volatile
compound extraction that was in there we
actually needed to specify it a little
bit more because some of the ways of
extracting it actually do need to be
done in a more controlled way so we
added that into the definitions and set
the requirements clarification in the
advisory committee cleaning up
definitions and then um there just the
change back to saying is liquor
commission instead of the liquor and
cannabis commission so this is not a
large departure from what passed
Commerce what I'm suggesting is just a
few changes um a few small changes
because they were there was also the
deadline there in order to work forward
um and also I'd be very happy to figure
out how to work um with whoever I can in
order to get so sharpen our pencil a
little bit more on the costs and the
expenses quite frankly this is the first
bill of mine that I brought into Finance
so I could have a little bit of
education and making sure that I'm
bringing you exactly what you need and
I'd be happy to put that work in for you
um so the reason why I'm so adamant that
it's this model and if we need to go so
something more tightly controlled it's
the state actually operating it is
because the franchise model is just
something that I will not be able to
support at all that's why I'm putting in
this work that's why I've been trying to
get to something where we all can come
to agreement 2011 reps 13 senators and
one other guy so that we can actually
get this done and I'm going to keep
working as long as you give me more time
in the deadline in order to meet all of
your
requirements so I do have a couple of
additional questions just looking at uh
going to page 32 there's a reference to
a statute RSA
77- on line 24 as far as the Department
of Revenue Administration I could not
find that um in my searches so I'm not
sure maybe it's just a misprint or
somebody typed the wrong number but if
you could check that out okay
um I will absolutely catch that I
thought I tried to follow each of those
breadcrumbs and thank you for catching
one for me page
32 Jo L 24 when I
was and then going to page 44 again the
money aspect um on page 44 line 14 it
talks about the sum of
$500,000 uh for the bium ending in
2025 for treatment prevention Recovery
Fund um it doesn't say where that money
is coming from doesn't say it's being
drawn in a warrant by the governor
coming with a general fund somewhere so
we need to know where that particular
amount of money half a million dollars
is coming from okay thank you I can find
where that would come from and that's
simply to make sure any any increase of
interest because we're talking about it
doesn't lead to people um needing these
services and making sure that we're
taking care of those people already
already using um before we move into
this now I'm going back through you had
a list of percentages going to like the
education fund I think was like 65% or
something but there were a whole list of
um folks that
would 33 that would
benefit
um okay starting on line five on page
33 uh as you know we have the drug and
alcohol fund already so I was curious
about developing this new
fund
um let's see under on line 27 the
substance Ed prevention treatment
recovering fund established
because we already have under rsa's 176
colon 16 Roman 3 the drug and alcohol
fund so You' you be looking to create
even another fund and I'm thinking
wouldn't you just send it to the
governor's drug and alcohol fund um so
part of the challenge with that is this
is something that's still federally
prohibited and it's just a matter of
trying to figure out when you mingle
those funds or not um it may make sense
for the 65 % that goes to the education
trust fund to go in perhaps the the day
the day before it happens or figure out
some way so that it can off set those
local property taxes so it's not
co-mingling there but the intention is
to directly offset local property taxes
with the 65% going to education um
similar and if there's any clarification
you can help me have there to make sure
that we're not comingling funds there
also would be important but that's why
it's separate because if we end up with
any issues with co-mingled funds that's
why most Most states when they've
implemented legalization they have that
five Commissioners in the Massachusetts
cannabis and they're not really
reporting to anybody that's because they
were trying to insulate it enough from
the state so that the federal government
wouldn't come after the state itself at
this point we're maturing but we still
want to be careful with that I mean if
you look at how if you have an improper
trade in your 401k fund when you're 30
they can still come after you when
you're 70 for anything that they deem to
be profits off of those improperly
mingled funds and it basically poisons
most of that account if you had violated
one of the rules early on and so that's
why having a separate fund keeps it
safer considering that it's still
federally
prohibited so um I asked the state
treasurer to be here today because of
the whole co- mangling and if you're
going to take money raised from Cannabis
and you're going to give it to the
education fund or these other agencies
and then somebody at some point comes
back and says uh you can't do this and I
know that there's a cannabis fund that
will be set aside separate that will be
overseen by the state treasury so I'd be
just curious at some point today we'll
call Monica up here from the the state
treasurer to speak to that issue because
that is a big concern if you're giving
all this money out and then somebody
like you say says there's a problem with
giving this money to other sources so
obviously something be a lot easier if
the federal government would just
legalize cannabis but they haven't yet
second um I don't think I have anything
else unless uh representative evil yes
thank you thank you um could you talk a
little bit about how this interfaces
with the atc's and the people that are
actually using the atc's now for medical
marijuana um will they well first of all
there's the issue of whether an ATC will
get any sort of preference but
secondarily will the folks that need Med
medical marijuana then be in a position
position where they have to go to these
newly licensed facilities well thank you
for the question that's actually a big
part of why in the amendment I address
some of the ATC concerns um initially we
looked about having a dual use
certification but that made multiple
people uncomfortable um about having an
entity that would be underneath both The
Liquor Commission and the Department of
Health and Human Services we have rule
making Authority within the law for um
and we have a requirement for the liquor
commission and DHHS to come to us with a
proposal for how they will blend those
two programs while making sure to
prioritize the maintenance of access um
the atc's there this sets out a whole
process by which they will in a in a
clear way set the requirements and the
metrics to assess a good applicant for
one of the Cannabis retail outlets one
of those metrics will need to be
something that reflects the experience
of running a successful cannabis vent
Venture in the state of New Hampshire
which only benefits the atcs because
they have been doing this we can't just
the first thought was to just
automatically give each of the three
atcs one of the licenses but then you
get into other challenges why them why
shouldn't somebody else get one of the
licenses and while they are the ones who
have been providing this access to
patients who need it especially those
with chronic pain and other issues um
it's we also need to make sure we strike
a balance um the amendment that I have
for you include some language just to
make sure that they'll be able to grow
both the therapeutic and adult use um at
the same site subject to appropriate Ru
making and just to make sure that
they're not having to run two separate
businesses because ideally the adult use
will help subsidize the cost of the
therapeutic cannabis um this is one of
those very important issues because we
want to make sure that there's still
that access this also would allow any of
the retail outlets to sell therapeutic
cannabis and that therap utic cannabis
in in my mind would be coming from the
atc's growing it because they have the
experience and knowing which strains
have been shown to be more beneficial in
different uses and to make sure that
that experience is leveraged and by
being able to have a market to sell it
to the other stores that's helps but
just being able to sell it in somebody
else's store isn't enough to be able to
make it so that they can be a more
robust operation and make it so those
prices can come down
because I I I haven't pulled any
patients lately but I have uh plenty of
people that in the past have talked
about the cost of it and I know that the
more that we have give them an
opportunity to make money in a more more
in a more Market driven situation as
opposed to a more therapeutic situation
it should be able to bring the
therapeutic price
down
okay fantastic I can't wait to see what
she said thank
you good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
C Treasurer Monica
mipel
sure I at
the so I saw that um back in November
that you testified before the commission
and you express some of those concerns
that we all know about and one in
particular that state would effectively
be engaged in a state sanction money
laundering due to the Canabis being
illegal and and then of course the
difficulty Banks whether the state
existing banks that the state uses would
be willing to accept money from Cannabis
sales could you expand on that or sure
thank you for for that comment um I'm
just going to clarify that during my
testimony that I think I think that um
that statement that became part of the
report it was part of a conversation so
I think it was just described in the
report that he came from my testimony
but I think was again a conversation at
that time um but it's but it it's true
in terms of um the concerns that I I
mentioned to the commission at the time
were uh what we've been here in you know
all over the country uh there are um
some banks who are U banks are concerned
about the r that they will um take uh
due to the banking loss and some of the
federal laws that they have to comply
with um the other um again the we we
hear and and this is just based on uh
limited information that I've received
there are some banks that are willing to
bank with um and do business with the
Cannabis business um I was um able to
speak to at least two of the banks that
we do business with and um I had two
different responses one um One bank said
yes we we could do we could we could
bank with you um if if you end up with a
bill that has cannabis the other bank
said absolutely not we can we can't do
that so we'll so we'll find that um I
think you know it'll be interesting to
to and and as I mentioned in my previous
testimony we do business with many banks
um with most chter um State chared Banks
um and then we also bank with three
Banks primarily because of their large
footprint we're able to um we conduct
most of our business with those uh three
large um Banks uh in the state and and
and again it will be uh we will have to
really um find out uh if this this bill
passes of some sort of this bill um or
again some some um a canab uh bill
passes we will have to learn and and try
to find out how um you know if we can
conduct business the same way with those
Banks um if not at least we at least we
know that there is one Bank willing to
to uh bank with us so we will have to
work with that particular Bank
uh to to receive the
collections um the other um something
that after after I was doing some
research and we were able to contact the
State of Maine so um I know um we
haven't receive detail information from
Main but this um uh um Main's Treasures
Office is willing to work with us and
try to to we we could learn from them
and and learn their model how they're
how they were able to implement um their
law and also how they conduct their
business so at least we will be able to
learn from um again I've I've been in
touch with Maine but we likely will be
able to learn how all the states U are
able to conduct business with the uh
Federal
challenges yeah main is interesting it's
under the department of administrative
Services up there is a bureau cannabis
which thought that was kind of an
interesting model but are there any
questions for the state treasurer yes
repr
Maguire thank you Mr chairman thank you
Madame Treasurer um does the Liquor
Commission currently for their alcohol
business have their own bank and their
own bank accounts and so on or is
everything through
you we do have separate banks for the
Liquor Commission but it's not
necessarily uh it's just clearly for
convenience at this time uh once we
collect those funds everything gets
pulled we we call pull cash all of the
collections on the state taxes fees
everything that'ss in One bank account
to be able to uh to be able to earn
interest so that's that's how we
typically conduct our business even
though we use separate bank accounts for
this particular case I think we could
accommodate One bank account for this
one fund but when it gets complicated is
really um and as I was listening to the
testimony I started thinking about how
we would be able to separate
funds um can AB
funds we could do as much as we can
again having a separate bank account but
when it's time to transfer funds to the
other agencies that's when it will
become really tricky um everything will
probably this fund the Cannabis fund
will live in the accounting system as
you know as part of the state accounting
system I don't see any resources that
speaks about uh having a separate Ledger
or separate accounting system that will
track this so we will have to become
part of what you know what we use for
the state's business and and and again
when we so doing that we again commingle
the funds so we may be able to collect
them in One bank account but then we
need to start Distributing it to the uh
ultimate recipients of this funds so I
don't know if that will create
additional challenges as I was listening
as I was here if I may follow up so when
the Liquor Commission currently pays
their suppliers the dis the distillers
and you know I don't know Johnny Walker
or somebody do do you write the check do
they on their own bank account or does
it come from from your we do it I mean
it technically is is just the way
mechanically Works uh even though we
collect the Liquor Commission funds in
One bank account ends up again in our
other accounts that we use for um for
our vendor payments so it's One bank
account again we just collect the money
and then we utilize other bank accounts
to facilitate the payments the same with
payroll we have one bank account for
payroll uh another one for vendors and
that's that's how we conduct our
business where are
questions as a followup to
representative Maguire's question I know
that the law specifically states that
liquor is supposed to make daily
deposits and that hasn't been done for a
period of time is that improved at all
or I believe they do uh they I believe
they do that it's just because most of
the businesses with um credit cards and
now they use um saves that automatically
deposits those funds into our bank
accounts so I believe that's um happens
on a daily basis thank
you well seeing no further questions
thanks Monica thanks very
much so we have
um where's banking G uh Wells Todd Wells
Todd Wells here hi
Todd good afternoon Mr chairman and good
afternoon all my name is Todd Wells I'm
the chief Bank examiner of New Hampshire
chartered Banks and Credit Unions I
serve at the New Hampshire banking
Department thank
you so you've heard some testimony today
which has to do with banking's any
further comments or uh I would uh so I
think my best response to that would be
to say uh I was the banking Department's
uh designated represent uh
representative or or serving on the
commission uh to study the legalization
regulation and taxation of marijuana
back uh we issued a final report in
2018 in preparation for uh my attendance
here today I did review that I would
tell you from the perspective of the
federal guidance that is out there
really nothing has changed there was a
the report that we issued under that
commission back in
2018 referenced uh some guidance from
what's known as the financial crimes
enforcement network uh that remains in
place uh I would also uh let you know
that as a department the New Hampshire
banking department has not issued any
kind of a position statement in this
matter nor have we issued any particular
guidance all right thought you looked
familiar uh we've had a number of these
cannabis Commissions in the past and uh
seems we always end up in the same spot
but anyway thanks Todd are there any
questions
all right seeing none thanks again
coming is I have a card here for the
chairman of the Liquor Commission if
he's out there
somewhere
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee Joseph Mala chairman of
the Liquor Commission and Tina deir our
CFO uh We've handed some things out uh
some updated
information through the LBA and
we'd be happy to answer any questions
you have on the
appropriation so we've received as you
already know some changes to the bill
that came through Commerce which we
haven't had a chance to really get into
I guess the LBA and Os will be getting a
draft of those changes to us and we also
have a an amendment that's just been
given to us from the Senate side of
things which we haven't looked at either
but I appre appreciate you being here
and you've probably heard some of the
testimony and again we really just have
in front of us
the the most recent um update as your
the financial impact and looking back at
the financial notes from the original
bill as it was
amended so I see that there was some
disagreement uh with the Liquor
Commission some of the costs that you
felt that probably be greater than what
was set aside in the amendment I think
the amendment called for $2 million for
some of the startup there was an $8
million request in there to get this up
and running um I think I counted about
29 new positions again I don't know what
these new amendments call for but I
guess the big question of the day are
you looking to do this is this something
that the Liquor Commission wants to do
or has an interest in
well that's a difficult question I
suppose but I mean we're we're business
people Mr chairman that's that's what we
do so I mean this is we are quite
frankly the state of New Hampshire is
bleeding money to the states around us
and uh it's not something that we're
interested in seeing as business people
and it's something that we you know we
we s certainly try to take advantage of
as the Liquor Commission but I mean in
the first 10 months of business uh the
state of Vermont had $67 million in
Revenue uh Massachusetts will do $2
billion this year and Maine will
probably do 500 million and uh I've been
to those States and visited a lot of
those stores and I would say 40 to 50%
of the cars in those parking lots are
from the state of New Hampshire so uh we
feel uh a conservative estimate would be
our first full year in business we could
probably take back 10 to 15% of that
business and put it into back into our
state coffers rather than the
surrounding states so is there an
interest on the part of the Liquor
Commission to do that yes sir there is I
do have further questions but I'll open
it up to my colleagues for US
Representative Maguire um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Mr commissioner
um looking at the first year the big
number here you have roughly 9 million
in expenses there's a $5 million item
for says standal government traceability
solution licensing and auditing and Erp
Financial system can you explain that
and why is it so
expensive well we're just going through
the system now the Erp system for uh The
Liquor Commission which is a 39y old
system which uh hasn't been upgraded in
in that many years and I I'm not sure
where we're actually at but I'm say I
would guess that we're somewhere in the
$30 million range um to run the Liquor
Commission business so this is this in
fact was an estimate to run that type of
system separate from the liquor entity
because we didn't want to co-mingle the
funds or blend the funds in case there
was ever an issue with uh the federal
government we wanted to make sure that
we could clearly identify in an audit
what was liquor funds transferred and
what were uh cannabis funds transferred
and
quite frankly I feel it's a probably a
very conservative estimate at around $6
million yes thank you um apparently in
the past there was a bill that passed
the house to um actually uh not have the
liquor um commission sell marijuana at
at themselves directly right and so
would some of these costs um line if
such a bill became long no uh the the
costs that you have in front of you now
are our estimates on a separate model
the main thing with selling it in our
stores so to speak is there's a certain
clientele that comes into uh the liquor
stores and we certainly it's we've
created a family business I was in one
of the stores yesterday there was a
gentle a husband and wife shopping with
their children that's no place for
cannabis to be sold and quite frankly I
don't think that it would I think it
would turn off some of the consumers
that shop in The Liquor Commission
stores to have that co-mingling of
stores so the idea was to go with a
separate a separate model a franchise
model and this is what I had originally
proposed uh in the Commerce Committee
when we did it so it would know the cost
that you see there would not diminish so
I I'm very surprised to hear you say
that because to me alcohol is not
something for children either right well
I'm not I'm not saying that something is
that alcohol is for children at all that
wasn't the statement and that wasn't my
mindset my mindset was that we've
created stores on the highways we're
putting out the RFP for the Hamptons uh
in the upcoming week people stop they
buy their children lunch they they take
advantage of our our roadside stores and
then they go into the liquor store with
their children I I just wouldn't think
that the state would want that exposure
uh of families in a a 21y old uh or an
adult
consumable reference with with cannabis
we just didn't think that it would would
blend we the thing with the Cannabis
Market is is unique in that there's a
certain generation of people that are
very in tune to it and very much buying
the product we saw that during the D the
D the past dry January so the the
alcohol sales
Nationwide declined 45% but the Cannabis
sales Nationwide increased 75% just
during the month of January during the J
January and the and the folks that are
gen Z's and gen xers are drinking less
but they're using they're using cannabis
products so so that's our our our
feeling and our mindset was we have an
established business with the New
Hampshire liquor and wine outwits and we
wouldn't want to uh wouldn't want to
turn off any of our of our consumers
that come here and have shop with us for
many many years we're 90 years in
business this year so we're established
and pretty proud of that thank
you sh represent Sweeney thank you Mr
chairman thank you chairman for being
here so just want to clarify by of the
models presented franchise is is what
what do you support we support the
franchise model that we feel that it's
the best way for the state to go about
about being in business it is uh in in
our mind I I I don't particularly love
the cliche but it is kind of a public
private partnership where the Liquor
Commission would oversee the model but
it would there the benefit to the people
that had the license is and to the jobs
that it would create Vermont created 700
jobs in the first 10 months when they
opened so our model would be at least
that if not more okay thank you thank
you further questions I do have another
one so in the original amendment that we
have before us uh in the fiscal note it
stated that the upper management of the
Liquor Commission should res receive at
least a 10% stipend or increase is that
in your new fiscal note or yes that was
in the note and and the the stien was
for anyone I believe that we we put in
the original language and we had just
passed out if I can find it quickly and
read it but it's not just for upper
management it's for anybody that's going
to be involved with doing two jobs
you're going to be asked to work on uh
the liquor the liquor model your normal
job and then you're going to be asked to
develop a brand new model the Cannabis
model so we felt that it was fair to
motivate folks to do that by giving them
a 10% stien and it would be anyone
involved with it across the board at The
Liquor
Commission and do you have an estimate
of that cost somewhere we
do we estimated at about 200,000 in the
first year
there's not a lot of and as you know
that we've spoken to this many many
times there's not a lot of full-time
positions at The Liquor Commission to
begin with there's only about 400
full-timers that includes our
enforcement our headquarters and our
stores so this is just a what I would
consider a thank you for being able to
to do two jobs and develop velop a new
business that would benefit the state
the 10% stien would would be just
that so you raised a good point about um
bringing more money in supporting the
state uh as you know in Massachusetts
they just have a separate cannabis
commission and they have five
Commissioners with this new role is it
appropriate to just have one I don't
like you know put you on the spot but U
to be quite candidate seems at least to
me that we should have at least more
than one commissioner if there's such a
large agency handling um both cannabis
and
liquor I don't feel that that would be
necessary I think that the the business
that we have in place there used to be
three Commissioners at The Liquor
Commission and one was the chairman uh
about six years ago they made it a
chairman and a Deputy Commissioner uh I
don't feel that in order to run this
business because we're not actually
we're not we're running the back side of
the business the we're running the the
advertising piece we're running the uh
licensing piece so all those folks are
considered in what we've asked as far as
the upper management there's no the the
business piece of it is all being run by
the additional folks that we've asked
for so no I don't feel that there's a
necessary a need for another
commissioner or another layer of
whatever you choose to call that now in
your um again the earlier Amendment and
I don't know if you heard my question uh
it gives a Liquor Commission complete
authority to go into a community with or
without notifying either the local
police the state police or the county is
that something you're comfortable with
or because I'm not I think that if
there's something going on that the
Liquor Commission should certainly
notify the local police of some kind
kind of activity and does not go into
any Community unannounced well the chief
is here but it's my understanding
whenever we go into a community that
Community knows that we're there from a
what the amend say from a liquor
standpoint well I I wouldn't agree that
we would ever have the authority to go
anywhere into a pro into a community and
not let people know they were we're
there and just one more I noticed that
uh there's no fiscal oversight for
transfers
so is that something uh as you know that
there's a requirement for transfers over
$75,000 to come to fiscal that is not in
the amendment so you're allowed to make
any transfers without fiscal
oversight well I think in running any
business we've uh you know we went from
having the ability to run to move 5% of
our total budget and and I certainly
think that in starting a business we
should be able to have that
transferability if the legislature
chooses to confine it at some point or
restrict it at some point that would be
the legislator's decis legislative
decision but I think when we're starting
the business we should have the ability
to transfer the funds to move it and
build the business the way we see that
it needs to be as it grows I guess I
would disagree I think starting a
business you would more likely want that
authority to take a look and there's my
colleague on fiscal Jess Edwards says
the more eyes the more transparency so
well I I I certainly understand uh your
standpoint but the flexibility of of
running a business and opening a
business is what we need and I know that
the time frames and the time constraints
are a big piece of what we're doing here
the states around us have a big lead and
we're going to need to catch up and
we're going to need to catch up quickly
with rules regulations licensing we have
to allow enough time for the people that
come in to get the licenses to build
their buildings put up their green
houses do their retail stores we have to
have a certain look and feel much like
we have with the Liquor Commission
stores so I think that's that
flexibility is necessary in order to be
nimble while we're building the business
now you mentioned rules I noticed that
the the possible rules delay could be
upwards of 20 months you know how
difficult it is to get through the rules
process so when would you guess that the
first day that the state would receive
any sort of return and not have to take
money out of the general fund to keep
this thing going well we just did we
just have redone 11 rule sets at The
Liquor Commission in the last three
years so I certainly understand doing
that as far as I I think it let's let's
find out what the actual bill looks like
and what we're going to pass and then
I'd be more than happy to answer that
question I appreciate that yeah because
we have a lot of things in front of us
that we haven't seen until today so it
kind of sets us back a little bit and
apologize for that represent Maguire
thank so um in the franchise model
Amendment it gives you control over
prices of products is it is it the case
that every store would have exactly the
same product and the exactly the same
price and so on and and any kind of
promotions would be common among all the
stores uh there would be our feeling
would be that there be certain over I
think the word that we wanted to use was
oversight of pricing we wanted to make
sure that we had the ability to look and
see what the franchises were carrying
and make sure that we were price
competitive hopefully beating the states
around us when it comes to those
particular products so we wanted to have
oversight of those products regardless
of what they were when they're cannabis
related as far as other other items that
the stores would carry not on cannabis
you know Swag t-shirts merchandise
whatever it would be that's up to the
the business individually but we
wouldn't want uh the stores to be
overpricing or price gouging uh our uh
consumers and making us uncompetitive
and as far as what the stores carried no
all we would ask of the franchisees is
that they let us know what they're
carrying in their stores and if they
wanted to differentiate from store to
store What They Carried or if there was
a specific grower that they had a
business relationship with that they
wanted to bring that product in we're
fine with that thank
you so you may have been out of the room
when I asked this question earlier one
of the things I noticed it said that if
there was a disciplinary matter brought
up before the commission uh the
commissioner would set whatever
suspension or fines or whatever without
the possibility of a hearing now as you
know like Lottery has hearings if
someone's upset by one of their decision
would you be opposed to having uh a
hearing so someone could defend
themselves if they found that the
commission was wrong or at least
alleging that it was wrongdoing on the
commission's part no absolutely not just
like we do on the liquor side of the
house uh people are allowed to come to
our weekly meetings and they're allowed
they're all public hearings and they're
allowed to uh have uh a hearing in front
of the Commission in front of our
hearings officer on any dispute that
they that they have
I I wouldn't be against that at all no I
think that it would be prudent quite
frankly well thank you for your
testimony and uh sorry your able
assistant wasn't able to speak on
anything but more than able assistant
thank you thank you Mr chairman thank
you members of the
committee so with Devin
chaffy
honorable members of the
committee
sorry thank you thank you and good
afternoon um and thank you for the
opportunity to comment I will be brief
um I just want to first start by saying
that I have so much respect for all of
the work that has gone in to this effort
um and I just sort of want to share I
think some of the um sentiments that
representative Sweeney uh indicated
earlier which is that we have a very
unique opportunity this year with
regards to actually making progress on
this effort of moving forward with
legalization of cannabis Senator Bradley
has recognized that we have the votes in
the Senate the governor has indicated
that with certain um conditions he will
sign the bill it's a very you know for
those of us who have been working on
this issue for many many many many years
many of you whom have uh the idea that
we could finally move this across the
Finish Line I think is very exciting I
have a very uh small and discreet issue
that I want to bring to the committee um
and some unintended p uh potential costs
that might be associated with that issue
and it has to do with um an issue that
representative Leon referred to earlier
um with the increase in penalties for
smoking in public um you can find it in
the version of HB 1633 that passed the
house you can find it on page nine lines
um lines 13 through
15 where you see that um the uh the
penalty for the third offense for
smoking in public uh it is uh you should
one should be guilty of an undefined
misdemeanor it just says guilty of a
misdemeanor it's unspecified because it
doesn't specify whether it should be a
Class A or a last b um what this means
is that under existing law if you are
caught with less than
34 uh of an ounce of marijuana on that
third offense um the that the highest
def the highest penalty that you can
receive is a Class B misdemeanor under
existing law um what this means is
essentially should this pass uh the
state will be on the hook for providing
potentially providing a public defender
to represent any individual who is
charged with a class a misdem meter um
under this um elevated penalty here in
addition to any costs of potentially um
holding an individual who's convicted of
a Class A misdemeanor in jail this is
because with a Class A misdemeanor you
can actually face jail time whereas a
Class B misdemeanor which is still a
crime it still has Hefty fines of up to
$1,200 so significant penalty still
creates a criminal record for the
individual um but that wouldn't require
uh the state to pay for public defenders
or potentially pay to hold this person
who was smoking in public in jail um and
so it's it's a very easy fix um uh to
address these potentially
unintended uh costs coming from them all
you would have to do is insert the word
Class B in front of Miss demeanor on
line 15 um and I would just really
encourage the committee as you're going
I think this is an issue that will
likely be present in all I don't I
haven't seen all of the versions that
you've seen but I believe that it is
likely a concern that would apply to any
version of it that's likely before you
and I would ask that you give serious
consideration as to whether or not New
Hampshire taxpayers should be paying for
public defenders for somebody who was
caught smoking in public or whether or
not that should be um specified as a
class be
misdemeanor thank you so
much so that's it nothing else gets your
attention that is my primary concern
thank you are there any questions
representative eil so I just want to
make sure everybody understands what you
said this bill the way it's written
makes uh changes the class of
misdemeanor to a higher class than what
it is now correct under the under this
existing under this under existing law
if you if you're SM if you were smoking
in public and had less than 3/4 of an
ounce which most people that would it
would be less than 3/4 of an ounce the
highest penalty that you can face is a
Class B misdemeanor under this law under
the the the bill as passed by the house
you could potentially face jail time
which would be a significant increase in
penalty and that would have an
Associated cost to the state represent
Maguire thank you Mr chairman thank you
um there's a similar thing I think for
for consuming while operating a mo
moving vehicle should that be the
same I think the issue with related to
consuming while operating a vehicle I
think is clearly a that is clearly a a
much more significant crime that may
warrant more significant penalties
you're talking about potentially putting
people in danger if you're consuming a
substance that's going to you know alter
your state while driving um so I would I
would I I think that there's a clear
distinction to be be made there I'm not
saying that you shouldn't Rec you know
consider that there might be similar
considerations but from our perspective
we're certainly more concerned with that
third offense for simply smoking in
public which is in our opinion a much
more minor crime just in general I've
spoken to police and asked them this
question and they say they never have
problems with with cannabis it's all
with alcohol so you know anyways thank
you thank you very much thanks
Dr Joe
Hannon good afternoon members of the
committee uh my name is Joe Hannon uh I
was a former legislator myself in the
Commerce Committee years ago and after I
left um voluntarily I
guess depends if the voters ATS say um I
I was on the Cannabis study Commission
in 2018 uh did extensive uh work on this
then I've been a part of the Coalition
that is helping to craft some of the
legislation for the last uh year and
even before that um I I just wanted to
run a couple anecdotal things past you
to maybe give some context or Clarity to
things that have already been said um
you know as far as uh our familyfriendly
liquor stores that are on the side of
the highways as you enter the state of
New Hampshire um I'm someone who's in
recovery from alcohol and other
substances for well over 30 years uh
alcohol was probably one of the most
horrible things that I'd encountered Ed
and I had encountered a lot of stuff um
I had been to one liquor store when I
was here and it was at an opening at the
liquor store in eping when I was a um
representative like yourselves and I was
a dignitary I saw the chairman give a
nice speech about how it's a safe
product that it's regulated it's much
more um it's a better thing to be
regulated um and that was the first time
I was in a store the second time was
recently when I was in the in the stores
looking at the labels because we were in
the last Commission was talking about oh
we have to have labels that are safe and
kid-friendly and all that and I took
hundreds of pictures of the bottles in
the liquor store of all the labels that
I don't know if I'd call them child safe
but I'm not arguing about that but when
I was there interestingly enough I
noticed a little child and we heard
there were kids in the stores because of
f familyfriendly environment there was a
little child walking around and I'm
thinking oh I didn't know you were
allowed in here cuz I've gone to visit
dispensaries and other states and every
single one I've been in Maine Vermont
Massachusetts you have should not only
give ID at the door they won't let you
in if it's not a current valid ID I was
behind a lady who was obviously in her
late 80s or 90s who had a expired
driver's license cuz she hasn't driven
since probably the late 80s and they
wouldn't let her in meanwhile there's a
5-year-old child running around the
store hanging on the shopping cart full
of booze they get to the cat checkout
register and the lady that works at the
store one of the employees of the state
hands the kid a lollipop so what better
incentive than to have a family-friendly
environment where we give the kids candy
come back to the liquor store kids as
I'm walking out out I see now you may if
any of you have had kids you notice that
they put all the candy at the checkout
aisle at eye level for children there
are a bucket of candy canes that were
Hollow filled with shots of hard liquor
right by the door this high off the
ground now I didn't notice it at first
so I noticed the kid then I started
looking around a little more and I
noticed that I thought it was a little
strange so I I think the familyfriendly
thing I think it's a brand that that the
state might not want to have interrupted
because sales do go down especially
amongst younger individuals um who just
don't really drink as much I uh
approached uh I'm on the board of ham
New Hampshire cannabis um New Hampshire
um cannabis and we had one of our other
board members is a pretty prominent Tik
Tock artist and she has hundreds of
thousands of followers and we went
downtown Manchester to ask people
questions you know about their use
legalization what they felt and we were
kind of amazed that most of the young
people we talk to don't really claim to
drink that much they'd much rather smoke
a legal safe
product um in Canada and other places
they've seen the cost of uh the liquor
sales go down especially in those
demographics and we heard the chairman
also say in dry January that prices
sales went down cannabis sales went up
there are other things you also see
other than alcohol consumption possibly
going down um opioid prescriptions have
gone down uh significantly in states
that have legalized spec First Medical
and then actually recreational uh opioid
prescriptions not all prescriptions went
down but they looked at coding spefic
specifically and Codine is one of the
easier narcotic prescriptions to get
it's one of the things that most people
that are in recovery could tell you well
it started they gave me Codine or perco
setes that was one of the things that
went down significantly in the in the
years right after legalization uh
insurance premiums had gone down
significantly uh I can't remember the
exact number I can find it for if you'd
like but it was well over $5 $1600 for
the average insurance premium cost that
went down um so if we're worried about a
few million here and there and we look
at the revenue that's coming in from
other states it's not even close if we
give 6 million 8 million whatever it is
if um you know if we give the liquor
Commissioners and the employees Li
commissioner sorry there's only one uh
if we give the commissioner and the
employees a 10% bonus which you know I
find funny that it keeps popping up in
their versions of the bill and
amendments um and also we have this
drastic need for no lobbying from the
corner office and other people in the
Senate and representative for this bill
put that in there no lobbying whatsoever
so the fact that they need more
employees to go over how advertising is
done there won't be
any they don't need 29 employees for 15
stores for that uh it's a licensing
apparatus unless they're actually
involved in the implementation of the
store design and all this other stuff
picking out locations you know giving
those locations to set in certain
individuals you know I don't know how
the process works I'm sure it's an open
process of RFP stuff but um it's it's a
pretty non-transparent thing to have I
believe one person person and I'm not
saying we have to change that now it's
kind of late if the Senate wants to do
it I welcome that um you know last thing
um what else I think I've said enough
damaging things uh but uh if there's any
questions about uh you know what's
happened at the last commission the the
1918 2000 sorry 2018 commission or
anything in the past year I'd be happy
to take
them represent Maguire thank you Mr
chairman thank you Dr for coming
um regardless regarding your point about
comparing the harms of alcohol to to
cannabis and also you said about your
own addiction problem would you believe
that if you were to go to the CDC
website and look up whether cannabis is
addictive it'll tell you 10% of users
are addicted okay but it has a reference
to an article a medical article and when
you go look at that medical article this
is an arttic it from 2011 and it
compared the
addictiveness of
nicotine
cocaine alcohol and
cannabis okay and what the article
actually says is nicotine 67%
addictive alcohol 23%
addictive cocaine 21% % day and cannabis
9% so not not only did they raise 9% to
10% right but but it sounds like when
you first look at their page it's it's
10% addictive oh my God but but it's
it's half as much as cocaine you know
what I mean so do is that comport with
your understanding I know many people
who are in recovery who actually use
cannabis uh I know people who were heavy
smokers who uh they may no longer smoke
cigarettes or cigars or tobacco but they
chew gum or use patches sometimes for
years I'm one of those people I quit
smoking cigarettes probably
33 34 years ago 33 years ago smoke
cigars for a while now I chew gum all
all the time all the time and I don't
care about I don't have a problem with
going I don't mind if people smoke now I
don't mind I don't have this urge to go
have a cigar or do something that's more
harmful to myself I have a way to
mitigate that harm that's what harm
reduction is harm reduction and we keep
hearing the governor and other people
talk about this is a harm reduction Bill
not a money-making Bill well except the
commissioner talked about this is a
business and you know so if we want it
to be a business I think that's the
person that should do this it's also a
question I asked in the last Commission
in 2018 I said you know I I praise them
for doing a great job at the commission
they have a big advertising budget they
do a great job getting a quality product
to as many people as they possibly can
and raising a lot of money for the State
of New Hampshire so if we wanted to sell
as much cannabis as possible put them in
charge of it now in the beginning it
might be a slow roll out but in the end
like with alcohol it's we don't have a
alcohol control State anymore to keep
people from drinking or having access to
alcohol that that ship has sailed a long
time ago now that mandate to do that to
do specifically that make it a safer
less accessible product is one of the
biggest businesses in New Hampshire now
and I think that's what we're going to
see if we set New Hampshire up to be a
state purely run without having any
other buyin uh from private sector I
think that's a mistake um
I I couldn't understand the 15 stores
and I asked some Senators who were
pushing this and you know that heard
from the governor directly so I heard
indirectly that how are you going to
have 15 stores unless they can the and
we heard an industry person who I think
might be here talk about that each store
would have to do about $2 million a
month in Revenue to to deal with the
demand that's going to be in New
Hampshire that's a lot that's more than
many of the state liquor stores actually
make but most of these liquor stores are
not little You Know hole-in-the-wall
Places they're giant you know Warehouse
type Stores um you know that's how
you're going to have 15 stores you're
going to have to have these massive
structures that are going to be you know
that's the only way it's going to work
if you have 15 little stores here and
there nobody's going to be really going
there unless they live around the corner
um and the other thing is the state has
the a mandate for this the sole sale of
alcohol because the 21st amendment when
alcohol prohibition was repealed
specifically gave States the man the
total control of Commerce of alcohol
within their states
that that doesn't happen for any other
product that I'm aware of so the fact
that New Hampshire State wants to take
over the control of an industry that
doesn't have the ability to do and the
argument is well it's illegal for them
to do it and it's illegal for us so
what's the difference if we break the
law I think there's a big difference
especially if we're looking at the
long-term Financial impacts of a program
that right now it's illegal to have
Interstate sales but we're going to have
a banking law change soon I believe I we
we keep hearing it but I think it's very
close we even heard the president talk
about changes coming very soon with the
rescheduling and also we're going to
have banking changes so it's just a
matter of time before we have some kind
of Interstate sales or some kind of
program to do that the reason why the
state is so so successful in alcohol
sales is because they have a legal and
rightful Monopoly under the Constitution
and the 21st amendment to be the only
people to do it but they can also get it
from anywhere they want they don't have
to wait for a bunch of people that
they've handed licenses to in New
Hampshire to grow it they can go to Iona
they can go to Italy they can go
wherever they want and buy alcohol to
sell in the New Hampshire stores that's
why it works if you have only a market
in New Hampshire and the state is the
only person selling it how are they
going to compete with larger states with
more outdoor growing or more uh lower
energy costs they can do more indoor
grows we are going to put ourselves at a
significant disadvantage if we prop up
this program and it might be a slow roll
out in the beginning but then we're
going to be stuck with it and you know
there's nothing more temporary more
permanent than a temporary government
program so I don't think this is the way
we should be doing this I can keep going
and I'd love to rant but I know you have
other people to hear and it's getting
late seeing no further questions uh
thank you thank you
all Matt
Simon from Nasher Granite Leaf
cannabis
thank you Mr chairman honorable
committee for the record Matt Simon I
work for granite Leaf cannabis uh we are
one of the three licensed alternative
treatment centers that supplies
therapeutic cannabis to uh just over
14,000 patients who are now registered
as part of New Hampshire's
program
so again we do support the bill uh we
support the Amendments that have been
offered by the prime sponsor I'd like to
thank the prime sponsor for all the hard
work she's put in to trying to thread
this difficult needle I've personally
been working on cannabis policy for 17
years in the state and I'm pleased that
we're finally close to being able to
pass a legalization Bill however I
remain very concerned about some of the
details uh just as some background I was
part of the Coalition that helped write
HB 639 so I'm very much on record as
preferring that model uh and I'm on
record as opposing the actual State
Monopoly model that would have had state
run stores uh this fall we participated
in the study commission we were asked to
comment on the franchise model and we
indicated that we were willing to work
within the framework of the franchise
model I would respectfully disagree with
the prime sponsor uh that in the
comparison with the State Monopoly model
I believe if we were to go down the road
of state run stores and then we were to
find out that that is problematic from a
legal perspective federally and there
are a number of ways that could happen
that it would be very difficult to
change course the state would have
already made a large investment and have
gone down a path that would that would
be very likely to wind up as a
boondoggle uh so I think the franchise
model if it does it is a unique model so
it may encounter difficulties uh but if
it does I think it would be much easier
to change some details and uh you would
still have private businesses operating
the franchise with some changes that
could be made a a program that would be
less problematic uh but I wanted to
mainly comment on on what we've been
asked to comment on throughout this
process which is the impact on
registered therapeutic cannabis uh
patients on the therapeutic cannabis
program and on the atcs that that have
been serving patients now for almost 8
years each
um this is a program that has been under
a lot of scrutiny ever since it passed
uh I would submit that if there had been
problems that you would have heard about
them and read about them by now and uh I
believe that the three companies that
have been doing this have been doing it
under a microscope have complied with
complex regulations
and um both from a policy perspective
but more uh to the relevance of the
focus of this committee from a revenue
perspective I think one of the biggest
mistakes New Hampshire could make would
be to try to move forward with cannabis
legalization without incorporating the
existing businesses and the existing
program we've learned a lot in the last
eight years and it would be a shame to
not do that New York is probably the
biggest example of a state that tried to
build a new adult use program from
scratch without incorporating medical
canvas businesses and they're very much
regretting it at this point uh and that
Pro that roll out has been
a big disaster so it would it would be
advantageous from a revenue uh and an
easy rollout perspective if the existing
businesses have a clear path to
licensing and are able to participate in
all of these license types it is the
retail license that are by far of the
most
interest uh Most states have seen fit to
have existing medical cannabis
businesses have a very easy if not a
guaranteed path to licensing and uh
generally it's as long as your
application is complete your licens is
in good standing you shall be issued
this license so we proposed that to the
study commission we encountered a lot of
opposition uh so the language that is in
the Commerce Amendment on this
establishes that it shall be a major
criteria in the application process that
at that previous experience that we have
oper ating in the state so we think that
language is is very important uh one of
the issues with the bills that came out
of Commerce was that language only
applied to retail licenses it did not
apply to the other license types so I
believe the amendment although I haven't
seen the amendment I believe that it
applies that same language to all of the
license types and that's one reason I
think it's very important um Vermont has
had adult use sales for about a year and
a half now uh they've reportedly had a
50% decrease in patient registrations
and a similar decrease in sales within
the medical cannabis space uh the report
that I've passed around is a a research
report that we presented to the study
commission uh looking at the experiences
of other states that have moved from
medical cannabis to adult use and
similarly finds that nearly all states
have a major decrease in registered
patients and in sales on the medical
side so that is the biggest concern that
we have is that this new program May
simply wipe away the the old
program uh the commissioner in Vermont
warned the legislature in Vermont
recently that the Standalone medical
dispensaries are in danger of closing no
longer being
viable basically as soon as you can buy
cannabis anywhere without having a card
uh that removes people's incentive to
get the card and uh you for now has 73
retail locations they only have seven or
eight uh medical dispensary locations so
you probably live much closer to an
adult use store and the adult use stores
are mostly giving patients a tax cut
they're they're paying the taxes for the
patients uh I've heard this informally
that they're just oh if you show your
card we will give you a discount that
offsets the tax we'll pay the tax on
your behalf so the current bill does
exempt patients from the agency fee
which we think is appropriate
um but if the atcs are not able to get
at least one retail license a piece
there is great danger that they will not
be viable companies and that they will
not be able to operate Standalone
dispensaries so from our perspective if
there only going to be 15 licenses those
are going to be very sought-after and in
demand we think the atc's need at least
one of them in order to be not only
viable but able to
improve the services we offer to
patients this should be an opportunity
to expand and improve access to patients
in addition to extending access to
adults from our perspective most people
who use cannabis we hear the word
recreational a lot I actually stopped
using it a long time ago because poll
after poll of cannabis consumers
indicates that most people who use
cannabis do so at least partly for
medical reasons if not entirely so we
don't want to lose the program that
we've got we want to learn from it and
we want to incorporate it and integrate
it into this so be happy to take any
questions I appreciate your comments I
couldn't have said it better well thank
you very much Mr chairman so how many
atcs are there in New Hampshire now you
said six there are three companies
companies operating seven dispensary
locations I know they grow a lot of my
community of Peterboro there's a large
facility there that's my company's
production facility is is the one
located in Peterboro so so right now is
the Department of Health and Human
Services they oversee your operation
testing qualifying inspection all that
every aspect of it from seedling to sale
patient
registrations so I I'll be candid as I
try to be all the time but I think the
15 store model is a disaster so I
certainly agree with what you said that
you folks are already in the business
you know it you've got a long record of
doing it without a heavy hand of the
state so just want to put that out there
represent Maguire thank you thank you Mr
chairman thank you Mr Simon for coming
um so if the atc's
converted in under these
bills would that be seven of the 15 or
three of the 15 or how does that work so
that's a great question
what Most states have done is they have
allowed dual use retail so you have a
medical dispensary you create a separate
counter for adult youth sales a separate
counter for medical sales you operate
from the same location this is obviously
much cheaper and more efficient way to
have a roll out that's what we would
prefer to have and that's what was in HB
639 which got 10 votes in the Senate but
did not become law uh there are some on
the study Commission who objected to
that I won't put words in their mouth to
try to explain why they did but they
felt it would be unfair to
allow our businesses to have any
advantage in the licensing process uh so
we we're willing to live with some
degree of un uncertainty uh the prospect
of this moving forward without us
getting any retail licenses it puts not
only our companies but the entire
program in Jeopardy so so understanding
that we weren't going to get a
guaranteed license uh out of the Senate
we instead pushed for this language that
we feel reduces the risk uh both to the
program and to our
companies sure so so I heard a story at
lunch about someone who a patient who
chooses not to buy in the the local
store the the medical store in New
Hampshire they they go to Vermont
because the price is so much cheaper or
just in the regular retail store would
prices for medical come way down if this
bill passes well I believe they would it
would one of there are several issues
that contribute to higher costs of
medical cannabis in New Hampshire one is
the fact that we have to grow entirely
indoors there's a bill that would change
that uh other states allow outdoor and
greenh Greenhouse cultivation which is
much cheaper that's just one of many um
the other is the limited number of
patients so when there were only a few
thousand patients and we're all creating
a broad range of products and making
very small batches of them we're not
able to benefit from the economies of
scale whereas if we could expand our
production facility grow more cannabis
for adults also be a we we would be able
to pass those cost savings on to
patients there were some Provisions in
HB 639 that would have spelled that out
more clearly and required us to uh
maintain low costs and a broad uh
Services broad spectrum of products for
patients I'm afraid that's not in the
current bill but uh it's certainly very
much Our intention we want to make
therapeutic cannabis more affordable we
have decreased our prices o over the
last couple of years uh some of those
patients aren't checking our menu often
and may not be aware of that but we've
worked hard to get our prices down and
this would enable us to do that more I
believe further
questions seeing none thank you very
much appreciate your
testimony
Senor good afternoon thank you for
having me for the record Senator Daryl
abbis I represent District 22 I serve
the communities of pum Salem ACC and
plastow I am testifying in opposition to
the the draft because um I can go into
the specifics why but I do know I heard
a lot of the testimonies saying this
this will pass and this will get
supported that draft does not have to
support in the state inate at least by
my whip count there's 24 of us I would
say 10 at best so so that's a d I'm
sorry that's a draft that we received a
copy of at the beginning of the hearing
no no what what was I believe passed the
Commerce Bill yes so your there's and
when I say there's some opposition to
that I I understand that this this has
been something been worked on for
multiple years and it's really a um
compromise among several individuals and
I would point out
that a lot of the compromis from people
who had traditionally voted against
cannabis legalization including myself
if anyone serving the house of me last
two terms it doesn't matter if it was
roll called I I was doing the floor
speeches in opposition to many of the
bills so I think it's fair to say I I'm
just trying to be as transparent as
possible wouldn't expect anything less
from you so yeah well um so the we just
got a copy I guess this is your proposal
that we just got a received a copy today
I don't want to take credit for the
whole document because like I said it's
a compromise so every provision in there
myself I may not necessarily personally
agree with but it's something that I
would support as part of the compromise
and one of the compromises is the
franchise model uh if last ter we had HB
98 that was the full State Control model
where the state would really run the
store and the state employees be working
in the store they would pay to build out
the store I my opinion I actually like
that the best the compromise between
that and just a you know an open market
was the State Franchise model and I
think there been some criticism over the
amount of stores that's part of the
compromise as well will that number stay
at 15 five 10 years from now highly
doubtful but I also think what other
states did they kind of came out too
fast and you saw the market kind of
collapse on itself for some reason every
single state has done that I can't
imagine why every other state that wants
to follow that same direction I rather
start slow and go the opposite way and
then take our time because when the
market drops out you have stores going
out of business in a franchise model if
one goes out out of business it's bad
for the brand itself The Branding
identity if there's a fast food chain
and a store goes out of business it
makes the brand look bad so the idea is
that you want to protect your
franchisees you don't want to put
someone in business set them up only to
have them fail so the idea is we rather
them have over demand that they can't
even keep up with the demand and that's
a very good reason to come to the
legislator and ask for more stores but
right now I know if you change that
number from 15 to 16 it's it breaks the
compromise so I would just recommend in
whatever version we have we leave it at
that future legislators I'm sure can
look into that uh some of the other I
think uh difficult issues that is the
over it I believe the bill that came out
of uh Commerce there was dual oversight
between DHHS and the Liquor Commission
when it comes to the enforceability of
the rules uh and in respect to some of
the rules that came up in different
hearings we had over the fall in the in
the the Cannabis commission that we had
some of those rules seem very difficult
to enforce once the product's in the
retail
store liquor needs to be in charge of
enforcing that but they're not going to
have any saying what the rules are so it
seemed kind of
a it didn't seem like that was going to
work so I think the commission really
adjusted from that so I think you're
going to have therapeutic products in
every single franchise store every
franchise you can sell therapeutic
products so you don't need to have this
dual license issue it's if you have the
therapeutic card you're going to be able
to buy it if you don't have it then you
can't buy the therapeutic grade product
that's defined in what was provided to
the committee today I think when it
looks at some of the um I Heard the lob
the issue with the lobbying language hey
I get it we all love free speech I don't
think it's a First Amendment violation
for two reasons number one you're
voluntarily opting into a franchise
agreement how have you ever seen any
franchise in any industry where
franchisees coming before the
legislature going against the franchise
or I've never heard of that happening
because it's in the franchise agreement
to not do that if you have all these
franchisees paddling in different
directions the hire things going to be a
disaster on top of that the Liquor
Commission they're not allowed to have a
lobbyist so they can't even actually
they're going to have to come in
themselves and they're not going to be
to put the same money into it that
that's the reason now we could did a
better job explaining that during the
commission this fall so I'll take some
responsibility for that but that is a
huge issue also the first amendment
restricts it says the government shall
not restrict a person
speech if you're operating in a business
relationship as a quasi state agent
offering a franchisee you're essentially
a government actor
yourself so I don't think it's a
violation of the First Amendment for
that reason and there's an interest to
not have that if every other franchise
agreement are is doing that so I I don't
think that's going to be the um the end
all be all this there is a severability
clause if one of the franchises really
wants to take that and challenge that
and it where it gets struck down the
rest of the bill will survive we did put
that in in the um the paperwork
some of the revenue allocations are
different I um talking with some of my
colleagues on the other side of the wall
of the house we kind of discussed we
thought that Community um not sure if
I'm calling it right the community
preservation or Community investment
fund we didn't think that we thought
that was too diluted to really make a
significant difference not that there
was any um anything in there that we had
an issue with and so much it was just
too it was cut up too many times um I
think the big sale sales pitch I had
last term when I was in the house was
property taxes property taxes property
taxes so I re reallocate most that to
the to the swept one of the compromises
was to put some money towards some legal
aid uh the reason for that is you know I
understand there's different opinions on
the injustices of illegal cannabis to
the extent that that exists ultimately
the best way to address that is with
legal representation our nonprofit Legal
Services already underfunded anyway I'm
sure this committee is well aware of
that so that was kind of a compromise we
came up with with
uh the smoking in
public if you get caught smoking in
public multiple times which is when the
misdemeanor would in in invoke
itself I'm not sure you're even trying
to hide it it's really a difficult thing
to get caught doing never mind multiple
times and the number one complaint I get
from people who oppose legalization is
the when you go to Massachusetts a main
or New York all you can do is smell it
so some of us
want to go to our constituent
constituents and actually put a penalty
that's we can explain well we may allow
Recreation but we're not going we're
going to be tough on public use
especially for repeat offenders to get
caught violing that you had to reach in
your pocket or whatever you got your bag
pull it out literally light it and smoke
it and still get caught doing it you're
going out of your way you're willfully
ignoring the law there's no excuse for
anyone to get caught violating that
multiple times unless they just
completely disregard the law so that's
part of a compromise and for the people
who are against the idea of the you know
having this this type of penalty I think
there's a they're getting a lot more
than they giving up that's that's in my
opinion uh the comparisons to alcohol
which I believe was legalized about 90
years ago it evolved over time I think
this will too Rome wasn't built in a day
this is a good starting point but with
what's presented with this agency
model it's a re branding of what just is
was the in the private lies they changed
the name of it to a retail outlet store
you're just giving a person a license to
sell operate a retail store that's it
you can call whatever you want but it's
not it's not any different than really
what was in 16 uh 639 it's just simple
as that that that's a non-starter with
me I can I can say that with confidence
so um some of the other things I would
just point out the possession limits a
raised significantly I don't know if
it's the same as what was in the
Commerce version but we're talking about
4 ounces of flour significantly higher
so that's the other reason why you want
to take into consideration some of the
driving laws and public use laws is that
you're allowing people to have much
larger quantities on them than 3/4 of an
ounce so some of the other I would just
say important things I I hear the issue
of liquor controlling the price and not
controlling the price understand and
this happened in Massachusetts it's
happened in other states States some
cultivators may also operate a
franchisee some may not and if you're
one if you're cultivated you can grow a
lot flood the market with your product
causes the price to go down some
franchisees may be able to operate at a
loss for some time some may not not
everyone's going to have the same
Financial stability as the next well one
that's obviously you don't want that to
happen to a
franchisee because it makes the brand
look bad back to that but also if liquor
can control the price and someone did
attempt to manipulate the market which
has happened like clockwork in literally
every
state if they can control the sale price
guess what it doesn't matter they a
cultivator chose to do that and guess
what this is what the price is so that's
it it stops that it actually is a
protection for the franchisees you don't
want something like that to happen uh I
think when it it comes to some of the
finance questions I would obviously
welcome any input on the the draft that
was provideed to this committee today uh
what I understand just looking at voting
records of some of my colleagues in in
the Senate if you look at the finance
committee I would be surprised it came
out with a negative uh if it came out
with a positive recommendation unless
someone changes their mind who's
historically been against it so with
that being said I think this this is the
finance committee that would give it the
best shot and I think it in
fairness I would welcome that because
whatever became law I should really I
think I would really value value the
input of the fin of both finances
committee but I don't see the votes
coming out as friendly across the wall
so for that reason when I know that
there's a version that would get signed
I say I'm not saying this draft that's
written would get signed I wouldn't put
something forward that I didn't think
would become law so part of the
compromise is that this is as close as I
think it's going to
get if you understand where I'm coming
from I wouldn't put something in there
that I thought was a deal
breaker well thanks for your testimon no
will give this a deep dive of
understanding that uh we just got it
today your Amendment and as someone and
I know when you were in the house you
were advocate for medical marijuana and
U I don't I don't believe I was as
strong of an advocate for the
therapeutic well you weren't not not as
much as they when you were in criminal
justice I thought you
were so when it comes to the therap
there's some one benefit that the draft
you have I'm just kidding I I think when
it comes to the therapeutic
product if any retail store is able to
sell it they have more distribution
points also any franchise fee that's in
there every product would be subject to
that franchise fee and I don't think
that some people kind of bck at that and
they say well oh the patient it
shouldn't have to pay for that the
therapeutic the uh the therapeutic
providers now if they become a retail
store they're going to make plenty of
extra money off the retail sales that
they shouldn't have to pass that on to
the a and they're also going to be able
to distribute their product through
multiple retail outlets as opposed to
the the stores they have now so they'll
be in a better position as well we're
not guaranteeing anyone a license I'm
heavily opposed to that I just don't
think that that's proper for the
legislator to do I I think it's fair to
set up a pathway to get one in take into
consideration someone's uh professional
experience including working in the
therapeutic industry but the guarantee
of license I think is highly
inappropriate if we were going to go
that wrote I would certainly put my name
on that list the guarantee license and
any of you find that egregious is
exactly why you shouldn't do
it questions for the good
Senator thank you Mr chairman thank you
Senator um did I just hear you say that
that a a len will have multiple
locations I thought it was this is
limited to 15 locations then that's it
so a therapeutic um someone the
therapeutic stores now if they wanted to
become a franchisee they're doing that
under their own no one's making them do
anything they're choosing to become a
franchisee they're asking they're fill
out the application if they get
approved but their product that they
manufacture and that they cultivate that
can be sold out of any retail store
that's as their as them as the
manufacturer and cultivator that's up to
them if they want to sell that and if
they want to educate the employees and
those
franchisees uh they can do that but that
gives them much more opportunities to uh
distribute their product I understand
okay so this might be a good time um I
met somewhat I know you've talked to the
governor extensively and I've met uh
with his representative the other uh the
other day and he gave me a list of items
that for the governor is sort of a
must-have and and you know I don't mind
saying the quiet part out loud of it
which is what he his message to me was
the governor
doesn't really want this that much right
he he he he would not be super upset if
it doesn't come to pass or if it did
come to pass he's somewhat neutral right
and so therefore since he's the one who
cares the least he has the most
control if you see what I mean right
checks and balance is at its best by the
way yeah that's what that's what our
system of government is is that we we're
supposed to work across the wall right
into the other divisions cross party
lines that's what we're supposed to do
so this is really this is a bipartison
issue that I hoping we all work together
and I don't mean to come in here and say
oh this has no what I'm just trying to
be honest because in my own committee I
sit on the the Judiciary Committee which
I believe would be the first committee
I'm fairly confident if you look at the
voting records in there it's already
pretty
tight yeah all right well anyways I'd
like to read these and see if you um
agree that these are what the governor
wants and and also that that's what's in
your Amendment okay number one it's not
just mine it's a remember it's a
collective effort all right fine but you
you were the drafter I believe all right
I'm not even taking credit for that okay
uh the franchise model run by The Liquor
Commission that that is one that is 100%
in there okay uh no smoking in public no
use public use
right yeah well the first offense is
still a violation and that was for me
compromise cuz I still think getting
caught the first time is egregious but
okay trying to work with everyone here
are you okay with the class B Mr meanor
or the third offense or whatever second
offense I I think the compromise may
require the second offense to be a
misdemeanor
that's oh as opposed to a class B M yes
I see and again to get caught smoking in
public is extremely difficult especially
unless you don't you literally just go
out of your way and smoke freely like
it's not a big deal ice okay
um well anyway all right um the Edibles
do not appear to be
candy I I believe that is in in the um
draft that I it was hand out to the
committee today so so he should tell the
Liquor Commission about this right those
those liquor filled candy
canes you know the comparison to liquor
I understand there's also there's an
except cep of liquor because it's been
legal for 90 years so the societ going
to people who have been adly against
cannabis and presenting this to them I I
I really think I understand some of us
are all willing to vote for virtually
any cannabis bill there's people like me
who are you should call a Swing Vote and
then some will vote against no matter
what it is you don't see that debate
with alcohol so the comparison to
alcohol I keep hearing it I think it's
not not the best way to go about things
okay um
no more than 15 stores right that that's
very clearly spelled out retailers to
consult The Liquor Commission on Final
price it it the way I have it drafted is
that liquor ultimate control the price
is to basically prevent the market
manipulation from happening in someone
going up under as a result someone
operates at a loss for a very long time
because when that you have that over
Supply what's being sold for $150 or
$200 or whatever it is all of a sudden
it's $30 or
$50 and not everyone's going to be able
to survive that what do you do about
that and I'm not sure why that's been
happening in other the states it doesn't
seem like a good idea so the idea was if
that happened you can they can step in
and stop it and again that's to protect
the
franchisee um no more than one road mile
from
schools if it's a city or town under
50,000 um and half mile if it's over
50,000 that is in there and that is that
is part of the compromise okay um that
the Liquor Commission would have the
final say on
locations yes and keep in mind too
that's that's very common when it comes
to approving a
franchise the franchisor likes to know
where you're going to put the store sure
the Liquor Commission would do all
advertising
to the extent that any advertising would
be permitted uh I understand that the
Commerce version has no advertising
period uh there is advertising is
extremely limited no Billboards no
mailings no TV commercials but to have
zero advertising we kind of left it open
to maybe have stuff inside perhaps the
state liquor store so we want to have
maybe some promotional but when I say
limited but whatever that is it would be
performed by The Liquor Commission
not the individual franchisee and but of
course any franchisee would benefit from
that
advertising no lobbying we've talked
about that one
yeah it's on the last page tucked away
but so I don't want to think I tried to
hide it yeah okay that um the product is
tested for potency so I guess maybe some
kind of standards of potency yeah so I
believe both both versions have have
that we were big on having private the
testing be done by a private company and
the reason for that when it comes to
dealing with narcotics or other control
drugs our state lab are you know they're
behind schedule when it comes to testing
on criminal prosecutions I'm talking
Fentanyl and those those cases you so
you don't really want to get that mixed
up and mess with that because someone
who's uh representing people charged
with offenses you can uh beat a case if
you don't if the state doesn't hurry up
so we don't want to cause a un intended
consequence sure and the franchise fee
being something between 10 and
15% I what's in what's in what I
provided or was provided today is 12 and
a half understand that when this
franchise model was first presented in
the
commission the number was 15 but it was
we didn't really discuss that we figured
that would be a
great assignment for Ways and Means or
Finance but we just we were focusing
more on just putting the model together
so it really hasn't been a discussion on
what it should be um I know that the
commer version lowered it to 10 but
again I I'm not sure that there was
really what went into that I will say by
including the therapeutic products as
part of the the fee it is justifiable to
maybe lower it from 15 to 12 and a half
I kind of looked at that as a 15 20%
market share that's where it kind of 12
and a half came into play but the lower
you make that you know I support that
but there needs to be a justification
for an
explanation I mean it needs to be
studied so if it should be lowered I
would hope uh there would be some reason
why all right so now let's talk so
that's my whole list here so let's talk
about so all that's in here right that
sounds like yeah okay it's it's in there
I hope everyone likes it all right I
understand let's talk about money um
because what's not on this list is my
main issue which is all the automatic
spending right there's there's most of
it goes to education but then there's
10% for the drug and
alcohol abuse thing there's 5% for this
there's there's you know Etc
um and I hate all that automatic
spending I think as a finance committee
we should decide what our spending is
going to be every every two years right
and um and we rightsize all of these
different things and we trade them off
against each other and so on but when
you put in when you put in automatic
numbers like are in all of these bills
then that becomes the base for people
who receive that money and they think
you know if we ever cut it which we can
do in house bill to right in House Bill
two we can always say well
notwithstanding RSA one whatever you
know we'll make it the you know you
don't get your 10% you get a million or
whatever you get but um all those people
people start to whine and say wait a
minute you're not fully funding me you
know because I supposed to get 10% you
know and um and so I'd like to avoid all
that stuff and just say you know
personally I'd like to say 100% goes to
education or something like that right
so so first of all the future legislator
can do make all the changes they want so
whatever's in here and they change it
you know it's it's what it is um I'm
glad you brought the funding issue I one
there's some talk about the governor's
Commission on alcohol and then there's
this this creates another commission
where it's um the substance abuse I'm
not sure if I'm titling those correctly
but it's right at the beginning on page
two one and two um there's some thought
that you really don't need to have those
separated the commission the Attorney
General recommended doing that simply
not to mix the funds together I that's
not a deal breaker for anyone that I can
understand it would be less government
operates if you just had one fund now
with that being said uh what I presented
75% it it would offset the liability for
the Statewide education property
tax um that's 75% of it 10% would go to
the substance use prevention treatment
and Recovery Fund that's obviously the
fund that could just be become the join
with the governor's commission 5% be
allocated to Public Safety
agencies and 5% shall be dis spers to
the Department of uh DHHS for services
for behavioral behavioral health there's
even some overlap there where um you
know the govern's commission does some
of that already so again hence why I
value the input from a finance committee
on a bill that has a good chance of
making over the finish line so I support
that if you want to put more into the
swept I'm certainly not going to make a
make any well I'm asking the question a
slightly different way does any of your
14 votes depend on HHS getting this or
you know
whatever well getting that you see what
I mean I haven't pulled that exact
question but I will say one of the I I
did skip over the the provision
involving some of the legal aid
issues and I know there was a social
justice Fund in here that had some very
vague undefined terms and I'm trying to
figure out where exactly would this be
used and how would that be used and what
communities does it go to we we have
artificial undefined terms describing
communities that I don't even know where
to begin with that that's that's a long
conversation for another day the
compromise with that to take that out
was the
um some of the money for the um legal
aid I think that that's that's
helpful so I would recommend you know
perhaps keeping that in there okay uh
some people may get upset and go back to
the social justice fund yeah I I the
name sounds great but the application
that doesn't really line up with any
other legal terms that work under
statute anywhere else thank
you further
questions sorry no no go ahead I thought
you were going to wrap it up no um when
representative Maguire was going through
the governor's requirements he talked
about um public
smoking uh I'm not sure he had an
opinion on the misdemeanor
classification do want to do your votes
rise and fall on your classification of
the misdemeanor for second and third
offense some of them
do and and when I say that I I hear a
lot about what everyone's talking about
would get signed to law remember it has
to make it to his desk and if it doesn't
make it to the Des his desk then it's
all it's not going to matter I know if
you left that a violation you're
definitely going to lose my vot making
it a second offense that puts into a
misdemeanor I what I wanted was the
first offense and if you listen to the
debate in the commission it was about an
hour long about just arguing back and
forth so after that that is a compromise
so I think that's pretty reasonable
because it's like I said whoever is
smoking cannabis in public I assume they
know it's illegal when they're doing it
and they're doing it to the point that
that it's so egregious
and I had family members in New York
City this past weekend they were
complaining all you can do is smell
cannabis my family we go to Old Orchard
Beach every summer I'm pushing a
stroller and all I can do is smell
cannabis I had was in Salem
Massachusetts going going to a
courthouse in the parking garage about
8:30 in the morning going down the
stairway trying to the elevator is a
little slow in that parking garage the
whole thing is and I'm worried now I'm
going to smell like this walking into a
courthouse so everywhere every state
that has legalized it it is people
walking down the street smoking it and
it's without consequence violation
offenses are really something that's I
yes it's a crime but the enforceability
has to make sense too there is is it
viable to enforce these penalties if
it's going to just be a violation
violation
violation what are we doing and then
repeat
offenders they didn't learn the first
time
so I I was looking for the fiscal note
out of curiosity and I see it's about
$18.2 million for the first two years
it's identical to what was in the
Cannabis report I guess on page 42 in
your 37 so I guess those numbers we know
it's about double what the uh Commerce
Commission or Commerce committee's uh
fiscal note was I I haven't done a side
by side of that there was some talk
about where that funding would come from
and I was speaking with one of my
colleagues in the Senate and it was the
thought was could it come from the
liquor fund versus the general fund
again that's something I think would be
best I would refer to this committee
what I would say that if is any money
taken out of the general fund I did put
a provision in here that that money
would be paid back uh by whatever
Revenue once it's once it's made I think
it's appropriate to return that to the
general fund it may not be in the first
year or two but if they do draw 18
million it should be paid back with with
Revenue yeah some of us have talked
about it whether it should be liquor
money or because it all goes to the same
pot but because this is a little
different maybe it should directly come
from liquor and not come out of the
general fund like $18.2 million out of
the general fund maybe it should come
out of liquor which would lessen what
comes back to the general fund but it's
that mixing of the money so maybe it
should come out of liquor initially and
I don't I don't believe that's a deal
breaker with anyone so that's and again
that's that's why I value the input of a
finance committee looking at this I've
never sat on a finance committee as
member of the house so right remember
you a good chair of Criminal Justice
though in the old days I appreciate the
kind words no thanks so much uh
representative sweet
no thank you Mr chairman thank you
senator for being here just to summarize
this compromised package can get at
least 13 votes in the senate in your
opinion and get to someone important St
by my count it's more than 13
but the other one I think I I believe
the count is 10 I I again that's that's
when I last did that was about a month
ago so thank
you again great to see you and thank you
and we'll be meeting next week the time
will be in the calendar but we'll look
forward to seeing you again thank
you all right at that we'll wrap this up
and we again we'll meet on this everyone
will have a chance to look at the new
Amendment and we'll discuss it I happen
to have uh four more copies Oh I thought
and representative McGuire will probably
have an amendment for us next
week what's that I
have
e